[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
>> WELCOME TO THE GAME OF THE
WEEK.
BIG -- BACK IN 1977, THAT IS THE
SITE IN BUFFALO, WHO WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT?
GAMES IN DUNEDIN AND BUFFALO FOR
THE BLUE JAYS.
THE GOOD NEWS FOR THE BLUE JAYS,
THEY ARE WINNING.
THEY OUTSCORED OPPONENTS 62-20,
LEAVING BASEBALL, POINT 452
SLUGGING PERCENTAGE IN 2021.
ADNAN VIRK AND BUCK SHOWALTER.
YOU STRIKE ME AS THE KIND OF GUY
WHO GOT TO THE PARK EARLY.
>> I CAN FORGET A LOT OF THINGS.
BUT BE THERE ON TIME.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF GOOD STUFF.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT SHOHEI
OHTANI.
11 HOME RUNS IN 13 GAMES, 2.58
E.R.A., EVERYONE KEEPS ASKING
HAVE YOU SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS?
>> I DROVE THE BUS TO THE YARD.
IT HAS CAUGHT ME OFF GUARD.
EARLY ON I THOUGHT HE COULDN'T
CONTINUE TO DO IT.
I HOPE FOR BASEBALL HE CAN, BUT
I HOPE EVERYBODY TAKES A STEP
BACK AND REALIZES HOW SPECIAL
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS.
HE WILL LEAD OFF TODAY, LET'S
FACE IT, HE CAN PINCH RUN.
THE CHALLENGE FOR JOE IS THE
ROTATION.
WILL HE PITCHED THE FIFTH OR
SIXTH DAY?
HOW MUCH WILL HE THROW?
AND THE WAY THAT AFFECTS THE
OTHER STARTERS.
IT IS A SMALL PROBLEM TO HAVE.
ADNAN: ANGELS AND YANKEES ON MLB
NETWORK, THE GAME HERE IS BLUE
JAYS AND MARINERS.
YESTERDAY, THE BLUE JAYS
OFFENSE, BACK WITH A BANG.
>> BO BICHETTE.
HITS IT HIGH AND DEEP INTO LEFT
CENTER.
IT'S GONE.
BO BICHETTE WITH A THREE RUN
HOME RUN.
SWUNG ON AND DRIVEN DEEP.
IT IS A FAIR BALL RIGHT OFF THE
FOUL POLE.
>> THAT IS HIS 19TH LONG BALL OF
THE YEAR.
HOW DO YOU HIT THAT BALL?
ADNAN: BLUE JAYS WIN 9-3.
THERE ARE THE A.L. EAST
STANDINGS.
THE BLUE JAYS ARE 4.5 BACK OF
THE RAYS, WHO ARE TWO BACK OF
BOSTON.
THE 1-2-3 PUNCH IS GREAT.
I WATCHED THE GAME LAST NIGHT
AND YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
TREVOR SEMIEN HOME RUN, HOW
QUICKLY HE GOT IT OUT IN FRONT.
BUCK: I SAW OHTANI HIT THE LINE
DRIVE THAT LEFT THE PARK AND
HALF A SECOND.
HE HAD THE KNOB SO FAR, THAT
BALL IS OFF THE WHITE LINE ON
THE INNER HALF.
YOU CAN'T HIT IT WITHOUT
BREAKING A THUMB OR YOUR BAT AND
HE KEPT IT FAIR.
YOU HAVE TO PULL YOUR BARREL
INSIDE TO GET THE BALL ON THE
HITTING SURFACE.
ADNAN: FOR THE BLUE JAYS, THEY
HAVE ASPIRATIONS OF THE
PLAYOFFS.
YOU LOOK AT SEMIEN AND BICHETTE
AND VLAD JR., PITCHING HAS BEEN
GOOD.
DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE ENOUGH TO
BE A PLAYOFF TEAM?
BUCK: I DO.
I TELL FANS, WATCH THE LOSS
COLUMN.
THEY ARE ONLY FIVE GAMES BACK.
WHAT A GREAT STORY IT WOULD BE
IF THEY WERE TO OPEN UP THE
BALLPARK AND IT IS FOR THE
PLAYOFFS?
CAN YOU IMAGINE, THEM GOING BACK
TO TORONTO FOR THE PLAYOFFS?
IT IS A GREAT BASEBALL CITY
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY ARE DOING
WELL.
I THINK THEY HAVE A CHANCE.
ONE THING THAT JUMPS OUT AT ME,
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY AND THE
PEOPLE TO MAKE THE BIG TRADE.
THEY HAVE THE PEOPLE WHO COULD
BRING BACK -- SOME CLUBS DON'T
HAVE THE PEOPLE TO BRING BACK
THOSE PLAYERS.
ADNAN: IF YOU CAN MAKE A MOVE,
OWNERSHIP BELIEVES IN THEM.
VERY ENTERTAINING TEAM, GREAT
OFFENSE.
THE MARINERS NEVER GET ENOUGH
LOVE.
LONGEST DROUGHT IN BASEBALL.
HOW DO YOU ASSESS THEIR CHANCES?
BUCK: EVERY YEAR THERE IS A TEAM
THAT EVERYBODY GOES TO SLEEP ON
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU GO, THEY
ARE RIGHT THERE.
DON'T LET THEM GET A SNIFF,
ESPECIALLY A YOUNG TEAM.
WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE THEY CAN WIN
THOSE GAMES, I THINK THEY ARE
18-7 IN ONE RUN GAMES.
THEY ARE A TEAM THAT IS UNDER
THE RADAR IN A NICE AMBUSH SPOT.
DON'T THINK, THERE ARE THE ONE
RUN GAMES.
THE RED SOX ARE BEHIND THEM.
THIS PERPETUATES CONFIDENCE IN A
YOUNG TEAM, WHEN THEY KNOW THEY
CAN GET INTO CRUNCH TIME LATE IN
THE GAME AND CLOSE IT OUT NOT
ONLY PHYSICALLY BUT MENTALLY.
ADNAN: THEY HAVE THE FOURTH
EASIEST REMAINING SCHEDULE AND
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
THAT PLAYS A PART.
THE TRAVEL CAN WEAR ON YOU BUT
IF YOU ARE FACING TEAMS BELOW
.500, THAT HELPS.
BUCK: AND THOSE TEAMS HAVE TO
TRAVEL TO YOU.
IT WEARS ON YOU GOING TO
OAKLAND, SEATTLE, ANAHEIM BACK
AND FORTH.
ADNAN: TY FRANCE AND J.P.
CRAWFORD HAVING GOOD OFFENSIVE
SEASONS.
A GUY WHO HAS BEEN WORTH IT,
MARCUS SEMIEN.
BRIAN KENNY TAKES A LOOK AT THE
IMPACT OF MARCUS.
>> GOING INTO THIS YEAR, ONE OF
THE BIGGEST SUBPLOTS OF THE
SEASON, THE SUPER LAST OF
SHORTSTOPS ABOUT TO HIT THE
MARKET.
EVEN WITH FRANCISCO LINDOR
SIGNING AN EXTENSION WITH THE
METS, THERE WERE FOUR SUPERSTAR
SHORTSTOPS IN THEIR CONTRACT
YEAR.
SINCE THE START OF THE SEASON,
MAKE THAT FIVE.
MARCUS SEMIEN IS FOR REAL.
HE SIGNED A ONE-YEAR DEAL WITH
THE BLUE JAYS TO HELP
REESTABLISH HIS VALUE.
HE IS PLAYING SECOND BASE
BECAUSE BO BICHETTE IS THE
FRANCHISE SHORTSTOP BUT SEMIEN
IS SLUGGING .533 WITH PLUS
FIELDING AT HIS NEW POSITION.
HE IS PLUS FIVE IN OUTS ABOVE
AVERAGE THIS SEASON AT SECOND
BASE AFTER BEING BELOW AVERAGE
THE PREVIOUS TWO SEASONS AT
SHORT.
THIS YEAR, COMBINED WITH HIS
MONSTROUS 2019, CHANGES THE VIEW
OF WHO HE IS.
HERE IS THE BIG FIVE OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
LAST YEAR WAS A SHORT SEASON.
THE TOTAL WAR AND O.P.S.+ OWING
BACK TO THE START OF 2019,
MARCUS SEMIEN IS NUMBER ONE IN
WAR, NUMBER ONE.
TREVOR STORY IS NEXT, JAVY BAEZ
IS HITTING JUST ABOVE LEAGUE
AVERAGE.
CORDY SEAGER -- COREY SEAGER CAN
HIT BUT HE IS OUT.
CARLOS CORREA HAVING A BIG
SEASON, REESTABLISHING HIS VALUE
AS THE BEST HITTER.
HIS O.P.S.+ IS NOT FAR ABOVE
SEMIEN.
DURABILITY FOR CORREA IS AN
ISSUE.
AGE IS A FACTOR.
CARLOS CORREA IS THE YOUNGEST.
HE WILL BE 27 NEXT YEAR.
SEAGER WILL BE 28.
STORY AND BAEZ WILL BE 29.
SEMIEN WILL BE 31 SO THAT WILL
AFFECT THE TOTAL MONEY.
THERE IS ANOTHER GROUP OF
QUALITY SHORTSTOPS ON THE MARKET
NEXT YEAR, CRAWFORD, SIMMONS AND
IGLESIAS.
CRAWFORD HAVING A BIG YEAR,
SLUGGING OVER .500 WITH PLUS
DEFENSE AT HIS AGE.
THEY ARE IN THEIR 30'S.
THEY COULD BE GOOD SIGNINGS.
THERE IS A BIG FIVE WITH MARCUS
SEMIEN, BUT EIGHT STARTING
SHORTSTOPS ALL ON THE MARKET AT
ONE TIME.
ADNAN: THANK YOU.
AS WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ALL-STAR BALLOT WATCH, SEMIEN IS
KNOWN AS A SHORTSTOP.
HE IS AT SECOND BASE AND HAS THE
EDGE OVER ALTUVE AND LEMAHIEU TO
BE THE STARTING SECOND BASEMAN
AT THE ALL-STAR GAME IN DENVER.
THERE IS NO QUESTION, ONE YEAR
DEAL FOR THIS GUY, HE HAS
SOMETHING TO PROVE.
IT HAS WORKED OUT WELL FOR
TORONTO AND HIM.
BUCK: WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
QUALITY INDIVIDUALS AROUND
BASEBALL UNDERNEATH THE
CLUBHOUSE, HE IS A NAME THAT
COMES UP.
HE IMPACTS THE CLUB MORE THAN
JUST STATISTICALLY.
HE BRINGS A CERTAIN INTELLIGENT
APPROACH TO BASEBALL AND HE IS
VERY APPROACHABLE, SOMEBODY THAT
MAKES HIS TEAMMATES BETTER.
YOU CAN'T QUANTIFY THAT.
ADNAN: ATOP THE LINEUP WITH VLAD
JR. AND BO BICHETTE, THOSE GUYS
HAVE BEEN IN SYNC.
WE ARE BUILDING UP TO THE BLUE
JAYS AND MARINERS.
WHO WILL WIN TONIGHT'S GAME, THE
MARINERS OR BLUE JAYS?
THE PITCHING MATCHUP, STEVEN
MATZ IS BACK FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
HE HAS A 4.26 E.R.A., FACING
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD, FIVE POINT 69
E.R.A..
STEVEN MATZ MAKING HIS FIRST
START SINCE JUNE 12 AFTER
TESTING POSITIVE FOR COVID.
STILL TO COME, NIAGARA FALLS, ON
A HOT DAY LIKE THIS, COULD USE A
LITTLE DEPTH.
DIP. BE CAREFUL WHAT
YOU WISH FOR.
BUFFALO, THE SITE OF THE
MARINERS AND THE BLUE JAYS.
THE GAME IS COMING UP IN ABOUT
20 MINUTES.
>> A SWING AND A DRIVE.
HIGH FLY BALL TO LEFT FIELD AND
THIS BALL IS GONE.
ANOTHER GUERRERO HOME RUN.
>> THIS IS THE KIND OF HITTER HE
IS.
>> ONE HAS COME INTO SCORE.
HE HITS IT HIGH AND THEY ARE TO
LEFT.
THIS BALL IS GOING TO GO.
GET OUT OF HERE.
HOME RANDALL RANDAL GRICHUK, THE
THIRD HOME RUN FOR THE BLUE JAYS
THIS AFTERNOON, THREE RUN HOMER
FOR RANDAL.
>> GUERRERO GOES AFTER THE FIRST
PITCH.
IT'S GONE.
HOME RUN GUERRERO.
HE IS 2-2 ON TWO PITCHES.
SWING AND A HIGH FLY BALL TO
LEFT FIELD.
THIS BALL IS GOING TO GO.
GONE, TWO RUN HOME RUN FOR
VLADDY THE FIRST PITCH AGAIN.
>> FASTEST IN TEAM HISTORY TO
HIT WHEN HE FIVE HOME RUNS IN 74
GAMES.
>> HERE IS ANOTHER ONE.
BACK TO BACK HOME RUNS.
SWING AT A DRIVE.
THIS BALL IS DEEP.
IF IT IS FAIR, IT IS GONE.
GRAND SLAM HOME RUN ON THE FIRST
PITCH FOR GURRIEL.
♪
ADNAN: YOU ARE WATCHING THE
MARINERS AND THE BLUE JAYS.
THIS IS OUR GAME OF THE WEEK
PREGAME SHOW.
TODAY'S BROADCAST IS POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
♪
ADNAN: TIME FOR OUR CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT.
IT IS A PLEASURE TO BRING IN
FIVE POINTS VINCE.
ROOTED IN SPORTS INFO YOU DIDN'T
KNOW YOU NEEDED, GENERALLY
LIGHTHEARTED BUT SOMETIMES
SERIOUS TAKES, COVERS EVERYTHING
FROM STADIUM REVIEWS TODD STATS.
A HUGE METS FAN.
FAVORITE BASEBALL MOMENT, THE
METS BEAT THE PHILLIES IN JULY
1990 AFTER THE PHILLIES SCORED
SIX RUNS IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
LINEUP.
-- IN THE BOTTOM OF THE NINTH.
THANKS FOR GIVING US A FEW
MINUTES.
TELL US THE TYPE OF BASEBALL
CONTENT YOU POST.
TODAY'S GAME IS A SPECIAL
STATCAST BROADCAST.
WHAT HE'S YOUR FAVORITE STAT?
>> ANY TIME THE STATCAST IS
RUNNING, I LOVE THE EXIT
VELOCITY STATS.
WHEN YOU SEE A GUY LIKE MOOKIE
BETTS THROWING THE BALL ACROSS
THE FIELD AND THEY TELL YOU THE
EXACT MILES PER HOUR HE THREW
IT, THAT BLOWS MY MIND THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY SEE THAT.
IN TERMS OF A REGULAR STAT, I
THINK WAR IS MY FAVORITE.
ADNAN: IT ACTUALLY INVOLVES
DEFENSE SO I'M WITH YOU.
YOU ARE A HUGE METS FAN.
DO THE METS NEED TO MAKE A MOVE
NOW?
SOME OF THESE OFFENSIVE NUMBERS
ARE BRUTAL.
CAN THEY STAY THE COURSE AS
CURRENTLY CONSTITUTED?
>> I THINK THEY COULD ACQUIRE A
SHAMAN TO GET EVERYONE HEALTHY.
THAT WOULD BE THE BEST MOVE FOR
THEM.
THEY HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB.
THEY HAVE BUILT A PLAYOFF LEVEL
ROSTER, BUT THE GUYS HAVE TO GET
HEALTHY AND THERE HAS BEEN SO
MUCH BAD LUCK.
PAUL R -- PILLAR GETTING HIT IN
THE FACE.
IF THEY CAN GET HEALTHY -- I DO
THINK THEY ADD A STARTER AT SOME
POINT BEFORE THE DEADLINE
BECAUSE THEY ARE THIN THERE, BUT
EVERYWHERE ELSE IS FINE.
ADNAN: CARLOS CARRASCO HOPES TO
COME BACK IN AUGUST, MAYBE NO
SYNDERGAARD.
THE TOP THREE STARTERS HAVE BEEN
TREMENDOUS.
THE BLUE JAYS ARE OUR YOUTUBE
GAME TONIGHT.
WHO DO YOU THINK EMERGES AS A
CHAMP?
THE BABY BLUE JAYS TRYING TO
MAKE A PUSH.
>> THAT DIVISION IS WIDE OPEN.
YOU HAVE FOUR TEAMS THAT REALLY,
ANYONE COULD WIN.
I HEAR MORE ABOUT HOW BAD THE
YANKEES ARE THAN HOW GOOD THE
RED SOX HAVE BEEN.
THE RED SOX HAVE QUIETLY LED THE
DIVISION.
I THINK THEY HAVE THE STUFF TO
TAKE IT BUT I'M REALLY EXCITED
TO SEE THE GAME TODAY AND SEE
WHAT THE BLUE JAYS DO.
THEY COULD MAKE A PUSH.
NOBODY SHOULD COUNT OUT THE RAYS
.
HONESTLY, AND THIS HURTS TO SAY,
THE YANKEES WILL PROBABLY BE
FINE.
ADNAN: YANKEES PROBABLY HAVE ONE
MORE PUSH.
GARY SANCHEZ HAS HAD A GREAT
MONTH, AARON JUDGE IS AN
ALL-STAR.
IT IS A MATTER OF THE OTHER GUYS
STEPPING UP.
FIVE POINTS VIDS, TELL US ABOUT
YOUR CHANNEL.
>> I USED TO DO LIST TYPE
VIDEOS, LIKE EVERY MLB'S TEAM'S
WORST BLOW OUT.
THEN I GOT INTO STADIUM CONTENT
AND CRITIQUING STADIUMS AND A
POPULAR SERIES I DO IS LOOKING
AT A STADIUM AND PERSONIFYING IT
AND TAKING IT THROUGH ITS LIFE
AS ITS JOURNEY AS A BUILDING
ITSELF.
PEOPLE GEEK OUT FOR STADIUM
CONTENT.
I LOVE OLD BALLPARKS, NEW
BALLPARKS, IT IS AMAZING TO LOOK
AT ONE AND SEE HOW WELL
ENGINEERED AND AMAZING THEY ARE.
ADNAN: I WAS AT CITI FIELD ON
FRIDAY, GOT CAUGHT IN THE
LINCOLN TUNNEL.
A PARK I APPRECIATE.
WE KNOW ABOUT SHEA STADIUM.
YOUR FAVORITE METS MOMENT, 1990
-- I THOUGHT YOU WOULD MENTION
DOC OR MOOKIE WILSON 1990
AGAINST THE PHILLIES.
WHAT WAS IT ABOUT THAT GAME?
>> IN THE TOP OF THE NINTH, THE
METS LED 9-0 AND IN THE TOP OF
THE NIGHT, THE METS SCORED THEIR
10TH RUN.
MY DAD LOOKED AT ME, I'M 13
YEARS OLD AND HE SAID, THE METS
NEEDED THAT RUN.
I SHOT HIM A LOOK.
IT WAS 10:30 AT THE TIME AND THE
PHILLIES PUT SIX RUNS UP AND
EVERYBODY HAD LEFT BUT THE
THOUSAND PHILLY FANS THAT WERE
STILL THERE AND THEY WERE THE
LOUDEST I HAVE EVER HEARD.
I REMEMBER COVERING MY EARS
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO FACE
THE REALITY OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
JOHN FRANCO, WHO HAS BEEN ON THE
YOUTUBE BROADCAST, CAME IN WITH
THE BASES LOADED NOBODY OUT,
THREW ONE PITCH, GOT A DOUBLE
PLAY AND THE NEXT GUY LINED OUT
TO THE SHORTSTOP AND I LOOKED AT
MY DAD LIKE, DON'T EVER DO THAT
AGAIN.
ADNAN: STILL LOVE JOHN FRANCO.
IT IS INTERESTING WHEN YOU LOOK
AT YOUR PASSION FOR THE GAME
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE METS, WE
SAW A CLIP FROM YOUR CHANNEL.
WHY ARE THE METS TRASH WHEN
DEGROM PITCHES?
>> THE ANSWER?
>> THEY HAVE GOTTEN, AS SOON AS
I PUBLISHED THAT THEY GOT
BETTER.
AT THE TIME WHEN I PUBLISHED
THAT VIDEO, THEY WERE SOMETHING
LIKE 38 AND 41 WHEN HE STARTED.
I CAN OWN -- I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE EXACT NUMBER BUT THEY GOT
BETTER.
HE IS AN AMAZING PITCHER.
I THINK HE SHOULD BE 30-0, 20
5-0.
WHEN HE STARTS THEY SHOULD WIN.
HE IS AN AMAZING PITCHER.
THEY HAVE DONE BETTER SO MAYBE I
ENCOURAGED THEM TO IMPROVE.
ADNAN: I THINK IT WAS YOUR VIDEO
THAT GOT THEM ROLLING.
HAVEN'T SEEN A GUY LIKE DEGROM
IN YEARS.
ADAM, FIVE POINT VIDS, CONTINUED
SUCCESS AND LET'S GO METS.
>> LET'S GO METS.
LGM.
ADNAN: GREAT STUFF THERE.
TAKING OFF THINGS WITH THE BLUE
JAYS AND MARINERS.
BRIAN KENNY, SARAH LANGS, MARK
DEROSA, IT WILLN AWESOME
BROADCAST AND IT IS COMING UP
MOMENTARILY.
THESE TEAMS ARE ROLLING.
BUCK SHOWALTER'S PICKS TO
CLICK'S NEXT.
>> HIGH FLY BALL, LONG RUN,
MAKES THE PLAY AND THAT WILL DO
IT.
THEY GET THE BIG MAN.
5-1 MARINERS.
>> HIGH BREAKING BALL, KITTED A
LONG WAY TOWARDS THE GAP, IT'S
GONE.
TWO RUN HOMER.
>> THE 2-2.
SWUNG ON, LIFTED TO RIGHT FIELD,
THIS IS HIT WELL, BACK IS GARCIA
LOOKING UP AND IT'S GONE.
INTO THE MARINERS BULLPEN.
LUIS TORRENS HAS STRUCK AGAIN.
>> J.P. CRAWFORD WITH THE
HARPOON PULLS IT BACK.
>> THE WELL-TIMED JUMP INTO THE
WEBBING OF HIS GLOVE.
>> FLY BALL.
CAN'T SEE IT BECAUSE IT IS OUT
OF HERE.
1-0 MARINERS.
ANOTHER ONE.
THE MARINERS HAVE A 3-2 LEAD.
A TWO HOME RUN DAY FOR TAYLOR.
>> OUT TO CENTER.
WAY BACK, GONE.
THERE IS HOME RUN NUMBER 7000 IN
CLUB HISTORY.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
♪
ADNAN: YOU WERE WATCHING THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW.
TODAY'S STATCAST BROADCAST IS
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
TIME FOR THE PICKS TO CLICK
PRESENTED BY FANDUEL SPORTS
BOOK.
LOVE PUTTING MY MANAGER ON THE
SPOT.
I FEEL LIKE I WILL SWAY THE JURY
BEFORE I ASK BUT VLAD GUERRERO,
IF HE WINS THE TRIPLE CROWN,
AVERAGE, HOME RUNS, R.B.I.,
SHOULD HE WIN THE A.L. M.V.P.
OVER OHTANI?
BUCK: THINK ABOUT THE WAYS
OHTANI IMPACTS THE CLUB.
THEY CAN ABOUT HOW HE HELPS HIS
TEAMMATES.
HE CAN DEFEND, HE CAN STEAL A
BASE, HIT A HOME RUN, HIT FOR AN
AVERAGE, PLAY RIGHT FIELD.
VLADDY IS A GREAT HITTER AND
HAVING A BIG YEAR BUT THIS GUY
IMPACTS HIS TEAM TOO MUCH.
ADNAN: WHAT IF VLAD JR.'S STATS
WERE SO ASTRONOMICALLY BETTER
THAN OHTANI?
MEANING AVERAGE, HOME RUNS,
R.B.I. BY A DEPRECIABLE
DIFFERENCE?
BUCK: I THINK IT WILL BE CLOSE.
ALMOST PHILOSOPHICAL FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE VOTING.
YOU STEP BACK AND SAY WHAT IS
HARDER TO DO, WHAT HE DID OR
WHAT THIS GUY DID?
THAT IS EASY, BUT I THINK THERE
WILL BE GREAT DEBATE.
ADNAN: GREAT TO SEE VLAD JR.
BACK AFTER ALL THE HYPE.
HE WAS ALL RIGHT TO BEGIN HIS
CAREER BUT HE HAS BEEN
SENSATIONAL.
THE ODDS TO WIN M.V.P., OHTANI
-135, VLAD JR. PLUS 120 AND
AFTER THAT, IT IS RIDICULOUS.
PLUS 4000, PLUS 5000.
THIS IS A TWO HORSE RACE.
SHOHEI OHTANI, VLAD JR. YOUR
HEAD-TO-HEAD.
BLUE JAYS, DO THEY HAVE A LEGIT
SHOT OF WINNING THE A.L. EAST?
THEY HAVE TO CATCH THE RAYS AND
RED SOX.
BUCK: THOSE FOUR CLUBS WILL BEAT
UP ON EACH OTHER IN THIS
DIVISION.
ALL THOSE GUYS, THOSE TEAMS
AREN'T GOING TO FOLD.
WHEN TWO OR THREE TEAMS ARE OUT
OF IT YOU DON'T LIKE IT BUT
TORONTO WAS ONLY FIVE BACK IN
THE LOSS COLUMN.
I LOVE THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE A
DEAL.
I THINK THEY WILL BE IN THE HUNT
THE WHOLE WAY.
ADNAN: THEY ARE THE FIRST TEAM
TO MAKE A MOVE, PICKING UP
CIMBER FOR THE BULLPEN.
BUCK: DICKERSON IS A GOOD WHAT
IF.
THEY WILL FIND PLENTY OF PLACES
TO PUT HIM.
IT ONLY MAKES THEM TOUGHER AND
GIVES THEM ABILITY TO MANEUVER
AND MAKE OTHER TRADES.
HE LETS THEM TRADE FROM DEPTH.
ADNAN: TOM VERDUCCI SAID THEY
NEEDED A LEFT-HANDED BAT.
WE HAVE SEEN GRICHUK STEPPING UP
FOR SPRINGER AND CIMBER IS IN
THE BULLPEN.
OVER-UNDER RUNS SCORED TONIGHT,
SHEFFIELD AGAINST MATZ.
BUCK: ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND,
SEATTLE IS SUSCEPTIBLE.
THEY HAVE TO START FOUR
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS WHICH IS
UNHEARD OF.
USUALLY WITH A LEFT-HANDED
PITCHER, THEY HAVE GOOD NUMBERS
AGAINST LEFT-HANDED HITTERS.
I THINK IT WILL BE UNDER.
I KNOW EVERYBODY WILL SAY OVER
BUT BECAUSE OF THE LEFT ON LEFT,
I THINK IT MAY BE UNDER.
ADNAN: SHEFFIELD HAS STRUGGLED
BUT MATZ, WHO KNOWS.
GEORGE SPRINGER IS A GUY, HIGH
EXPECTATIONS, BIG CONTRACT, ONLY
HITTING .19 ZERO HIS FIRST SIX
GAMES BACK.
WILL HE PLAY HIMSELF INTO SHAPE?
BUCK: I THINK YOU TRUST THE
PEDIGREE AND THE BACKGROUND.
THERE IS NOT THAT MUCH FOCUS ON
HIM BECAUSE THEY HAVE SO MANY
DIFFERENT PIECES.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THE WHOLE
CLUB WAS WAITING ON HIM TO
PERFORM?
THAT IS A POSITIVE TO ME BECAUSE
I KNOW WHERE THAT WILL WIND UP.
HE WILL GET HIS.
WE WILL SEE IF ANYBODY --
EVERYBODY ELSE CAN MAINTAIN THAT
LEVEL.
ADNAN: THE BLUE JAYS TOP FIVE
OFFENSE WITHOUT SPRINGER.
BUCK: LIKE THE NATIONALS.
SOTO HASN'T FOUND HIS FOOTING
YET AND THEY ARE COMING ON BIG
TIME.
TORONTO, LET HIM GET GOING AND I
WOULDN'T WANT TO HAVE TO DEFEND
THEM.
ADNAN: THE NATIONALS ARE UP
THERE.
WE HAVEN'T REALLY SEEN THE BEST
OF JUAN SOTO.
SCHWARBER HAS BEEN RIDICULOUS.
TREA TURNER, HOW UNDERRATED IS
THIS GUY?
BUCK: HE AND MULLINS ARE
PROBABLY THE TWO BEST LEADOFF
HITTERS IN THE GAME.
THEY CAN DO SO MANY THINGS TO
BEAT YOU READING OFF.
ADNAN: WITH HIS KIND OF SPEED,
ABILITY TO ATTACK THE BALL, CAN
HIT FOR POWER.
YOU SEE THE NATIONALS, SINGLE,
DOUBLE, NOW THE HOME RUN FOR
TREA TURNER.
BUCK: THAT IS IN THE TWILIGHT
WITH THOSE SHADOWS.
THIS GOES IN THREE OR FOUR
DIFFERENT LIGHTINGS.
NO PROBLEM FOR HIM.
ADNAN: THE THIRD CYCLE OF TREA
TURNER'S CAREER WHICH TIES IN
MLB RECORD.
HE WAS A TRIPLE CHEYENNE HE GETS
IT.
-- A TRIPLE SHY AND HE GETS IT.
BUCK: HE GETS ABOUT HALF WAY TO
SECOND AND CAN RUN.
ADNAN: HE ACCELERATES AND THAT
IS TREA TURNER DOING TREA TURNER
THINGS.
HITS FOR THE CYCLE.
HERE COME THE NATIONALS, A TEAM
THAT RIGHT NOW IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE EAST, THE METS ARE THE
DIVISION LEADERS.
THEY HAVE BATTLED INJURIES.
YOU WONDER IF THE METS ARE
SUSTAINABLE.
I TELL YOU WHAT.
EVENTUALLY YOU HAVE TO SAY WE
ARE WHAT WE ARE.
I SAY THE BRAVES WILL BE THERE
BUT THEY ARE SUB .50 ZERO.
THEIR STARS HAVE UNDERACHIEVED.
THAT MEANS METS AND NATIONALS.
BUCK: THE GREAT THING ABOUT
BASEBALL, WE PLAY TOO MANY GAMES
FOR THERE TO BE CINDERELLA'S.
YOU ARE WHO YOU ARE.
IF YOU HAVE A WEAKNESS OR A
STRENGTH IT WILL SHOW UP.
ASSUME THE POSITION AND SEE WHAT
THE BOYS HAVE IN STORE FOR YOU.
THAT IS WHAT I USED TO SAY
WALKING DOWN THE RUNWAY.
ATLANTA WILL SEEK THEIR LEVEL.
ADNAN: WASHINGTON, A SLOW
STARTER BUT YOU FEEL CONFIDENT
ONCE THEY GET GOING, THEY WILL
BE GOOD.
BUCK: BEHIND CLOSED DOORS, YOU
GO -- I WISH THEY DIDN'T HAVE SO
MUCH CONFIDENCE IN ME.
ADNAN: I LIKE A LITTLE MORE
BALANCE.
BUCK: I NEED SOMETHING BACK FOR
THE CONFIDENCE.
ADNAN: THE NATS ARE SECOND IN
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE EAST.
THE QUESTION WE ASKED YOU, WHO
WILL WIN TONIGHT'S GAME?
A LOT OF BLUE JAYS FANS VOTING.
76% RIGHT NOW FOR THE GAME OF
THE WEEK POLL, BLUE JAYS HAVE
WON EIGHT OF THEIR LAST NINE
OVERALL AND LOOKING TO GO SIX
GAMES OVER .500 FOR THE SECOND
TIME THIS YEAR.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE MARINERS
AND TALK ABOUT THE BULLPEN.
THE BULLPENS CAN BE CYCLICAL.
THE NON-CLOSERS, WE SEE SEATTLE,
THEY LOVE TO MAKE TRADES.
FEELS LIKE FOR SEATTLE,
HOPEFULLY THEY HAVE A RECIPE
THEY CAN RELY ON.
BUCK: GOOD GENERAL MANAGERS
REALIZE NON-CLOSERS ARE
CYCLICAL.
THEY GO FROM A GOOD YEAR, THEN
BE CAREFUL.
GUYS THAT AREN'T THAT WAY ARE
CALLED CLOSERS.
THEY GRADUATE.
NON-CLOSER RELIEVERS, THEY ARE
NOT CONSISTENT SOMETIMES.
THERE IS A REASON THEY ARE DOWN
THERE AND YOU HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET BACK INTO
THE ROTATION OR BECOME A CLOSER.
THERE IS A REASON WHY THEY ARE
THERE.
IF YOU GET A LOT OF GUYS ON THE
RIGHT CYCLE, YOU HAVE A GOOD
BULLPEN.
ADNAN: WHEN A BULLPEN IS ROLLING
AND IT STARTS SLUMPING,
SEATTLE'S BULLPEN E.R.A. IN
JUNE, .547 -- 5.47.
BUCK: IF I HAD TO WATCH ONE
THING FOR ONE GAME TO TELL ME IF
A MANAGER OR PITCHING COACH
KNOWS WHAT THEY WERE DOING I
WOULD WATCH THE BULLPEN.
IF GUYS ARE UP AND NOT GETTING
IN THE GAME OR THEY GET UP IN
THE SECOND INNING, SIT FOR THREE
INNINGS AND GET UP AGAIN, NOT A
GOOD RECIPE.
WHEN CLUBS ARE GOING LIKE THAT
IT IS PROBABLY ABOUT THE USE.
ADNAN: YOU, BRUCE BOCHY, GUYS
WHO HAVE A GOOD FEEL -- IF I'M
GOING TO GET UP --
BUCK: THE PHONE RINGS AND NOBODY
HAS TO ANSWER, THEY KNOWS --
THEY KNOW WHO'S SPOT IT IS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE GOOD STARTING
PITCHING IT DOESN'T MATTER.
YOUR RELEASE TO COME IN AND GET
SOMEBODY OUT.
THE STARTER CAN GET THROUGH THE
SECOND INNING.
ADNAN: IN SEATTLE'S DIVISION,
THE ASTROS ARE GOOD.
THE ATHLETICS HAVE GOOD PLAYERS
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
FOR THE MARINERS YOU ARE
FIGHTING FOR A WILD-CARD SPOT.
BUCK: YOU ARE IN THE AMBUSH
POSITION.
THAT MENTALITY PLAYS WELL WITH
YOUNG PLAYERS ESPECIALLY IN ONE
RUN GAMES, BUT HOUSTON AND
OAKLAND AREN'T GOING ANYWHERE.
THEY PLAY EACH OTHER SO MANY
TIMES.
IT IS THERE FOR SEATTLE.
THEY CAN MAKE THIS INTERESTING.
THEY COULD MAKE A QUALITY TRADE.
ADNAN: THE COLDEST GAME EVER IN
TORONTO YOU EXPERIENCED?
BUCK: EXHIBITION, BEFORE THEY
HAD A DOME.
THE WORST ONE WAS CLEVELAND
OPENING DAY, 80000 AND THE OLD
PLACE AND STEINBRENNER PUT THE
SCOUT IN A BAD PLACE AND I WAS
THE I AM THE SKY.
I WAS IN THE UPPER DECK IN THE
RIGHT-FIELD CORNER IN THE FIFTH
INNING.
CANDIOTTI VERSUS TIM LEARY,
STARTS SNOWING.
I GOT MY SEARS AND ROEBUCK
TRENCHCOAT AND I'M WALKING BACK
TO THE CLUBHOUSE AND IT WAS
COLD.
ADNAN: THAT IS WHY THEY HAD A
DOME.
AN UPDATE, SPEAKING OF
CLEVELAND, CLEVELAND ROCKS.
JOSE RAMIREZ FACING THE TIGERS,
ANOTHER TEAM, THE INDIANS ARE
2.5 GAMES BACK IN THE CENTRAL.
BUCK: NOBODY NEEDS TO SAY WHAT
TYPE OF A MANAGER FRANCONA IS.
HE CAN TAKE HIS AND BEAT YOURS
AND TAKE YOURS AND BEAT HIS.
ADNAN: 1-0 RIGHT NOW FOR THE
INDIANS.
2.5 GAMES BACK OF THE WHITE SOX.
THE OFFENSE STEPPED UP.
REMEMBER AS HAVING A STRONG
SEASON.
-- RAMIREZ HAVING A STRONG
SEVERAL PEOPLE HAVE BEEN OUT.
HE ALWAYS HAS THE GUM WORKING,
EATS LIKE 12 POPSICLES PER GAME.
I WORRY ABOUT HIS DIET.
BUCK: HE WILL TAKE IT.
HE WILL BE FINE.
ADNAN: USED TO RIDE THE SCOOTER
IN THE PARK.
BUCK: DOESN'T TAKE HIMSELF
SERIOUSLY.
ADNAN: THAT IS A GREAT
COMPLEMENT.
FAVORITE STAT IN THE GAME,
ADVANCED STAT?
WAR, O.P.S., WHICH ONE?
BUCK: NONE OF THE ABOVE.
I WOULD SAY WAR.
ADNAN: MARINERS AND BLUE JAYS,
BRIAN KENNY AND COMPANY.
ENJOY THE GAME.
>> HERE IS THE PITCH.
♪
>> WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK.
THE BLUE JAYS AND THE MARINERS.
SHEFFIELD AND STEVEN MATZ.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> I GOT TO SLEEP IN.
>> A LOT OF CATEGORIES.
BUT THEY ARE GETTING IT DONE
WHEN IT COUNTS.
THEY ARE GETTING IT DONE WHEN IT
COUNTS IN THERE BIG THING IS
CONTROLLED HIS OWN.
GOOD AT-BATS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, PITCHING,
THE BULLPEN ON THAT FRONT.
>> THEY ARE A GOOD TEAM ON THE
FRONT.
-- ON THE FIELD.
THEY SWEPT THE RAYS IN A
FOUR-GAME SERIES NOT TOO FAR
BACK.
THE JAYS ARE A TEAM, WE THOUGHT
FUTURE SUPERSTARS.
SUPERSTARS HAPPENING NOW WITH
VLAD GUERRERO.
>> M.V.P. CANDIDATE, WE KNOW
WHAT OHTANI IS DOING BUT VLAD
JR. IS HAVING A TRADITIONAL
M.V.P. SEASON, AND SOMETHING
THAT STOOD OUT HIS HE IS PLATE
DISCIPLINE.
HE IS OWNING THE ZONE.
I LOVE THAT BECAUSE HIS FAMILY
NAME, WE DON'T ASSOCIATE WITH
PLATE DISCIPLINE.
IT WORKED FOR HIS FATHER BUT IT
IS INCREDIBLE THAT THAT IS WHAT
HAS PUT VLAD JR. ON THE NEXT
LEVEL.
>> GUERRERO, GURRIEL, BICHETTE,
BIGGIO.
BO BICHETTE ON THE GAME LAST
NIGHT WITH A THREE RUN HOME RUN.
HAVE TO LOVE THE WAY THIS GUY
ATTACKS.
>> HE IS A STUD.
THIS IS WHAT HE DOES.
AN UNCONVENTIONAL WAY OF
HITTING, COILS THE BAT LIKE A
SNAKE.
JUST FREEDOM.
I'M BLOWN AWAY BY THE FREEDOM.
HE WILL SHORTEN UP WITH TWO
STRIKES, ILLUMINATE THE LEG KICK
AND PUSH IT TO RIGHT.
BRIAN: THERE IS AN IQ HAPPENING
WITH THESE GUYS.
WE WILL TAKE A SHORT BREAK.
WE WILL GET READY FOR THE GAME
WHEN JAYS.
WE WILL HAVE THE LINEUP SENT
FIRST PITCH COMING UP NEXT.
♪
>> DEEP FLY BALL OUT TO RIGHT
FIELD.
BLACKMAN, GONE.
MARINERS ON THE BOARD.
FIRST HIT FOR THE MARINERS PUTS
A RUN ACROSS.
>> HE WAS CRUISING.
HE WAS PERFECT.
THIS TIME, BREAKING BALL.
TAYLOR ABLE TO GET JUST ENOUGH
OF IT.
>> FLY BALL.
>> CAN'T SEE IT BECAUSE IT IS
OUT OF HERE.
THAT IS WHY.
1-0 MARINERS.
TAYLOR TRAMMELL WITH HIS SEVENTH
HOME RUN.
1-0 MARINERS IN THE FIFTH.
A TWO OUT BLAST.
>> FOR TAYLOR, HIS GAME PLAN WAS
TO HIT A FIRST PITCH FASTBALL.
BELT HIGH, MIDDLE IN, THROWS THE
BARREL AT IT.
EXIT VELO 99 MILES PER HOUR, 372
FEET.
>> LOOKS LIKE HE GOT ANOTHER
ONE.
THE MARINERS HAVE A 3-2 LEAD.
TAYLOR TRAMMELL 82 HOME RUN DAY.
THAT -- A TWO HOME RUN DAY.
THAT GIVES HIM EIGHT ON THE
SEASON.
BRIAN: WELCOME BACK TO THE GAME
OF THE WEEK.
TONIGHT'S BROADCAST IS POWERED
BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
REAL STAR POWER, MARINERS AND
BLUE JAYS.
MARK DEROSA, THE NUMBER ONE
HITTER IN BASEBALL, VLAD JR. HOW
DID HE TAKE THE JUMP FROM
DISAPPOINTING TO THE NUMBER ONE
HITTER?
MARK: HE TOOK OWNERSHIP IN HIS
OWN CAREER.
LET'S DIVE IN, BECAUSE THIS GUY
IS KILLING IT.
.3 44, 26 AND 66 R.B.I.'S, WE
ARE SEEING STUFF WE HAVEN'T SEEN
SINCE TED WILLIAMS 80 YEARS AGO.
HE HAS A CHANCE TO HAVE ONE OF
THE BEST OFFENSIVE SEASONS OF
ALL TIME, AGE 22 OR YOUNGER.
SEARCH FOR RHYTHM, SEARCH FOR
TIMING, SEARCH FOR PLATE
DISCIPLINE AND HE IS PUTTING ALL
THOSE FACETS TOGETHER.
AND HE HAS TOWER POWER.
KINSLER, DOWN AND DONE A, 465.
I BRING THIS UP BECAUSE I WAS IN
OLYMPIC STADIUM BACK IN THE DAY,
I THINK IT WAS 2003, JULY 28,
MIKE HAMPTON TRIES TO GET THE
CUTTER IN.
502 FEET LATER, I THINK THEY PUT
A SIGN UP THERE.
500 TWO FEET.
UNBELIEVABLE.
I WANT THE SIDE-BY-SIDE WITH HIS
OLD MAN.
HE GOES WITH THE TOE TAP LIKE
SAMMY SOSA.
STOP IT RIGHT HERE.
HERE IS THE DIFFERENCE.
I PUT HIM IN WHITE BECAUSE WHITE
MAKES YOU LOOK BIGGER.
I DON'T KNOW, LOOKS PRETTY
SVELTE TO ME.
HERE IS 2020 AND THE GRAY, 40
POUNDS OVERWEIGHT AND WHAT DOES
THAT DO?
THE ABILITY TO CREATE THAT SPEED
-- BAT SPEED AND GET TO THE GAS.
IN THE BIG LEAGUES THAT IS WHAT
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE,
93-95 MILES PER HOUR PLUS.
NOBODY DOES IT BETTER.
HIS AVERAGE, 2019 AND 2020, .1
97.
LOOK AT IT NOW, .49 ZERO, BEST
IN THE MAJORS.
SLUGGING PERCENTAGE HAS GONE
THROUGH THE ROOF TO .7 25.
EXIT VELO AS WELL.
HE HAS TAKEN OWNERSHIP.
HE WANTS TO BE ONE OF THE BIG
BOYS, FIGHTING SHOHEI OHTANI FOR
THE A.L. M.V.P.
BRIAN: THE WHITE IS NOT
SLAMMING.
-- IS NOT SLAMMING.
-- IS NOT SLIMMING.
BRIAN: A CHANCE OF RAIN IN
BUFFALO.
THERE IS SCOTT SERVAIS.
TAKING A LOOK AT THE LINEUP FOR
THE MARINERS, J.P. CRAWFORD,
OUTSTANDING FIELDING SHORTSTOP.
MITCH HANIGER, BATTING SECOND.
THEN TY FRANCE, GOOD POWER AT
FIRST.
KYLE SEAGER AT THIRD, LUIS
TORRENS BEHIND THE PLATE, JAKE
BAUERS IN LEFT, TOM MURPHY D.H.,
DYLAN MOORE THE SECOND BASEMEN
ANN TAYLOR TAYLOR TRAMMELL AT 23
YEARS OLD.
STEVEN MATZ AND HIS FIRST START
SINCE JUNE 12, HAD A POSITIVE
COVID TEST.
WE ARE UNDERWAY.
THERE IS A STRIKE.
HE WILL BE ON A PITCH COUNT.
BRIAN: --
>> THIS GUY CAME OFF THE COVID
I.L.
YOU HAVE TO ISOLATE.
HE WAS THROWING INTO A NET.
COULDN'T THROW WITH A THROWING
PARTNER, AND HE IS ON A 60 PITCH
SIMULATED GAME AND HERE HE IS.
BRIAN: QUICK GROUND OUT TO
LOURDES GURRIEL AT FIRST.
VLAD JR. IS THE D.H. SO THERE IS
THE DEFENSE, SEMIEN AT SECOND,
BO BICHETTE, I ALMOST SAID DANTE
.
I NEVER SAY CRAIG BIGGIO BUT I
SAY DANTE BICHETTE ALL THE TIME.
SELECTIVE.
MITCH HANIGER SLUGGING .490.
THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS WE WILL
PUT OUT THERE.
THE ON-BASE SLUGGING, WEIGHTED
RUNS CREATED PLUS, THAT ONE IS
GONE.
IS IT?
MARK: HE HAMMERS FASTBALLS,
MITCH HANIGER.
THE BREAKING STUFF HAS GIVEN HIM
FITS, JUMPING ON THE HEATER.
BRIAN: TWO OUTS.
STATCAST 3D, AS WE SHOW YOU THE
PITCH USAGE.
RYAN: CURVEBALL HAS BEEN A BIG
WEAPON FOR STEVEN MATZ.
17 DAYS AGO, HE HAS BEEN ON THE
COVID I.L. BUT THE CURVEBALL
CAME ALIVE.
THAT WAS A BIG PITCH.
>> THE WIND IS BLOWING IT OFF
THE LAKE.
>> OTHERWISE IT WOULDN'T PULL
LIKE THAT.
>> WAY TO CALL A HOME RUN.
MARK: I PLAYED IN THAT YARD.
COMING UP THROUGH THE ENTER
LEAGUE MULTIPLE TIMES.
BRIAN: WHAT WAS THE AFFILIATE?
MARK: CLEVELAND.
I WAS WITH THE BRAVES IN
RICHMOND.
I WAS A VISITING PLAYER.
BRIAN: TY FRANCE, GOOD OFFENSIVE
YEAR, .351 ON-BASE, SLUGGING
.431.
HE IS THE POWER IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING THE GAME
NATIONALLY, THE MARINERS ARE
GETTING ENOUGH OFFENSE.
YOU MENTIONED ALL IN ALL, NOT
ENOUGH -- IMPRESSIVE OFFENSIVE
CLUB.
RYAN: THEY SEE A LOT OF PITCHES
AND HE HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVE BUT
YOU TAKE OUT THE STING, HE TRIED
TO PLAY THROUGH IT, WENT ON THE
I.L. AND IF YOU TAKE OUT THOSE
COUPLE WEEKS BEFORE HE WENT ON
THE I.L., HE PUTS UP BIGGER
NUMBERS.
BRIAN: MATZ WAS USED TO GETTING
LIT UP IN THE FIRST INNING.
WE SEE A VERY EFFICIENT FIRST
INNING FOR HIM.
MARK: THAT HAS BEEN THE KEY.
DOES HE HAVE FASTBALL COMMAND?
CAN HE MAKE IT 0-1 INSTEAD OF
1-0 AND NOT BECOME PREDICTABLE?
THE STUFF PLAYS.
BRIAN: 0-2, TWO OUTS.
FIRST START SINCE JUNE 12 AFTER
A POSITIVE COVID TEST.
JON MOROSI WILL BE REPORTING FOR
US LATER.
IT WAS ASYMPTOMATIC SO HE WASN'T
BEDRIDDEN, BUT HAD A POSITIVE
TEST, HASN'T PITCHED SINCE THEN.
IN HIS LAST FOUR STARTS BEFORE
THEN, 3.32 E.R.A..
SARAH: HIS SECOND MOST SWINGING
STRIKES IN HIS LAST START.
MARK: HE COMES OVER FROM THE
METS, GOES TO THE BLUE JAYS,
FIRST THREE HE WON SIX OR MORE
IN ALL THREE, GAVE UP ONE RUN IN
ALL THREE SO MADE A POSITIVE
IMPRESSION EARLY ON.
BRIAN: THE 1-0 IS DOWN LOW.
YOU SHOW UP, THERE IS A PREMISES
BIAS.
YOU KIND OF CEMENT THAT QUICKLY.
MARK: ABSOLUTELY.
FOR ME, THE GRASS ISN'T ALWAYS
GREENER BUT FOR STEVEN MATZ, IT
HAD RUN ITS COURSE WITH THE
METS.
THEY MAY BE LABELED HIM AND HE
GETS A CHANCE TO GO TO SPRING
TRAINING AND STRUCK HIS STUFF.
BRIAN: FRANCE WITH A GROUND
BALL.
BICHETTE OFF THE BACK LEG GETS
THE OUT.
QUICK 1-2-3 INNING.
STEVEN MATZ IT'S THROUGH THE
FIRST.
WE HAVE THE TOP OF THE ORDER
BRINGING THE LUMBER, SEMIEN,
BICHETTENEXT FOR
THE BLUE JAYS.
>> SWING AND A DRIVE, HIGH FLY
BALL, THIS IS GONE.
ANOTHER VLADDY GUERRERO HOME
RUN.
ASK WHEN YOU ARE WALKING BY THE
TELEVISION YOU WANT TO WATCH HIS
AT-BATS.
>> GUERRERO HIGH AND DEEP TO
CENTER.
HOME RUN GUERRERO.
2-2 ON TWO PITCHES.
HOME RUN NUMBER 25 FOR GUERRERO
AND HE BREAKS THE 1-1 TIE.
>> GETS ANOTHER PITCH OVER THE
PLATE.
ANOTHER FASTBALL AND HE IS ALL
OVER IT.
>> BACK TO BACK TO BACK OUT
DOUBLES FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
SWING AND A HIGH FLY BALL TO
LEFT, THIS BALL IS GOING TO GO.
TWO RUN HOME RUN FOR VLADDY ON
THE FIRST PITCH AGAIN.
FAIR BALL DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD
LINE.
THAT IS GOING TO SCORE ONE.
SEMIEN IS BEING WAVED HOME.
THE THROW TO THE PLATE, IT IS
CUT OFF AND GUERRERO COMES
THROUGH ONCE AGAIN.
A TO STRIKE, ONE OUT DOUBLE FOR
VLADDY AND THE BLUE JAYS HAVE A
3-1 LEAD.
♪
BRIAN: HERE IS THE BLUE JAYS
LINEUP.
IT IS STAR-STUDDED WITH GEORGE
SPRINGER BACK IN THE LINEUP.
MARCUS SEMIEN LEADING OFF, BO
BICHETTE SECOND, VLAD JR. ADDING
THIRD AS THE D.H., XWOBA IS
EXPECTED WEIGHTED ON-BASE.
O.P.S.+, 100 IS LEAGUE AVERAGE.
THE STRENGTH OF TWO MEN.
THAT IS STAN MUSIAL TERRITORY.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ, SPRINGER,
RANDAL GRICHUK, CAVAN BIGGIO,
LOURDES GURRIEL THE FIRST
BASEMAN, THE CATCHER IS RILEY
ADAMS.
ON THE HILL IS JUSTUS SHEFFIELD,
25 YEARS OLD, LEFT-HANDER, CAME
OVER AND THE JAMES PAXTON TRADE
WITH THE YANKEES.
HE HAS STRUGGLED THIS YEAR, 5.69
E.R.A., E.R.A. PLUS IS 72,
LEAGUE AVERAGE IS 100.
MARCUS SEMIEN TAKES A BALL
INSIDE.
RYAN: THAT FASTBALL IN WILL BE
THE KEY FOR HIM.
THIS WILL BE THE TOUGHEST
MATCHUP IN 2021I THINK FOR
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD.
HE HAS STRUGGLED WITH THE
FASTBALL IN.
BRIAN: THAT IS GOING TO BE WORTH
LIKE $100 MILLION.
MARK: MOVED THE POSITION, ONE
YEAR, $18 MILLION, HATS OFF TO
HIM, HE IS KILLING THE BASEBALL.
BRIAN: 2-0.
HE HAD THE MONSTER 2019, LEGIT
M.V.P. CANDIDATE, 3-0 QUICKLY.
THE TWO RUN SEASON LAST YEAR,
LESS THAN IMPRESSIVE, GOOD
PLAYOFF BUT WAS THAT HIS SPIKE
YEAR?
OR WAS HE THE GUY FROM 2019?
THIS YEAR, SHOWING HE IS THE GUY
FROM 2019.
MARK: I AM SURPRISED.
I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT A LOT OF
GENERAL MANAGERS WOULD HAVE
THROWN OUT 2020 NUMBERS.
BRIAN: HE HAD FOUR OR FIVE YEARS
OF THIS KIND OF LEAGUE AVERAGE
OFFENSIVE GUY.
STATCAST 3D KIM -- 3D, HERE IS
THE USAGE FOR SHEFFIELD.
RYAN: SINKER 42%, THE SLIDER IS
HIS BIG WEAPON BUT HE HAS
STRUGGLED WITH COMMAND.
YOU SEE MORE OF THE CHANGEUP
TONIGHT, 23%.
THE USAGE HAS JUMPED BECAUSE HE
HASN'T HAD THE FASTBALL COMMAND
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE SLIPS BEHIND
IN COUNTS.
BRIAN: BO BICHETTE GOING AFTER
THE FIRST PITCH, BASE HIT.
BIG AMBUSH PLAYER, BO BICHETTE.
NICELY DONE.
MARCUS SEMIEN.
BEAUTIFUL BASE RUNNING.
IS THAT 50-50?
MARK: ESPECIALLY WITH MY MAN
VLAD JR. COMING UP, I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO PUMP THE BRAKES A LITTLE
BUT I LIKE THE AGGRESSIVE
NATURE.
BRIAN: I LOVE THIS.
HE IS AN AGGRESSIVE PLAYER,
CONFIDENCE, GETS AFTER IT.
POUNCES IMMEDIATELY.
HAD A BIG THREE RUN SHOT
YESTERDAY.
THAT HAS TO BE TALKED ABOUT
GOING INTO THE SEASON, OR GOING
INTO THIS SERIES, THAT THEY WILL
TEST THE OUTFIELD ARMS.
I WAS WATCHING VLAD JR. TAKE
FIRST AND THIRD.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ.
BRIAN: HANIGER HAS A GOOD ARM
AND RIGHT BUT THAT BALL IS HIT
TO CENTER.
HERE IS VLAD JR., .446 ON BASE,
.685 SLUGGING.
GOING AFTER THE FIRST PITCH, AS
WELL.
RYAN: JUSTUS SHEFFIELD TRYING TO
SETTLE IN.
THE GAME SPEEDS UP QUICK WHEN
YOU STRUGGLE.
A COUPLE MINUTES IN AND HE HAS
VLAD JR. WITH RUNNERS ON AND
SCORING POSITION.
BRIAN: LOOK AT THE SAVAGE
NUMBERS.
HE ADDED 100 POINTS IN ON BASE,
200 POINTS IN SLUGGING IN ONE
YEAR.
WE DID TOP 10 RIGHT NOW, THAT IS
A GOOD GAUGE OF WHAT THE THOUGHT
IS ABOUT A GUY IN A CERTAIN
OFF-SEASON.
HE FOULS THAT BACK.
WE WERE STRUGGLING NOW THAT HE
WAS MOVING TO FIRST.
IS HE ONE OF THE TOP FIRST
BASEMAN IN BASEBALL?
SEEMS LIKE A SILLY QUESTION.
IT WASN'T A FEW MONTHS AGO.
SARAH: I CAN'T REMEMBER, BUT I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAD HIM, THAT
HAS CHANGED NOW BUT WE WERE
HOPING THIS WOULD HAPPEN FOR HIM
THIS YEAR BUT WE COULDN'T HAVE
SEEN THIS COMING.
BRIAN: HE LEVEL JUMPED.
IF HE WAS SLUGGING .500 YOU
WOULD SAY HE IS BECOMING A GOOD
MAJOR LEAGUE PLAYER.
HE HAS GONE PAST THAT.
MARK: THE GAME HUMBLED HIM.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO BE?
ALL THE TOOLS AND THE WORLD, WE
TALK ABOUT THE CHASE RATE, HE
GETS A SLIDER DOWN AND HE GOES
AFTER IT BUT HE HAS TAKEN IT
UPON HIMSELF, INSTEAD OF LEAVING
-- READING THE PRESS, WHO WERE
MY GOING TO BE?
-- UMI GOING TO BE?
RYAN: YOU GET THAT REACTION
BECAUSE YOU ARE 0-2 AND THAT IS
A HUGE BOOST FOR JUSTUS
SHEFFIELD.
BRIAN: WHEN IT COMES IN THAT
SLOW, TOTAL RUNS IN THE GAME
OVER-UNDER IS 10.5.
I WOULD GO OVER.
MARK: THE WAY MITCH HANIGER HIT
THAT BALL IN THE TOP OF THE
FIRST, WE MIGHT GO UNDER.
THAT LOOKED LIKE IT WAS LEAVING
THE YARD.
BRIAN: HERE IS HERNANDEZ
SLUGGING .498 THIS YEAR.
YOU SEE THE DEFENSE FOR THE
MARINERS.
CRAWFORD AND SEAGER HAVE WON
GOLD GLOVES.
SARAH: 379 FOR A FLY BALL.
IT WASN'T 200 FEET.
BRIAN: I CALL BOXING WITH GUYS
WHO SAY, ONE SHOT, THE FIGHT IS
OVER.
LET THE REF COUNT.
HERO BALL.
MARK: A LOT OF OFFSPEED AFTER
THOSE FIRST PITCHES TO SEMIEN
WHERE HE WAS TRYING TO ESTABLISH
THE HEATER.
RYAN: THE CHANGEUP, HE REALLY
THREW THAT PICKS LAST YEAR.
HE WAS A TWO PITCH GUY AS A
STARTER IN THE SHORTENED SEASON.
WE ARE SEEING MORE CHANGEUPS
ESPECIALLY STRUGGLING WITH THE
FASTBALL COMMAND.
BRIAN: HERNANDEZ IS AN ALL-STAR
-- ALL-STAR FINALIST?
DID I MAKE THAT UP?
SARAH: HE IS.
BRIAN: I REMEMBER SEEING THAT
AND I THOUGHT, ARE THE TORONTO
FANS OVER-VOTING?
NO, ACTUALLY.
HE HAS EARNED IT.
HE IS SLUGGING AROUND .500, AN
IMPRESSIVE LAY HER, A GUY WHO
COULD GET LOST AMID THE BIG
FOUNDATION SUPERSTAR PLAYERS
THEY HAVE.
MARK: GETS THROUGH THE ZONE FREE
AND EASY.
AND HE HAS GEORGE SPRINGER
HITTING BEHIND HIM.
BRIAN: A NICE CROWD IN BUFFALO.
1-2, ONE OUT, FIRST AND THIRD.
SHEFFIELD GOES TO FIRST.
FRANCE.
HERNANDEZ, SPRINGER ON DECK,
THEN RANDAL GRICHUK THEN CAVAN
BIGGIO WITH HIS PLATE
DISCIPLINE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LOOKS.
I THINK IT IS HELPFUL TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT SKILL SET THROUGH THE
LINEUP, DIVERSITY.
THE 1-2.
TOOK SOMETHING OFF THAT.
GLOVED AT SHORT BY CRAWFORD.
THEY GOT HIM?
WOW.
DOUBLE PLAY, INNING OVER.
FIRST TWO ON VERY QUICKLY,
STRIKEOUT, DOUBLE PLAY.
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD HAS SURVIVED.
NO SCORE THROUGH ONE IN BUFFALO.
>> MARCUS SEMIEN WILL FACE
FLEXEN FOR A SECOND TIME.
THAT IS ON THE GROUND, FAIR BALL
DOWN THE THIRD-BASE LINE.
THAT WILL SCORE TWO.
GRICHUK IS INTO SCORE AND RIGHT
BEHIND HIM AS LOURDES GURRIEL.
MARCUS SEMIEN COMES THROUGH
AGAIN.
>> ONE OUT, TWO OF BOARD FOR TY
FRANCE.
FASTBALL SWUNG ON AND DRIVEN
DEEP TO LEFT.
GOING BACK IS SPRINGER, REACHING
UP, IT'S GONE.
TIE GAME.
TY FRANCE DELIVERS.
HOME RUN NUMBER EIGHT.
RIGHT ON TIME.
>> THERE IS BO BICHETTE.
HITS IT HIGH AND DEEP INTO LEFT
CENTER.
THIS ONE IS GOING TO GO.
GET OUT OF HERE, GONE.
BO BICHETTE WITH A THREE RUN
HOME RUN.
HE BREAKS THE TIE IMMEDIATELY.
>> MARCUS SEMIEN, TWO MORE HITS
TONIGHT, DROVE IN THE FIRST TWO
BLUE JAYS RUNS IN THE SECOND.
SWUNG ON AND DRIVEN, IT IS A
FAIR BALL RIGHT OFF THE FOUL
POLE.
>> THAT IS HIS 19TH LONG BALL OF
THE YEAR.
♪
JON: WELCOME BACK.
WE ARE THREE AND A HALF MILES
AWAY FROM THE PEACE BRIDGE THAT
LINKS BUFFALO AND FORT ERIE,
ONTARIO, THE SECOND CLOSEST
BALLPARK TO ANY INTERNATIONAL
BORDER.
THIS MATCHUP IS CLOSELY FOLLOWED
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER.
HAPPY EARLY CANADA DAY TO OUR
VIEWERS IN CANADA.
WHEN THESE TEAMS PLAY IN
SEATTLE, CLOSELY WATCHED ON
EITHER SIDE AND THE BLUE JAYS
RIGHT NOW, EXPECTING TO STAY FOR
A FEW MORE WEEKS.
CHANGING BORDER RESTRICTIONS AS
EARLY AS MONDAY SO PERHAPS THEY
WILL MAKE THEIR WAY HOME TO
TORONTO BEFORE MUCH LONGER.
BRIAN: THANKS, J.P.
IT HAS BEEN A STRANGE YEAR FOR
THESE GUYS, BOUNCING BACK AND
FORTH AS WE START, KYLE SEAGER,
TORRENS AND BOWERS.
FOR THE BLUE JAYS, PLAYING THE
WAY THEY HAVE, WE TALKED TO
CHARLIE MONTOYO, HOW HAS IT BEEN
AS FAR AS CHANGING PLAY GOING
FROM DUNEDIN, FLORIDA, THEN
BUFFALO?
HE SAID, REAL-WORLD, IT HASN'T
BEEN EASY.
WE ARE MOVING FAMILIES, FINDING
NEW APARTMENTS, PLAYING IN
DUNEDIN, WHEN WE PLAY THE RAYS
IN THE YANKEES THEY HAVE MORE
FANS THAN WE DO.
THEY ARE NOT A GOOD HOME TEAM
RIGHT KNOW BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A
HOME STADIUM.
SEAGER STRIKES OUT.
I THINK THIS IS A SECOND-HALF
TEAM.
MARK: I DO LIKE THEM.
LINEUP FOR DAYS.
THE THREE LEFT-HANDERS BACK TO
BACK TO BACK, ROBBIE RAY,
HYUN-JIN RYU, STEVEN MATZ, I
THINK IT IS INTERESTING AND
COMFORTABLE FOR SOME OF THE
BETTER LINEUPS THEY WILL HAVE TO
FACE IF THEY GET TO THE
POSTSEASON.
BUT HE HAS DONE A HECKUVA JOB.
BRIAN: 10-11 IN DUNEDIN AND THEY
ARE BARELY WINNING IN BUFFALO
BUT IT IS NOT IDEAL.
THAT MUCH YOU CAN SEE.
BEHIND-THE-SCENES, YOU GUYS KNOW
, YOU ARE NOT JUST SHOWING UP AT
THE PARK WITH YOUR STAFF
USHERING YOU IN.
YOU HAVE THINGS TO DEAL WITH,
GUYS HAVE WIVES AND KIDS.
YOU ARE NOT IN YOUR HOME
STADIUM.
RYAN: DERO, I BROUGHT THIS UP
YESTERDAY, IF YOU ARE GETTING
YOUR FIRST CALL UP TO THE BIG
LEAGUES, HERE YOU GO, OFF TO
BUFFALO.
YOU WANT TO GO TO A BIG-LEAGUE
STADIUM AND HAVE THE EXPERIENCE.
BRIAN: BO BICHETTE GLOVES THAT.
THE AVERAGE EXIT VELOCITY
LEADERS, ANYTHING OVER 95 IS
CONSIDERED A HARD-HIT BALL.
THESE GUYS BASICALLY AVERAGING
BAT, AARON JUDGE NUMBER ONE,
VLAD JR. NUMBER TWO, AND ACUNA
AND MANNY MACHADO AS WELL.
WHICH PLAYER WOULD YOU WANT UP
WITH THE GAME ON THE LINE?
WE WILL GIVE YOU THOSE CHOICES,
JUDGE, GUERRERO, MACHADO OR
RONALD ACUNA JR..
WE WILL HAVE THE RESULTS LATER.
I MISSED THIS LAST TIME BECAUSE
BO BICHETTE GOT GHOSTED, HE HIT
THE BALL AT 113 MILES PER HOUR,
BICHETTE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM AT FIRST?
I NEVER SAW HIM AGAIN.
IT WAS A LINE DRIVE AND I'M LIKE
-- PLATO FIRST?
I DON'T SEE A GUY RUNNING BACK
TO FIRST.
DID HE TAKE HIS POSITION?
MARK: I WILL TRADE PLACES.
BRIAN: 3-0 TO BOWERS.
MARK: JAKE BAUERS HAS FOUND NEW
LIFE.
BRIAN: BASE HIT.
GEORGE SPRINGER OUT THERE IN
CENTER FIELD.
TWO OUT, ONE MAN ON.
I NEVER SAW BO BICHETTE AGAIN.
HE WAS ON FIRST, AND BICHETTE,
WAS HE RUNNING OR DID HE HAVE A
BIG LEAD?
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE HE WAS
RUNNING.
THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
HE IS A TOP FIVE BASE RUNNER SO
HE IS A GOOD BASE RUNNER.
SARAH: THEY ARE AGGRESSIVE,
AMONG THE LEADERS ON OUTS ON THE
BASES AND BASES TAKEN.
BRIAN: TOM MURPHY STEPS IN, THE
D.H., THE CATCHER, NOT HITTING
MUCH THIS YEAR.
HAS SHOWN A GOOD OFFENSIVE
QUALITY IN THE PAST IN HIS
CAREER.
I LOVE HOW SEMIEN WENT TO THIRD
DEFINITIVELY AND BICHETTE WAS
OFF AND RUNNING AND GOT BURNED
WITH A LINE DRIVE.
THAT TEAM GETS AFTER WRIT AND
THEY WILL WIN EXTRA GAMES AND BE
GOOD IN THE PLAYOFFS.
PRETTY WILD TO FIRST.
I'M GLAD WE SAW THAT.
BICHETTE LOOKED DISENGAGED.
ARE YOU GETTING A HOT DOG?
SHOW US AN EFFORT.
BUT HE WAS RUNNING.
RYAN: ON THE OTHER SIDE, J.P.,
THE FENCING, GOLD GLOVE LAST
YEAR, PERRY HILL HAS BEEN THE
GUY FOR HIM.
BRIAN: BICHETTE GLOVES THAT,
BUSY IN THIS GAME.
THAT WILL DO IT.
BICHETTE MAKES TWO WERE RECORDEO
SCORE, WE GO TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE SECOND AND WE WILL GET
SPRINGER, GRICHUK AND BIGGIO
COMING UP.
>> HIGH FLY BALL COME ALONG RUN
FOR HANIGER, MAKES THE PLAY AND
THAT WILL DO IT.
NICELY DONE TO GET THE BIG MAN
FOR THE WHITE SOX.
FIVE P1 -- 5-1 MARINERS.
>> HIGH BREAKING BALL HIT A LONG
WAY TOWARDS THE GAP.
IT'S GONE.
TWO RUN HOMER, LUIS TORRENS.
>> THE 2-2 SWUNG ON, LIFTED TO
RIGHT, THIS IS HIT WELL.
BACK IS GARCIA LOOKING UP AND IT
IS GONE.
INTO THE MARINERS BULLPEN.
LUIS TORRENS HAS STRUCK AGAIN.
>> J.P. CRAWFORD WITH THE
HARPOON, PULLS IT BACK.
TWO GONE.
>> WELL-TIMED JUMP INTO THE
WEBBING OF HIS GLOVE.
>> FLY BALL, CAN'T SEE IT
BECAUSE IT IS OUT OF HERE.
THAT'S WHY.
1-0 MARINERS.
DID HE GET ANOTHER ONE?
LOOKS LIKE HE DID.
THE MARINERS HAVE A 3-2 LEAD.
TAYLOR TRAMMELL A TWO HOME RUN
DAY.
>> SHOULD OUT TO CENTER -- SHED
OUT TO CENTER.
WAY BACK, GONE.
HOME RUN NUMBER 7000 IN CLUB
HISTORY.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
BRIAN: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK.
TONIGHT'S BROADCAST IS BROUGHT
TO YOU BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
I AM BRIAN KENNY ALONGSIDE RYAN
ROWLAND-SMITH, MARK DEROSA,
SARAH.
JON MOROSI IS WITH US.
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD, HE GOT OUT OF
THAT FIRST INNING, HE HAD A
CHANGE OF PACE.
RYAN: IT IS SO KEY FOR HIM.
THE USAGE, HE CANNOT RELY ON
THIS.
HE HAS TO FIGURE OUT THAT
FASTBALL.
GOING BACK TO 2020, PEOPLE WOULD
SAY, LOOK, THE FASTBALL PROFILE,
BELOW-AVERAGE ON THE SPIN.
HE HAS TO GET DOWN AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE STRIKE ZONE OR IT WILL BE
A TON OF SWINGS JUST LIKE THAT
AND THEY WILL BE SOME DAMAGE.
BRIAN: HERE IS GEORGE SPRINGER.
ALREADY ABOVE LEAGUE AVERAGE.
THIS IS ONE OF THEIR BIG
ACQUISITIONS.
A BIG TICKET ITEM.
MARK: 150.
SARAH: LARGEST CONTRACT IN TEAM
HISTORY.
BRIAN: JUST INSIDE.
HE IS A DYNAMIC PLAYER.
THERE IS THE DEFENSE AND SPRAY
CHART FOR SPRINGER.
IT DID NOT HURT ALL THE ACTION
IN THE POSTSEASON.
THE GUY CAN PLAY CENTER FIELD.
A LOT CORNER OUTFIELDERS CAN
HIT.
NOT MANY CAN PLAY CENTER FIELD.
SARAH: HE IS SO GOOD
DEFENSIVELY.
I AM NOT SURE HE WILL BE AS GOOD
AT THE END OF THE DEAL BUT YOU
GET SO MUCH IN THE FIRST FEW
YEARS.
CREDIT TO THE BLUE JAYS.
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE DONE
WITHOUT HIM FOR THE MAJORITY OF
THE SEASON UNTIL THE LAST FEW
DAYS REALLY.
BRIAN: MICHAEL BRANTLEY, THEY
HAD HIM ALL BUT SIGNED.
THE ANNOUNCEMENTS WERE MADE, THE
REPORTERS WERE MAKING THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
GATES GOT HURT.
BUT I LIKE THE RAW AGGRESSION OF
MARK SHAPIRO, ATKINS, GOT AFTER
IT.
WELL HIT, BASE HIT.
SLIDING LEFT FIELD.
JAKE BAUERS GETS IT IN QUICKLY.
THESE GUYS ARE AGGRESSIVE.
POUNCING ON THAT FIRST PITCH,
HITTING IT HARD.
RYAN: THAT FASTBALL, IT'LL END
UP.
IT IS GOT TO BE DOWN IN THE
STRIKE ZONE OR THERE WILL BE
MORE OF THIS.
GEORGE SPRINGER OFF TO A SLOW
START.
IT WILL TAKE A LITTLE BIT FOR
HIM TO GET SETTLED IN.
BRIAN: 108 MILES PER HOUR.
THAT IS WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THE
EXIT VELO.
IS IT EVERYTHING?
NO.
BUT WHEN A GUY HITS A BALL HARD,
HOW HARD?
MARK: YOU JUST DESCRIBED -- WE
DESCRIBED IT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY WHEN WE SAT ON THE
BENCH.
WE WOULD SAY, THIS CASE A SOFT
280.
AS OPPOSED TO ANOTHER GUY, A
SCALDING 240.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
YOU BRING IN SPRINGER BUT YOU
STILL HOLD ON TO RANDAL GRICHUK.
YOU'VE GOT THE LOGJAM IN THE
OUTFIELD.
THROUGH INJURIES AND EVERYTHING,
A MONSTER START TO THE SEASON.
BRIAN: THEY PAID HIM, A 40, 50
MILLION DOLLAR DEAL.
WHEN YOU ARE TRYING TO PUT
TOGETHER A CHAMPIONSHIP TEAM,
AND HE IS YOUR SECOND BEST
HITTER.
SARAH: HE IS ANOTHER ONE WHO IS
OUT THERE GOOD DEFENSIVELY FOR
THEM.
BRIAN: NOBODY OUT, GEORGE
SPRINGER ON FIRST.
BIGGIO, PLATE DISCIPLINE, KIND
OF A SMALLER JOEY VOTTO.
FAL BACK AGAIN.
THE THING THAT IS IMPRESSIVE
ABOUT BIGGIO, BICHETTE,
GUERRERO, THE POLISH, THE
AWARENESS, AND THAT THEY HAVE
ALL DELIVERED.
SARAH: THERE WAS SO MUCH HYPE
SURROUNDING THIS.
THE SONS OF MAJOR LEAGUERS, THE
SON OF YULI GURRIEL OBVIOUSLY,
HIS FATHER.
THEY HAVE LIVED UP TO IT.
THE ONE WHO TOOK THE LONGEST TO
GET HERE WAS GUERRERO.
BRIAN: ANOTHER BASE HIT.
WE ARE SEEING SINGLES.
I THOUGHT SINGLES WERE DEAD.
AT LEAST THREE.
ADDING TO THIS UNIQUE VIEWING
EXPERIENCE, CHECK OUT THE LIVE
GAME COMMENTARY, A SELECT GROUP
OF YOUTUBE CREATORS, LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY ON YOUR MOBILE
DEVICE, YOUR TV.
THEY ARE CALLING THEIR OWN
GAMES.
GOING UP AGAINST US.
THEY ARE COMMENTING ON US.
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED.
FOUR SINGLES IN THIS GAME.
WHAT IS THE RECORD.
SINGLES WERE AT AN ALL-TIME LOW.
MARK: GET THE BUNT DOWN.
BRIAN: HERE IS CAVAN BIGGIO.
FIRST AND SECOND, NOBODY OUT, IS
THE TIME TO BUNT TRYING TO GET A
RUN, AND IT WILL INCREASE YOUR
RUN PROBABILITY AND RUN
EXPECTANCY.
SECOND INNING SEEMS A LITTLE
EARLY.
THE LAST GAME WE CALLED WAS WITH
TONY LA RUSSA.
HE BUNTED THREE TIMES.
MARK: NO CHANCE UNLESS HE WANTS
TO DO IT ON HIS OWN.
HE DOES NOT HAVE HIS FASTBALL
COMMAND.
HE HAS A LOT OF SOFT STUFF.
THERE IS A CHANCE TO GET
SOMETHING UP IN THE ZONE AND
JUST DO HIS THING.
BRIAN: HE LAYS OFF, A QUALITY
TAKE.
HE IMMEDIATELY WAS NUMBER ONE,
NOT LIKE TOP 10.
MEANING HE IS NOT SWINGING
OUTSIDE OF THE ZONE.
I AM TALKING ROOKIE, NOT
CHASING.
NUMBER ONE IN THE LEAGUE, THAT
IS IMPRESSIVE.
MARK: TRYING TO THINK, WAS CRAIG
A FREE SWINGER?
BRIAN: HE WAS BALANCED, HE GOT
-- HE WAS KIND OF A COMPLETE
PACKAGE.
MARK: CHRISTMAS DINNER, CAVAN IS
LIKE, DAD, I GOT A BETTER EYE
THAN YOU.
RYAN: IS HE THROWING ALL THE
STATCAST NUMBERS AT HIS DAD?
BRIAN: HIS DAD, CRAIG, CRAIG
BIGGIO WAS THE BEST FOOTBALL
PLAYER ON LONG ISLAND.
HE WAS THE RUNNING BACK OF THE
YEAR IN SUFFOLK COUNTY.
I THINK HE WON THE HANSEN AWARD.
MARK: TEAMED UP WITH MO VAUGHN.
BRIAN: HE WAS A CATCHER, SECOND
BASEMAN, CENTER FIELDER.
ON THE FAR RIGHT, THAT IS A
SKINNY LITTLE SPUD.
IF YOU YEARS AGO, AND HERE HE
IS.
2-2.
WHERE WAS HE DRAFTED?
HIS DAD WAS A BLUE-CHIPPER
COMING UP.
CAVAN WAS NOT THAT.
HE WORKED HIS WAY THROUGH.
CAVAN BIGGIO IS NOT CHASING
THAT.
HERE THEY ARE A LITTLE OLDER.
NOW CRAIG HAS GOT THE GRAY HAIR.
SARAH: A FIFTH ROUNDER.
2016.
BRIAN: IF YOU ARE IN YOUR
HOMETOWN AND YOU ARE DRAFTED IN
THE FIFTH ROUND, THAT IS GREAT.
IN THE PARLANCE OF THE MAJOR
LEAGUES AND HOW MUCH PUSH YOU
GET, IF YOU ARE NOT A FIRST OR
SECOND RIDER.
WHERE WERE YOU?
MARK: SEVENTH.
BRIAN: THAT IS A QUALITY TAKE.
NO, HE DID NOT.
THAT IS THE HIGHLIGHT OF THE
GAME.
MY DAY IS MADE.
I DON'T NEED A GRAND SLAM.
I DON'T NEED ANYBODY HITTING FOR
THE CYCLE.
MARK THAT DOWN FOR NEW QUALITY
TAKE.
ON A 3-2 LOOK AT THAT.
THAT IS GORGEOUS.
THAT IS STATE-OF-THE-ART PLATE.
AND THE BASES ARE LOADED.
MARK: HOW DO YOU NOT PULL THE
TRIGGER?
HE IS NUMBER ONE IN BASEBALL.
THAT IS A TRANSFERABLE SKILL.
MARK: MIKE TROUT IS ON THAT
LIST?
SARAH: MIKE TROUT IS ON EVERY
LIST.
BRIAN: NOBODY OUT, BASES LOADED
FOR GURRIEL.
IF YOU DON'T SPEAK THIS
LANGUAGE, HASN'T HIT AS OF YET.
SHEFFIELD IN TROUBLE AGAIN, ABLE
TO DANCE OUT OF IT IN THE FIRST
INNING WITH A LINE DRIVE DOUBLE
PLAY.
LOADED, NOBODY OUT.
RYAN: THERE IT WAS.
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD, IT IS NOT LIKE
HE IS MISSING BY A BUNCH.
THAT WAS A GOOD PITCH.
AS ONE OF THOSE PITCHES, JUST
GIVE ME THAT BLACK ONES.
BRIAN: ON THE WHOLE, MORE THAN
TWO RUNS SCORED WHEN YOU GET
THEM LOADED WITH NOBODY OUT.
BIGGIO, GRICHUK, AND SPRINGER ON
FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
NO SCORE HERE.
THAT IS A STRIKE.
MARK: IF HE CAN LOCATE THAT
PITCH, HE CAN MOVE THE SLIDER
AND BURY IT.
BRIAN: HE HAD 55 INNINGS, A 3.58
E.R.A. LAST YEAR.
RYAN: YOU CAN GET AHEAD IN THE
COUNT AND COMMAND ONE OR TWO
PITCHES, THAT SLIDER WORKS.
MARK: THE ONE THING WITH THAT
PITCH, IT IS SLOWER THIS YEAR.
THE MOVEMENT ON IT, THERE IS A
COUPLE MORE INCHES OF MOVEMENT.
IT IS MOVING A LITTLE BIT MORE.
IT IS BECAUSE HE IS THROWING
THAT PITCH SLOWER.
YOU HAVE TO RELY ON THAT PITCH
MORE BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T GOT
THAT FASTBALL, THEN YOU HAVE TO
START THROWING IT FOR A STRIKE,
HE STARTS SLOWING UP.
BRIAN: WHERE WERE YOU DRAFTED?
MARK: SEVENTH ROUND.
HAD TO GRIND.
BRIAN: AGAIN, TO YOUR HOMETOWN,
SEVENTH ROUND PICK, THAT IS A
REAL GUY.
GETTING YOUR OWN FOOD.
MARK: YOU DON'T WANT TO KNOW.
BRIAN: DRIVING YOUR DODGE DART
TO THE GAME.
MARK: SLEEPING ON A RAFT,
FIGHTING FOR MY LIFE.
BRIAN: NOWHERE TO PUT THEM, 3-2.
GURRIEL LAST YEAR SLUGGED .544.
NOBODY OUT, BASES LOADED.
BACK-TO-BACK YEARS, SLUGGING
OVER .500.
MARK: THE PITCH HE HAS COMMANDED
ALL GAME IS KIND OF THAT
BACKDOOR BREAKING BALL.
SARAH: THE JAYS HIT BREAKING
BALLS BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
BRIAN: PAYOFF PITCH, LIFTED INTO
RIGHT FIELD, THAT SHOULD BE DEEP
ENOUGH.
1-0, BLUE JAYS ON TOP.
MARK: THAT IS THE STUFF, IN
GAME, YOU HAVE A GAME PLAN
COMING IN YOU ARE SITTING THERE
WATCHING IT FOR AN INNING AND A
THIRD, YOU HAVE TO BE SITTING ON
THAT PITCH IN THAT SITUATION.
IT HAS FALLEN INTO A PATTERN
HERE EARLY COMMAND-WISE WHERE HE
FEELS THAT IS THE ONLY PITCH
WHERE HE HAS TO THAT HE CAN
THROW FOR A STRIKE.
RYAN: ON TOP OF THAT, HE IS
50-50 COMMAND, ESPECIALLY 3-2
COUNT.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE YOURSELF MIDDLE
OR MIDDLE AWAY JUST LIKE THAT.
BRIAN: HERE IS RILEY ADAMS, THE
CATCHER TODAY, HAS NOT HIT VERY
WELL SO FAR THIS SEASON.
SOME NUMBERS YOU DON'T NORMALLY
SEE.
AND -40.
DO NOT KNOW IT WENT THAT LOW.
SARAH: IT IS ALSO A SMALL SAMPLE
SIZE FOR HIM MARK: HIS
COUNTERPART HAS BEEN SWINGING A
HOT BAT.
I THINK THAT IS WHO CATCHERS,
BANGED UP, JANSEN AND KIRK DOWN
IN THE MINOR LEAGUES, I THINK
THEY STARTED THEIR REHAB
ASSIGNMENTS, RIGHT?
BRIAN: BIG SPOT HERE, FIRST AND
THIRD, ONE OUT.
BLUE JAYS TAKING A 1-0 LEAD.
TALK ABOUT DRAFT PICKS.
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD WAS A
FIRST-ROUND PICK, THE BOTTOM OF
THE FIRST ROUND.
36 OVERALL.
BIG EXPECTATIONS BEING DRAFTED
BY THE YANKEES IN THE FIRST
ROUND AND HE HAS NOT DELIVERED
AS OF YET.
ADAMS IS A THIRD ROUND PICK.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE VELOCITY,
YOU BETTER HAVE A REAL ARSENAL.
RYAN: THAT IS WHY HE -- HE HAD A
LITTLE BIT MORE VELO.
2019, VELOCITIES WERE UP.
HE CHANGED IT TO THAT TWO-SEAM,
TRYING TO GENERATE MORE GROUND
BALLS.
BELOW THE AVERAGE SPIN RATE.
BRIAN: 2-1.
RYAN: THE YANKEES TRADED HIM FOR
JAMES PAXTON, BIG TRADE, BIG
EXPECTATION.
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO AA TO WORK
WITH PITCHING COACH PETE
WOODWORTH.
BRIAN: A ROUGH WAY FOR DAVID TO
GET NOTICED, THE HOME PLATE
UMPIRE.
TOOK ONE OFF THE SHOULDER.
THE LOOK BACK, ARE YOU GOOD?
I GUESS.
[LAUGHTER]
IT IS STILL ATTACHED.
IN THE AIR, CENTER FIELD.
SEND HIM.
MARK: AS THE HITTER, YOU ARE
RUNNING DOWN THE FIRST-BASE
LINE, SENT HIM.
BRIAN: I THOUGHT INITIALLY HE
WOULD.
NOW YOU HAVE TWO OUTS, FIRST AND
THIRD.
I WILL SAY THIS.
RARELY DO YOU SEE A GUY GOING ON
THAT.
IF YOU ARE A THIRD BASE COACH
AND YOU HAVE A 95% SUCCESS RATE,
YOU ARE NOT DOING YOUR JOB.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME GUYS
THROWN OFF EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE.
YOU HAVE TO SEND GUYS AND TAKE A
50-50 SHOT, BE AGGRESSIVE.
MARK: IT IS SO HARD FOR AN
OUTFIELDER TO OCCASIONALLY MOOD
LIGHT THERE.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A PERFECT
THROW, DOES A CATCHER CAN ONE
HOP?
RIGHT THERE, IT IS A LITTLE TOO
SHALLOW.
BRIAN: RIVERA, THE THIRD BASE
COACH.
MARCUS SEMIEN, TOP OF THE ORDER.
YOU SEE THE WEIGHTED RUNS, PLUS
A HEALTHY 137, WALKED THE FIRST
TIME UP.
SHEFFIELD TRYING TO DANCE
THROUGH THIS.
HE IS CLOSE.
HE DID IT THE FIRST INNING.
THAT WOULD BE MASSIVE SUCCESS,
AFTER ALLOWING JUST ONE RUN.
THIS IS WHAT WE MEAN BY PUT UP
THE RUN EXPECTED, 0-2.
IF YOU GET OUT WITH ONE, YOU
DEFIED THE ODDS.
DEFENSIVE POSITIONING AT THIS
POINT IN THE MAJORS, SO
PINPOINT.
SARAH: ABSOLUTELY.
THE DEFAULT FONT IS MANNY
MACHADO STANDING IN RIGHT FIELD,
WHICH WE ARE ALSO USED TO.
SO SPECIFIC, SO MANY SPECIFIC
LITTLE PLOTS.
MARK: I DON'T WANT TO BAN IT.
MAYBE THE STICKY STUFF COMING
OFF THE BASEBALL.
I WAS JUST SEARCHING FOR SOME
MORE OFFENSE.
B.K., IF YOU COME UP TO THE
PLATE AND SEE THREE GUYS ON THE
LEFT SIDE OF THE INFIELD, I
THINK WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS GUYS
WOULD MAKE ADJUSTMENTS OF GOING
THE OTHER WAY.
THERE IS NOT THAT MANY COMPLETE
HATERS.
BRIAN: THERE ARE THOSE HITTERS,
BUT THEY ARE NOT GETTING
DRAFTED, THEY ARE IN HIGH A
BALL, NOT GETTING PROMOTED,
BECAUSE YOU WANT POWER GUYS.
MARK: I CAN'T MANIPULATE 97
EXPLODING WITH SPLIT ALL OVER
THE LOT.
ELIMINATE THE SHIFT.
BRIAN: LOW HANGING FRUIT.
IT IS SUCH AN EASY --
MARK: DO YOU THINK THE FANS
WOULD VISIT -- WOULD MISS IT?
LET THE ATHLETES BE ATHLETES.
BRIAN: WHAT YOU ARE DOING IS YOU
ARE PROTECTING THE
ONE-DIMENSIONAL HITTER AND THEN
THE CAVAN BIGGIOS OF THE WORLD,
YOU ARE STILL OUT ON YOUR OWN.
I KNOW YOU DON'T NEED THE SHIFT
BANNED FOR YOU.
MARK: I WOULD HAVE ATE THE SHIFT
ALIVE BECAUSE I COULD MOVE THE
BALL AROUND.
RYAN: A LITTLE BIT OF BUNT DOWN
THE LINE.
ADJUSTMENT.
BRIAN: WE ARE SEEING MORE OF IT.
RYAN: I THINK IF THE GAME CAN
SOMEHOW CORRECT ITSELF.
IT IS TOUGH, THE WAY PITCHERS
ARE THROWING NOW AT 97.
BRIAN: FIRST AND THIRD, TWO
OUTS.
SHEFFIELD WAS CLOSE.
MARCUS SEMIEN.
BICHETTE ON-DECK.
SEGER OFF THE GROUND BALL AND
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD IS DANCING
BETWEEN THE RAINDRONLY 1-0.
WE HAVE PLAYED TWO IN BUFFALO.
>> SWING AND A DRIVE, HIGH FLY
BALL TO LEFT FIELD.
VLADDY GUERRERO HOME RUN.
>> ONE HAS ALREADY COME INTO
SCORE.
THIS BALL IS CARRYING, THIS BALL
IS GOING TO GO.
HOME RUN FOR RANDAL GRICHUK.
THE THIRD HOME RUN FOR THE BLUE
JAYS, A THREE RUN HOMER.
VLADDY GUERRERO GOES AFTER THE
FIRST PITCH, HIGH AND DEEP TO
CENTER.
GONE!
HOME RUN, GUERRERO.
HE IS 2-2.
SWING AND A HIGH FLY BALL TO
LEFT FIELD.
THIS BALL IS GOING TO GO.
TO RUN HOMER.
ON THE FIRST PITCH AGAIN.
>> THE FASTEST IN TEAM HISTORY.
74 GAMES.
>> HERE IS ANOTHER ONE.
SWING AND A DRIVE, THIS BALL IS
DEEP.
I GRAND SLAM HOME RUN FOR
GURRIEL.
BRIAN: MLB THE SHOW 21 AVAILABLE
NOW.
XBOX GAME PASS.
RATED E FOR EVERYONE.
WE HAVE THE RESULTS NOW.
WHICH PLAYER WOULD YOU WANT WITH
THE GAME ON THE LINE?
VLAD JR.
WHO WOULD I PICK?
I HAVE AARON JUDGE BIAS.
RYAN: I AM GOING VLAD JR.
SARAH MENTIONED SOME OF THE
PLATE DISCIPLINE.
SARAH: I THINK I GO WITH VLAD.
THERE HE IS.
BRIAN: HE IS LIKE, I WON.
SARAH: THAT SERIES THEY HAD IN
FENWAY, I KNOW THEY LOST, BUT
THAT GAME-TYING HOME RUN HE HIT
IN THE NINTH INNING, IT WAS ONE
OF THE AT-BATS --
IT IS NOT A STAT, BUT IT IS A
REASON.
BRIAN: DYLAN MOORE, BASE HIT.
FIVE SINGLES NOW?
AT LEAST.
WE ARE ON A RECORD-BREAKING PACE
FOR 2021.
SARAH: THE MOST SINGLES AND A
GAME THIS YEAR, 24.
COMBINED.
BRIAN: THAT IS A LOT MORE THAN I
THOUGHT.
SINGLES ARE AT AN ALL-TIME LOW,
HAVE I LOST MY MIND?
MARK: WHY DO YOU HATE THIS
SINGLE?
BRIAN: I LIKE THE SINGLE.
MARK: IT IS GOING AWAY BECAUSE
OF YOUR SHIFT.
BRIAN: I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
CAVAN BIGGIOS OF THE WORLD HAVE
SUCCESS.
MARK: THERE ARE TABLE SETTER'S
AND TABLE CLEAR'S.
BRIAN: TEIXEIRA WAS VICTIMIZED.
MARK: I WAS A TABLE SETTER.
YOU CAN'T HAVE NINE TABLE
CLEAR'S.
-- TABLE CLEARERS.
BRIAN: TRAMMELL CAME OVER IN THE
TREVOR BAUER TRADE.
EXCITING YOUNG PLAYER.
MARK: ONE OF THE BEST BAT FLIPS
OF THE YEAR THE OTHER DAY
AGAINST LIAM HENDRIKS, FLIPPED
IT TO HIMSELF, CAUGHT IT, THEN
SHOCKED IT.
I THOUGHT HE SURPRISED HIMSELF.
BRIAN: TRIPLE SALCEDO -- TRIPLE
SALCOW.
MATZ HIS FIRST START SINCE MID
JUNE, A POSITIVE COVID TEST.
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO 2016, 25
YEARS OLD, 132 INNINGS, 3.40
E.R.A.
YOU ARE THINKING, YOU DO THAT AT
25, HE WILL BE A NUMBER TWO, IF
NOT A NUMBER ONE.
MARK: I CAME UP WITH 11, MADDUX,
AND SCHMALTZ.
GLAVINE, HE WOULD FORCE YOU TO
COMMIT TO IT.
STEVEN MATZ, THAT HAS BEEN HIS
M.O.
BRIAN: BOUNCING THAT OFF THE
WALL.
THEY ARE GOING TO SEND HIM.
COMING TO THE PLATE, BICHETTE,
ON THE GROUND, NO.
HE GOT AROUND, SCORING.
THAT BALL JUST EXPLODED TO THE
WALL.
I DID NOT KNOW IT WAS GOING TO
GO THAT FAR.
RIGHT OUTSIDE OF THE ZONE.
THAT TRAVELED.
RYAN: TAYLOR TRAMMELL, WHEN HE
FIRST CAME TO THE BIG LEAGUES,
OPENING NIGHT, HE JUST LOOKED
OVERWHELMED.
BRIAN: HERE IS DYLAN MOORE.
IT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE HE IS
FLANDE BUT WHAT I LOOKED UP, I
THOUGHT, NO, WE DON'T HAVE A
PLAY AT THE PLATE.
BUNT.
I HAVE SEEN EVERYTHING.
MARK: LOOK AT THIS.
BRIAN: J.P. CRAWFORD.
WE ARE SEEING SINGLES, BUNTS.
WAS THAT A HIT IN ERROR?
MARK: IT IS A HIT.
BRIAN: SARAH, TELL HIM, THEY ARE
ALL HITS.
MARK: I WOULD LOVE IT IF YOU
WERE AROUND WHEN I WAS.
BRIAN: IF YOU PUT THE BALL AND
-- IF YOU PUT THE BALL IN PLAY
AND YOU REACH BASE, THAT IS A
HIT.
YOU WANT TO TAKE THIS AWAY NOW?
MAKE THE DEFENSE DO SOMETHING.
NOW THEY GET A 2-1 LEAD.
LOURDES GURRIEL HAS ONLY PLAYED
THREE GAMES AT FIRST THIS YEAR,
ONLY SEVEN IN HIS CAREER.
BRINGS UP MITCH HANIGER.
FIRST PITCH BUNTING, UNEXPECTED.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT, SEATTLE IS A LITTLE
BETTER THAN YOU THINK.
THEY ARE AN ABOVE 500 TEAM.
SARAH: J.P. CRAWFORD, HE KNOWS
HE IS FAST COMING OF HE CAN PULL
THAT OFF.
THEY DON'T TAKE EXTRA BASES VERY
MUCH BUNT WE ARE SEEING MORE
AGGRESSION HERE TONIGHT THAN
THEY HAVE SHOWN IN THE SEASON
OVERALL.
BRIAN: MARINERS HAVE WON SEVEN
OF 10.
THEY TOOK TWO OUT OF THREE
AGAINST THE TWINS.
SWEPT FOUR AGAINST THE RAYS.
SPLIT TWO WITH COLORADO,
DISAPPOINTING.
TOOK TWO OUT OF THREE AGAINST
THE WHITE SOX.
IF YOU BEAT THE RAYS -- WHEN YOU
SEE THE RAYS PLAY THE YANKEES,
IT IS SAD HOW MUCH THESE LITTLE
WELTERWEIGHT'S ARE PUMMELING THE
HEAVYWEIGHT.
THIS AROUND THEM, CRUSH THEM,
BREAK THEIR SPIRIT.
THE MARINERS PLAYING THE RAYS
AND SWEEPING FOUR, I DON'T THEY
IS HAPPENSTANCE.
THEY ARE VERY BALANCED, SCRAPPY,
AND THEY CAN GET AFTER IT.
RYAN: AS CLICHÉ AS THIS SOUNDS,
BUT PITCHING, AGAINST THE WHITE
SOX, AGAINST THE RAYS.
THEIR BULLPEN, THEY HAVE A
COUPLE OF NAMES YOU HAVE NEVER
HEARD OF.
MARK: YOU GET ON A PLANE AFTER
SWEEPING TAMPA, SOMEONE IS
SAYING, WE CAN BEAT THESE GUYS.
BRIAN: TO BEAT THEM FOUR IN A
ROW IN A SERIES.
THE MARINERS, THEIR PAYROLL IS
$73 MILLION.
THEY ARE NOT SPENDING THEIR
MONEY RIGHT NOW.
JERRY DIPOTO HAS BEEN VERY
QUIET.
THEY ARE IN A SLOW REBUILD.
THERE ARE FEW TEAMS THAT ARE
GREATER THAN THE SUM OF THEIR
PARTS.
THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
MITCH HANIGER IS ONE OF THEM.
VERY BASEBALLY.
HE CAN RUN, FIELD, HE THROWS
WELL.
THIS YEAR, HE IS HITTING BOMBS.
BETTER THAN THE OVERALL
PRODUCTION.
MARK: WHEN JERRY DIPOTO HUNG THE
PHONE UP WITH JERRY VAN WAGENEN
AND UNLOADED ROBINSON CANO.
BRIAN: BIG STRIKEOUT THERE FOR
MATZ.
MITCH HANIGER STRIKES OUT TY
FRANCE -- STRIKES OUT.
TY FRANCE STEPPING UP.
TY FRANCE IS MIKED UP FOR US.
>> COACH CARSON.
WAY BETTER TODAY.
YESTERDAY, IT WAS HORRIBLE.
THE COLOR COMBO, IT MAKES THE
RED POP.
>> LOTS OF FASTBALLS DOWN THE
MIDDLE TODAY.
BRIAN: I WAS WONDERING, WHAT
BASEBALL THING IS HE TALKING
ABOUT?
HE IS ABOUT THE LINEUP.
MARK: HE USED TO DO IT IN
CALLIGRAPHY.
I LOVE A GOOD LINEUP CARD.
BRIAN: IT IS THE LITTLE THINGS.
RYAN: YOU GET TO THE END OF THAT
DUGOUT, YOU ARE LIKE, WE ARE
GOOD TODAY.
BRIAN: THAT IS IMPRESSIVE.
IT IS NICE WHEN IT IS READABLE.
MARK: WE ARE GOING TO PLAY LIKE
CHICKEN SCRATCH.
BRIAN: THAT IS WHAT THEY SAY IN
RAISING.
A DIRTY PART DOES NOT WIN A RACE
BUT IT SURE WILL LOSE ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN: TY FRANCE, 34TH ROUND
PICK.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
BUT, TORE UP THE MINORS.
HAS VERY GOOD NUMBERS RIGHT NOW.
.351 ON-BASE, .451 SLUGGING.
RUNS CREATED PLUS, 121.
TY FRANCE IS 26.
HE SLUGGED .770 IN EL PASO IN
AAA.
MARK: HE WAS STARTING FOR THE
PADRES FOR A LITTLE WHILE LAST
YEAR.
RYAN: I THINK FINALLY GOT A
CHANCE TO PLAY.
COMING OVER HERE WITH THE
MANAGERS COME A SAID, LOOK, WE
WILL TRAIN YOU IN THAT SNEAKY
LITTLE TRADE.
TRADING JERRY AND GETTING TY.
BASICALLY SAYING, LOOK, YOU WILL
BE IN THE LINEUP EVERY DAY.
WHEN YOU KNOW YOU ARE PLAYING
EVERY DAY, IT IS A DIFFERENT
VIBE.
BRIAN: 1-2 NOW TO FRANCE.
JP, YOU SPOKE TO JERRY DIPOTO.
WHERE TO SEE THINK THIS CLUB IS
THAT?
J.P.: AS HE DESCRIBED TO ME, IT
WILL BE A MODERN APPROACH, WHICH
MEANS BUYING AND SELLING
POSSIBLY, AS YOU WOULD NOT
EXPECT THE MANAGERS TO BE BUYING
SHORTER-TERM ASSETS AS WE SEE
MONTOYO STEPPING OUT OF THE
DUGOUT.
IN GENERAL, I WOULD EXPECT, IF
THE MANAGER -- IF THE MARINERS
SEE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
POTENTIALLY MOVIE MITCH HANIGER.
THEY HAVE JULIO RODRIGUEZ COMING
UP.
IT IS AN AREA OF STRENGTH.
THEY CAN REALLOCATE SOME ASSETS.
THEY HAVE THREE DIFFERENT
PLAYERS GOING TO THE FUTURES
GAME NEXT MONTH.
BRIAN: HAVING A CONVERSATION
WITH MATZ NOW.
A PHYSICAL ISSUE?
RYAN: I THINK THIS IS PURELY THE
FACT THAT HE SET OUT FOR 17
DAYS, YOU THROW IN THE FACT THAT
HE HAS NO THROWING PARTNER.
I THINK THE TRAINER IS COMING
OUT AND SAYING, YOU ALL GOOD?
YOU CAN TO FIGURE HE WILL BE
AROUND THE 60 70-PITCH MARK.
I THINK MITCH HANIGER IS KIND OF
THAT TIPPING POINT, ARE WE GOING
TO BE ALL IN FOR THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS OR IS HE STILL IN HIS
REBUILD MODE?
BRIAN: TEAM STARTED AROUND A
LITTLE FASTER THAN YOU THINK.
THAT IS A BIG OUT.
TWO OUTS NOW.
SO, YOU NEVER KNOW HOW CLOSE YOU
CAN BE.
YEARS AND YEARS AWAY, MAYBE NOT.
RINGS UP KYLE SEAGER, WHO IS IN
THE LAST YEAR OF HIS DEAL.
I THINK THEY HAVE AN OPTION ON
HIM.
UNLIKELY TO PICK THAT UP.
RYAN: HE HAS A CLUB OPTION FOR
NEXT YEAR.
IF HE DOES GET TRADED, IT THEN
TURNS INTO A PLAYERS OPTION.
THAT HAS BEEN A TOUGH PART OF
THAT.
MARK: TRADE ME.
BRIAN: WHAT IS THAT OPTION?
RYAN: I THINK IT IS AROUND 15,
18 MILLION.
BRIAN: REAL MONEY.
MARK: THERE ARE CERTAIN GUYS,
LIKE A LOOK AT ADAM WAINWRIGHT,
CHIPPER JONES, I CAN'T IMAGINE
THEM PUTTING ON ANOTHER UNIFORM.
KYLE, DOES HE VALUE THAT?
RYAN: I THINK HE DOES.
I SPOKE TO PERRY HILL THE OTHER
DAY.
ESPECIALLY WITH INFIELDERS, A
PROGRAM FOR BATTING PRACTICE
EVERY DAY, THE FIRST GUY OUT
THERE IS KYLE SEAGER.
THERE IS A LOT OF THIS THAT YOU
THROW IN THE MIX, ESPECIALLY THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
BRIAN: STEVEN MATZ, A SINGLE,
THEN A DOUBLE, THEN THERE WAS
THAT BUNT BASE HIT.
THAT HE HAS GOT TWO STRIKEOUTS.
TRYING TO GET OUT OF THIS ONE,
LEFTY VERSUS LEFTY.
BRIAN: SEAGER WAS A FIVE WIN
PLAYER.
HIS NUMBERS ARE DEFLATED PLAYING
IN SEATTLE BUT HIS DEFENSE WAS
EXCELLENT.
HE HAS LONG BEEN ONE OF THE
UNDERRATED PLAYERS IN BASEBALL.
RYAN: SWING AND MISS THIS YEAR.
CAREERWISE, HE USUALLY OWNS
LEFTIES.
THAT PITCH RIGHT THERE, THAT
SLIDER DOWN AND AWAY, LATELY A
PINCH HE IS SWINGING AT.
BRIAN: 3-1, AGAIN TRAVELING TO
LEFT FIELD, AND THAT IS GONE.
BIG TWO-RUN SHOT, KYLE SEAGER.
THERE MUST BE A WIND TUNNEL
GOING OUT TO LEFT FIELD.
THAT IS THE SECOND SHOT WE HAVE
SEEN HIT OUT THERE THAT GETS OUT
NARA.
TWO-RUN SHOT.
MARK: THAT IS A 3-1 COUNT.
UP IN THE ZONE, PEPPERING IT,
KIND OF FOLLOWING TAYLOR
TRAMMELL.
BRIAN: TRAMMELL HIT THAT TO LEFT
FIELD.
YOU SAW A LEFT FIELDER JUST LOOK
AND RUN.
OUT IN A HARRY.
RYAN: GOOD TO SEE KYLE SEAGER
GET A PITCH TO HIT.
HE LOOK AT SOME OF THE NUMBERS,
THE USAGE, USUALLY A SLIDER IS A
PITCH WHERE YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
ARE NOT SO MUCH GIVING IN.
KYLE SEAGER WAS LOOKING LEFT
FIELD ALL DAY.
BRIAN: THAT WILL DO IT FOR
STEVEN MATZ.
MATZ IS DONE, NOW GIVING UP FOUR
RUNS.
ALMOST GOT OUT OF THAT.
P ASIDE FOR A MOMENT.
BACK IN BUFFALO AFTER THIS.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> OH MY.
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
>> KNOCKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
BRIAN: STEVEN MATZ.
IT UNRAVEL ON HIM RATHER
QUICKLY, DIDN'T IT?
RYAN: IT DID.
THAT RELAY.
YOU CAN WRAP THIS UP TO THE
FACT, 17 DAYS OFF, THROWING ON
THE COVID IL STINT, NO ONE CAN
PLAY CATCH WITH HIM.
BRIAN: YOU SEE THE
DISAPPOINTMENT ON HIS FACE.
IT SEEMED LIKE HE WAS PITCHING
DECENTLY EARLY ON.
THORNTON, 35-PLUS INNINGS THIS
YEAR.
38 STRIKEOUTS, 14 WALKS.
HIS WALK RATE IS A LITTLE HIGH.
HE HAS GIVEN UP A BUNCH OF HOME
RUNS THOUGH.
EIGHT HOME RUNS IN 35 INNINGS.
THAT IS NOT GOOD, MISSED
OUTSIDE.
THE BLUE JAYS BULLPEN HAS BEEN
ONE OF THEIR WEAKNESSES.
KIND OF KEPT THEM DOWN IN THE
FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR.
SARAH: IT WAS GOOD TO SEE THEM
MAKE THAT TRADE FOR ADAM CIMBER.
THIS OFFENSE, WE NEED TO SEE
THAT.
BRIAN: CIMBER MIGHT BE AVAILABLE
TOMORROW IF NOT TONIGHT.
HE IS AVAILABLE TONIGHT.
MARK: I AM INTERESTED TO SEE HOW
THEY USE COREY DICKERSON.
I KNOW HE IS IN A WALKING BOOT
RIGHT NOW SO HE IS NOT
AVAILABLE.
HE CAN HIT.
DOES NOT SEEM LIKE THERE ARE TOO
MANY A.B.'S LEFT AND THAT
LINEUP.
BRIAN: BUY LOW ON A GUY.
LYLE DICKERSON HAS BEEN HURT.
LOOK WHAT HE HAS BEEN DOING THE
PAST FOUR YEARS.
119, 120.
THAT IS A PLUS HITTER.
3-1 NOW.
THE CATCHER FOULS THAT BACK.
3-2.
WE THOUGHT WE WOULD SEE SOME
BULLPEN HERE.
WE DID NOT THINK LUCY JUSTUS
SHEFFIELD WITH A 4-1 LEAD.
HE IS SITTING IN THE DUGOUT
GOING, I AM UP, I AM UP BIG.
I AM DOMINATING.
HE HAS GIVEN UP A BUNCH OF BASE
RUNNERS BUT JUST ONE RUN.
3-2.
BO BICHETTE FIRES IT TO FIRST.
THE BLUE JAYS OUT OF THAT
INNING, DAMAGE DONE THOUGH.
TWO-RUN HOME RUN BY KYLE SEAGER.
BOTTOM OF THE THIRD AFTER THIS.
>> THE ART IS PALPITATING.
-- HEART IS PALPITATING.
>> FOULED OFF TO THE RIGHT OUT
OF PLAY.
>> QUITE THE CATCH.
>> CASCADING DOWN FROM THE UPPER
DECK.
THE RIGHT-HANDED GRAB, BABY IN
TOW.
CAREFUL WITH THE LITTLE ONE
THOUGH.
>> THE PHANATIC WAS CHATTING
WITH JOE WEST.
JOE MUST'VE SAID SOMETHING.
OUT OF THE GAME.
>> THE WHOLE WEEK.
>> THAT IS CALLED -- IS COLD.
IT WAS ICE.
>> HE MAY BRING IN MAHOMES IN
RELIEF.
>> IS COACH TAKING A SELFIE?
>> HE IS.
I LIKE IT.
>> HE HAS SOMETHING IN HIS EYE.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE EVER
HEARD OF THAT KIND OF REMEDY.
>> YOUR LEG KICK.
YOU HAVE ONE OF MY FAVORITE
SWINGS BUT THERE IS NO WAY I CAN
DO WHAT YOU DO.
I WOULD NEVER BE ON TIME.
>> I USED ALWAYS WORRY ABOUT MY
LEG KICK AND STILL BE LATE.
BRIAN: THAT IS INCREDIBLE.
EVERYONE IS VERY FRIENDLY THESE
DAYS.
MARK: THAT IS WHY I LOVE TALKING
HITTING.
WHEN YOU LISTEN TO WHAT BO
BICHETTE SAID, NOW I WORRY ABOUT
MY UPPER BODY AND MY LOWER BODY
WILL CATCH UP, THAT IS SO THE
POLAR OPPOSITE OF WHAT 90% OF
THE LEAGUE IS THINKING.
IT IS ALWAYS IF YOUR LOWER HALF
IS ON TIME.
BRIAN: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR
HITTING, OK, HAVING A LITTLE
SEMINAR.
RYAN: THAT WAS A 10 SECOND
DATING LESSON.
BRIAN: HERE IS BICHETTE NOW.
HE IS NUMBER THREE IN BASEBALL
SWINGING AT THE FIRST PITCH 45%
OF THE TIME.
BASE HIT IN THE FIRST INNING.
THE WEIGHTED RUN SCREEN PLUS, A
HEALTHY .486 SLUGGING.
BICHETTE, GUERRERO, TEOSCAR
HERNANDEZ HERE IN THE BOTTOM OF
THE THIRD.
I CAN'T IMAGINE EVER MARTIN
GETTING ON FIRST BASE, JOHNNY
MIZE SAYS, YOU KNOW WHAT I DO
WITH MY LEG KICK.
GET LOST, PUNK.
LET ME GIVE YOU SOME FREE
ADVICE.
MARK: YOU WOULD BE SURPRISED.
SAILOR FIELD WAS THE FIELD THAT
JEFF MANVILLE DELTA.
HE WAS LIKE CRUSH DAVIS OF THE
MINOR LEAGUES.
I WOULD TRY TO GET TO FIRST BASE
TO GET HITTING LESSONS.
BRIAN: BY THE WAY, THAT WAS
EXCELLENT.
TY FRANCE COMES UP, IT'S TO
TALK, HEY, IT IS BO BICHETTE.
RYAN: THERE WERE TIMES WHEN I
WAS PITCHING, STRUGGLING, OVER
HAVING A CHAT, LAUGHING.
I AM LIKE, HEY, MAN.
BRIAN: BICHETTE PUTS THAT THE
OTHER WAY.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
OUTLAW.
I SAY REWARD BO BICHETTE FOR
HITTING AGAINST THE SHIFT.
BICHETTE NOW 2-2.
DID HE MEAN TO DO THAT?
OR DID THAT JUST HAPPEN?
MARK: I AM GOING TO SAY NO, HE
WAS NOT TRYING TO HIT A DRIBBLER
THROUGH THE 4-3 ALL.
BUT THE LEG KICK IS SO IMPACTFUL
BUT HE KEEPS HIS SHOULDER SO
SQUARED, HE IS NOT LIKE A GUY
CHEATING AT THINGS.
BRIAN: VLAD GUERRERO JR., STRUCK
OUT HIS FIRST TIME UP.
NUMBER ONE ATER AND THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE.
TAKES A STRIKE.
HE HAS TAKEN FOUR STRIKES SO
FAR.
MY WANT TO START SWINGING.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO START
SWINGING.
CHARLIE LOWE WAS A HEAD COACH IN
THE 1970'S, GEORGE BRETT.
LOOK IT UP.
MISSED OUTSIDE.
CAREFUL WITH MR. GUERRERO.
I SAW INDUCTION WEEKEND, WITH
HIS DAD, OUT THERE IN HIS SUIT,
SHIRTSLEEVES, PLAYING WIFFLE
BALL.
A LITTLE 17-YEAR-OLD KID RUNNING
AROUND, HITTING BOMBS IN WIFFLE
BALL.
I SAID, THAT IS VLADDY JR..
ABOUT TO COME TO THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
1-1.
I DID NOT EXPECT HIM THIS
QUICKLY TO BECOME THE NUMBER ONE
HITTER IN ALL OF BASEBALL.
ALL OF THAT PROMISE, NOW COMING
TO FRUITION.
IT IS A LOT OF FUN.
THE COMBINATION BETWEEN
GUERRERO, TATIS, SHOHEI OHTANI.
WE HAVE IMMENSE STAR POWER RIGHT
NOW.
MARK: SOTO.
BRIAN: 2-1.
BY THE WAY, SHOHEI OHTANI GOT
ROUGHED UP TODAY.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A SECOND.
HERE IS THE FIRST AT-BAT FROM
GUERRERO.
RYAN: GETS TO TWO STRIKES QUICK.
THAT IS THAT PLUS SLIDER.
THE ONE WHERE HE HAS TO GET
INSIDE THE STRIKE ZONE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
METRICS ON THAT PITCH.
WHEN HE GETS TO TWO STRIKES,
THAT CAN BE NASTY.
BRIAN: A NICE PITCH TO STRIKE
HIM OUT.
2-2.
HE HAS TWO STRIKES ON HIM NOW.
SHEFFIELD, A LONG LOOK AT
BICHETTE.
MISSED UP HIGH.
WHAT HAPPENED TO SHOHEI OHTANI?
OHTANI HAS BEEN BUSTED UP THE
YANKEES.
GUYS CHANCE ON THE MOUND.
SARAH: DID NOT MAKE IT OUT OF
THE FIRST INNING.
0.2 INNING, SEVEN RUNS.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT, WHEN HE IS
NOT ON PITCHING, THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT LACK OF CONTROL.
BRIAN: IT IS NOT EASY.
YOU GO FROM THE TOP OFFENSIVE
PLAYER, THEN HAVING TO START
TONIGHT.
MISSED DOWN LOW, WALKED HIM.
SARAH: CHARLIE MONTOYO WAS
SAYING BUT -- SAYING BEFORE THE
GAME, THAT IS WHAT HAS IMPRESSED
HIM, TAKING HIS WALKS.
HIS PLATE DISCIPLINE HAS BEEN
OFF THE CHARTS.
I KNOW WE SAW THAT SWING IN THE
FIRST INNING BUT OVERALL, IT HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLE AND THAT IS PART
OF IT, TAKING THOSE WALKS.
BRIAN: TWO ON, NOBODY OUT.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ STEP IN.
FANS RECOGNIZING HIS
BREAKTHROUGH SEASON.
MARK: THE VOTING STARTS OVER
NOW, RIGHT?
BRIAN: IS IT A FRESH START?
WOW.
SARAH: YEAH, TOMORROW.
BRIAN: DID NOT REALIZE THAT.
TOP THREE AT EACH POSITION, THAT
TOP NINE OUTFIELDERS.
BY THE WAY, HERNANDEZ IS ONE OF
THESE GUYS WHO HITS THE BALL
HARD AND HAS ENORMOUS SPRINT
SPEED.
HE IS DELIVERING.
SLUGGING NEAR .500.
IF YOU GET INTO THE STATCAST
NUMBERS, 85TH PERCENTILE-PLUS.
THERE IS ONLY FIVE GUYS WHO DO
THAT, WHO CRUSH IT AND CAN ALSO
EXPLODE WITH THEIR SPEED.
IT IS OHTANI, FERNANDO TATIS,
ACUNA JR., TYLER O'NEILL,
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ.
IT IS KIND OF EXPLOSIVE RATE.
AND HE IS ONE OF THOSE FIVE.
SARAH: THE POWER-SPEED COMBOS,
HE GETS LOST A LITTLE BIT MAYBE
JUST IN TERMS OF FAN AWARENESS.
HE HITS VERY FUN HOMERS FOR
STATCAST, FOR SURE.
BRIAN: WE SEE THE DEFENSIVE
POSITIONING, THE SECOND BASEMAN
STRAIGHT UP THE MIDDLE.
HIS BO BICHETTE RUNNING?
HE GOT DOUBLED OFF.
WHILE.
HE HAD A JUMP.
MARK: VLAD DID NOT KNOW HE WAS
GOING.
RYAN: THAT BIG LEG KICK FROM
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD.
WHEN YOU ARE TRYING TO MAKE A
PITCH THAT BAD, YOU FORGET ABOUT
THAT GUY AT SECOND BASE.
BRIAN: BICHETTE IS 12-12 IN
STOLEN BASES.
HIS EXTRA-BASE TAKEN PERCENTAGE
IS 55%.
THAT IS VERY HIGH.
ONE OF THE TOP BASE RUNNERS IN
BASEBALL RIGHT NOW.
THAT STAT, YOU CAN FIND IT ON
FANGRAPHS AS WELL.
VERY VALUABLE TO SEE WHO CAN
RUN.
HE HAS HAD TWO MONSTER JOBS.
GOT DOUBLED OFF ONE TIME.
THE OTHER TIME, IT DID NOT WORK.
0-2.
MISSED INSIDE.
DAVID RACKLEY HAS A GOOD STRIKE
ZONE.
MARK: ON THE ONES THAT ARE VERY
CLOSE THAT HAVE MISSED, HE HAS
BEEN VERY GOOD.
BRIAN: I DON'T EVEN NEED AN UMP
IF I HAVE THAT BOX.
BEEP, THAT IS IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE UMPIRES CAN
DO?
MOVING THE GAME ALONG.
PITCH, PITCH.
THE UMPS HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO.
MARK: EUGENIO SUAREZ AND MARCUS
TRYING TO PLAY FIRST AND SECOND
TOGETHER.
YOU TRY TO PUT PEOPLE IN PLACES
THEY DON'T NORMALLY PLAY.
YOU PUT ROBO UMPS BACK THERE,
YOU WILL HAVE GUYS PLAYING
CATCHER WHO WOULD NOT NORMALLY
PLAY CATCHER.
BRIAN: BIFF, ONE OF MY
FAVORITES.
THE UMPIRES CAN MOVE PITCHES
ALONG.
A PITCH EVERY 15 SECONDS, AND
ALSO LOOK FOR THE STICKY STUFF,
MAKE AN ARREST HERE AND THERE.
THEY WILL BE BUSY.
IT WILL BE LIKE 1890.
2-2.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ.
OH!
STRUCK HIM OUT.
IT WAS A BALL.
MARK: IF THAT BOX IS NOT THERE,
YOU ARE SAYING IT IS A STRIKE.
BRIAN: IT IS A BIT OUTSIDE AND
HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
THERE IS YOUR FRAMING.
LOOK AT LUIS TORRES.
COME ON!
MARK: YOU DON'T GET THAT PITCH.
RYAN: WE HAVE SEEN IT.
MAY HAVE BEEN OFF THE BLACK, BUT
WHEN YOU EXECUTE A PITCH LIKE
THAT, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE
STRUGGLING, IT IS THE BEST THING
EVER.
BRIAN: IT IS A GREAT FEELING
GETTING A BALL CALLED A STRIKE
WHEN YOU ARE A PITCHER.
RYAN: THAT IS A STRIKE ALL DAY,
I AM SORRY.
BRIAN: NOT IN THE ROBO ZONE.
GEORGE SPRINGER.
THAT IS A LONG AT-BAT FOR
HERNANDEZ.
HOW MANY PITCHES DENISI TH --
PITCHES DID HE SEE, NINE OR 10?
WOW, 6?
SARAH: I WASN'T GOING TO SAY IT
BUT THEY TOLD US.
BRIAN: YOU AND I HAD DISCUSSED
LIKE WORLD PEACE.
BY THE WAY, UMPIRES HAVE A LOT
TO DO.
ONE THING THEY HAVE FOUND WHEN
THEY HAVE ELECTRONIC STRIKE ZONE
, UMPIRES CAN THEN FOCUS.
SPRINGER SKIES THIS TO RIGHT
FIELD.
HANIGER SETS UP.
LOOK AT THIS.
THEY GOT HIM AT THIRD.
MITCH HANIGER.
BICHETTE DOUBLED UP FOR THE
SECOND TIME.
HE WANTS TO LOOK.
I LIKE THE WAY HANIGER CAME
FIRING.
MARK: AS GOOD OF A BASE RUNNER
AS BO BICHETTE IS, THIS IS NOT A
GOOD BASE RUNNING PLAY.
YOU DON'T MAKE THE THIRD OUT AT
THIRD BASE RIGHT THERE WITH A
LINEUP AS GOOD AS YOURS.
HE MIGHT BE SAFE.
HOLD ON A SECOND.
BRIAN: I LOVE THAT THROW.
YOU KNOW WHAT I LOVE?
I LOVE ACTION ON THE BASE PATH.
SINGLES, GUYS GETTING AFTER IT,
HANIGER FIRING A STRIKE.
THIS IS EXCITING.
HE IS SAFE.
MARK: TO YOUR POINT, THEY ARE
REVIEWING IT.
CAN YOU OVERRULE?
BECAUSE THAT IS HOW THE RULES
WORK.
BRIAN: CAN'T QUITE TELL.
LOOKS LIKE HE IS IN.
NOW, IF YOU ARE IN NEW YORK, DO
YOU FEEL CONFIDENT ENOUGH
OVERTURNING THAT?
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE ASKING.
MARK: I AM SURE THEY ARE SLOWING
IT DOWN MORE THAN THAT.
BRIAN: THEY CALLED IT SAFE.
WHY, WITH TWO OUTS, ARE YOU
TRYING TO GET THERE?
AGAIN, DO YOU LIKE BASEBALL?
DO YOU LIKE MITCH HANIGER AIRING
IT OUT?
LET'S SEE SOME ACTION.
I MENTIONED 1890, JUST JOKINGLY.
THIS IS WHAT BASEBALL LOOKED
LIKE.
GUYS WERE RUNNING, FIELDING.
DARING ON THE BASE PATHS.
RYAN: LOOKS A LOT LIKE ICHIRO,
2001, THAT FAMOUS THROW.
SARAH: ON THE FLY, PRETTY GOOD.
MARK: THE SAME ARM STRENGTH AS
RAMON LAUREANO.
BRIAN: MITCH HANIGER, TWO YEARS
AGO, ONE OF HIS BREAKOUT YEARS.
THE BASEBALL-Y PLAY OF THE DAY.
AT ONE TIME, I THINK IT WAS A
GAME AGAINST THE LATIN --
AGAINST THE YANKEES.
HE ATE THEM UP.
HE MADE A DIVING CATCH.
SINGLE-HANDEDLY DREW A WALK,
STOLE SECOND, SCORED ON A
SINGLE.
HE SINGLE-HANDEDLY BEAT THE
YANKEES AND LIKE THE NINTH AND
10TH INNING.
HANIGER IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS,
VERY BASEBALL-Y.
NORMALLY SARAH AND I ARE GOING
OVER THE NUMBERS AND ALGORITHMS
BUT YOU HAVE TO GET A LITTLE
BASEBALL-Y SOMETIMES.
FIRST AND THIRD.
THERE IS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
STRIKES THAT IS A BALL.
I WILL SAY THIS.
THIS OPENS UP -- MAYBE IT IS NOT
FOR THIS PITCHER, BUT THIS DOES
OPEN UP A PASSED BALL, WILD
PITCH.
IN THIS DAY AND AGE, WITH THE
STICKY STUFF, THE ACTION ON THE
SLIDERS, MUCH MORE OF A THING.
HIT HARD DOWN THE LINE, BASE
HIT.
BO BICHETTE WILL SCORE AND WE
GOT A PLAY AT THE PLATE.
DIVING IN, VLAD IS IN!
AND GRICHUK GOES ALL THE WAY TO
THIRD.
VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR., BEAUTIFUL
BASERUNNING, SCORED ALL THE WAY
FROM FIRST BASE.
MARK: B.K., THIS WAS LIKE PETE
ROSE DIVE AT HOME PLATE.
BRIAN: WE DID NOT GET A GOOD
LOOK AT HIM COMING AROUND.
BICHETTE HAS ALREADY TAKEN
THIRD.
JAKE BAUERS HAS TO DIG THAT OUT.
HERE IS A GOOD LOOK.
MARK: A LITTLE BIT UNDERNEATH.
BRIAN: DIED ON HIM.
MARK: THE RELAY.
BRIAN: J.P. CRAWFORD WITH THE
PICK AND A NICE THROW.
DID HE TOUCH HIM?
ANYWAY, 4-3.
TWO RUNS SCORE.
WE WERE TALKING TO CHARLIE
MONTOYO EARLIER TODAY.
HE SAID INSTINCTS ARE VERY HIGH
WITH VLAD JR.
BRINGS UP CAVAN BIGGIO.
BACK TO ONE OF OUR THEMES, THE
SONS OF MAJOR LEAGUERS,
THROUGHOUT MOSES, THEY ARE
LEARNING BASEBALL AS KIDS.
SARAH: VLAD IS FASTER THIS YEAR.
HE IS JUST BELOW THE MAJOR
LEAGUE AVERAGE IN SPRINT SPEED.
26.8 FEET FOR SECOND.
HE AVERAGES 27.
HE WAS AT 25.3 FEET FOR SECOND
LAST YEAR.
THAT IS A BIG IMPROVEMENT.
HE IS NOT GOING TO BE A BURNER
BUT BEING CLOSER THE AVERAGE AND
GO INTO THE NEXT YEAR ON A PLAY
LIKE THAT IS HUGE FOR THE BLUE
JAYS.
BRIAN: DROPPING THAT WEIGHT,
GETTING SERIOUS ABOUT YOUR
CAREER.
HE WAS THAT HEAVY AND YOU ARE
THINKING, 20 YEARS OLD.
MARK: BOBBY COX USED TO SAY, IT
IS YOUR
YOU ARE A SON OF A SUPERSTAR,
YOU ARE GOING TO BE GOOD.
BRIAN: GRICHUK IS DANCING.
YOU CAN SHIFT UNTIL THE COWS
COME HOME BUT DANCE DOWN THE
LINE, DARE THESE GUYS.
GOOD FOR GRICHUK.
IF YOU DON'T WANT ME TO DO THIS,
BUT A GUY ON THIRD BASE.
DARE THEM.
MARK: YOU MADE IT.
BRIAN: YOU MENTIONED PETE ROSE,
WHAT DO YOU THINK PETE ROSE
WOULD BE DOING?
STANDING AT THIRD BASE.
2-2.
GROUNDBALL TO THE SHIFT.
ALL RIGHT.
SHEFFIELD TALKING TO HIMSELF.
TWOMORE BOTTOM OF THE LINEUP.
WE HAVE GOT A NEW BALLGAME, 4-3
RIGHT NOW.
>> 4-3 IN BUFFALO.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
OH MY!
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT THEY
CAME FOR.
♪
BRIAN: BACK HERE IN BUFFALO AND
THERE IS VLADIMIR JUNIOR FROM
FIRST BASE, DIGGING HARD.
STATCAST IS POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
FIRST TO HOME AND JUST UNDER 11
SECONDS, BIG DIVE AND THEN A
CLOUD OF DUSTY.
YOU CAN SEE THE LEADERS THIS
SEASON.
YANKEES HAD THAT GOOD OF CONTACT
WITH THAT OFFENSE AT THIRD?
SARAH: THEY ARE UNDERPERFORMING
FOR WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
BRIAN: ASTROS, NUMBER ONE,
CRUSHING IT UP AND DOWN THE
LINEUP.
HE IS NUMBER ONE INDIVIDUALLY.
WE ASKED YOU WHICH AMERICAN
LEAGUE TEAM HAS THE BEST
OFFENSE.
ASTROS, BLUE JAYS, TWINS, OR
YANKEES?
FIRST FOUR WITH THE QUALITY OF
CONTACT.
VLAD JR. IN THERE, D.H.'ING
TODAY.
JAKE BAUERS LEADS OFF.
TOM MURPHY, DYLAN MOORE, FOR THE
MARINERS, WHO HAVE A 4-3 LEAD.
IT'S AN INTERESTING BALLGAME,
ISN'T IT?
THIS WAS ON MLB NETWORK LAST
NIGHT, I WAS WATCHING FROM HOME,
AND THIS WAS A NICE BASEBALL
GAME.
INTERESTING.
>> TWO TEAMS, VERY DIFFERENT
FROM WHERE THEY ARE AT.
MARINERS PUNCH UP PRETTY WELL.
RYAN: GIVING UP THE THREE RUN
HOME RUN LATE IN THE GAME, BUT
YES, IT'S INTERESTING.
YOU TALK ABOUT JUSTUS SHEFFIELD
WALKING THAT TIGHT ROPE.
THAT COMMAND OF HIS, THIS WILL
GET BACK AND FORTH.
YOU HAVE THE FEELING ALL NIGHT
LONG.
BRIAN: SITTING THERE, THE WAY HE
IS THROWING THE BALL, KIND OF
REMINDED ME OF ROBBIE RAY'S
NIGHT.
A 30 PITCHING INNING, GIVES UP
THE THREE RUN HOMER.
>> YOU CAN GO BEHIND THE SCENES,
CHECK OUT THE LATEST MIKED UP
CONTENT ON THE YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
SUBSCRIBE TODAY AT
YOUTUBE.COM/MARINERS.
>> BAUER STRIKES OUT TO BRING UP
TOM MURPHY.
D.H.'ING TONIGHT AND ALSO
CATCHES.
RYAN: THIS IS A GUY WHO IS
EXTREMELY OPPOSED TO THE ROBO
ARM, TOM MURPHY.
I SPOKE TO HIM ON MY PODCAST IN
THE OFF-SEASON.
BRIAN: HE IS A FRAMER?
RYAN: YES.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE NUANCE OF
FRAMING.
HOW WOULD CATCHING LOOK IF YOU
HAD A ROBO ARM?
A LAWN CHAIR WITH A GUY SITTING
BACK THERE.
BRIAN: FINE.
NICE.
LAWN CHAIR.
YOU KNOW, TV, WATCH YOUTUBE.
MARK: HERE IS MY TAKE ON WHY I
THINK IT SHOULD COME UP TV --
>> THAT HAS NEVER HAPPENED.
IT IS NEVER HAPPENING.
RYAN: GO AHEAD.
MARK: I THINK IT SHOULD.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET MAD AT
WHAT I AM ABOUT TO SAY.
YOU HAVE TO EARN A STRIKE ZONE
IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
BARRY BONDS DID NOT HAVE THE
SAME STRIKE ZONE IN HIS LINEUP.
HE DID IT.
YOU LOVE YOUR CAVAN BIGGIO AND I
GET THAT BUT CAVAN BIGGIO SHOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO JUST SPIT ON
PITCHES, DIME OFF THE DISH, AND
GET AWAY WITH IT.
BRIAN: I WILL SAY THIS.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
I'M CELEBRATING THE JOEY VOTTOS
-- I WOULD CELEBRATE THE JOEY
VOTTOS OF THE WORLD AND NOW THE
CAVAN BIGGIOS OF THE WORLD BUT
YOU GET TO THE POINT WHERE YOU
HAVE A WHOLE GENERATION OF CAVAN
BIGGIOS AND WE ARE PLAYING
LAWYER BALL.
I GET THAT.
WHEREAS THE IDEA IS -- THE
REASON BALLS AND STRIKES WERE
PUT IN IN THE FIRST PLACE IS YOU
ARE TALKING 1880'S, 1890'S.
THROW THE BALL TO WHERE YOU CAN
HIT IT.
THAT IS WHAT THE IDEA IS.
I'M NOT DISAGREEING WITH
EVERYTHING YOU'RE ARE SAYING.
A FAN NOW IN TV PRODUCTION
UNITS, YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT.
WHEN YOU ARE WATCHING THE GAME,
YOU ARE WATCHING THE BOX, THE
STRIKE ZONE.
RYAN: YOU CANNOT HELP BUT LOOK
AT IT.
IT IS IN FRONT OF THE CATCHER'S
GLOVE.
AND TO HIS POINT, YOU HAVE TO
EARN IT.
LIKE WE SAW WITH HIM, HE EARNED
IT.
I CAN UNDERSTAND IT.
DO LOVE THE FACT THAT THERE IS
THAT HUMAN ELEMENT EVEN IN THE
STRIKE ZONE.
BRIAN: WHY DO YOU LIKE THE HUMAN
ELEMENT?
I HAVE HAD DYLAN MOORE -- I
HEARD PEOPLE SAY THAT, I LIKE IT
SOMETIMES THAT I MISSED A CALL.
WHY DO YOU LIKE THAT?
WHY DO YOU LIKE HUMAN FAILURE?
"I LIKE HUMAN ERROR."
GO WALK ON THE STREETS.
THERE'S PLENTY OF HUMAN ERROR
AND FAILURE ALL AROUND YOU.
HOW ABOUT GETTING SOMETHING THAT
IS PERFECT?
RYAN: I LOVE WATCHING THE
MANAGER BLOWING UP --
BRIAN: WHY?
LET HIM CONCENTRATE ON HIS JOB.
MARK: BOBBY COX, STORMING OUT --
BRIAN: WHY ARE THEY THAT ELITE?
-- THAT ANGRY?
RYAN: BECAUSE THEY ARE FIGHTING
FOR THEIR BOYS.
BRING THE FIGHT SOMEWHERE ELSE.
MARK: MAXIMIZE PERFORMANCE FOR
YOUR PLAYER.
WE SAW THE CALL OVERTURNED WITH
BO BICHETTE.
THERE WAS A TIME A FEW YEARS
AGO, KIDS, THAT PEOPLE WOULD SAY
YOU HAVE TO GET EVERYTHING
RIGHT?
NO, YOU GET USED TO IT.
AND THE UMPIRE WHO DID NOT MAKE
THE RIGHT CALL, FINE.
YOU ARE A HUMAN BEING.
YOU MAKE MISTAKES.
GET IT RIGHT AND MOVE ON.
IT WAS A BIG DEAL AT THE TIME.
BRIAN: I'M TELLING YOU, ONCE YOU
CAN GET AWAY FROM THE THING
ABOUT EVERY CALL -- EVERY PLAYER
IS LIKE -- IT WAS A MILLIMETER
OFF.
ONCE YOU ARE AWAY FROM THAT,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S EITHER A
STRIKE OR IT IS NOT, AND THERE
WAS NO EVEN ARGUING ON THAT CALL
BECAUSE THEY WENT BACK TO NEW
YORK, THEY LOOKED AT IT, IT IS
WHAT IT IS, WALK OFF THE FIELD.
IT WILL BE THAT WAY FOR BALLS
AND STRIKES.
YOU DON'T BEEF, YOU TAKE IT, AND
PLAY, PLAY, PLAY, PLAY.
STOP BEATING ABOUT BALLS AND
STRIKES.
THERE, I'M DONE.
RYAN: CRUSHED FOUL INTO THE
BUFFALO NIGHT.
BRIAN: YOU ARE GOING TO REALLY
ENJOY IT.
YOU GET TO TELL THE UMPIRES, BY
THE WAY, THESE PITCHERS CAN
PITCH EVERY 15 SECONDS.
MAKE THEM DO THAT.
I COULD DO THAT RIGHT NOW,
TOMORROW.
MARK: 500 FEET TO LEFT CENTER.
BRIAN: I AM AN UMPIRE.
FINE, GOOD.
I WANT TO SEE SOME HOME RUNS.
3-2.
BO BICHETTE!
NO, NOT QUITE.
RYAN: HE IS A GOOD ATHLETE.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT DEFENSE,
TOO.
I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT SEMIEN AT
SECOND BASE.
HE HAS BEEN MAKING SOME AMAZING
PLAYS TO POP UP ON EVERY
HIGHLIGHT REEL BUT JUST AS FAR
AS SOUND DEFENSIVELY, I'M SURE
YOU GOT SOME DEFENSIVE NUMBERS
BUT HE IS GOOD.
HE FOUND A HOME AT SECOND.
MARK: BICHETTE IS A GUY WHOSE
CAREER SLUGGING IS OVER .500.
PLUS TWO DEFENSIVE RUNS SAVED.
HE SCORED EARLIER, HE FLEW
AROUND THE BASES IN THE SECOND
INNING.
SO YOU ARE RIGHT.
THAT GUY MOVES.
WE ARE SEEING ATHLETICISM.
GOOD FIELDING, GOOD RUNNING,
AGGRESSIVE PLAY.
THIS IS A DELIGHT TO WATCH.
SARAH: 29 FEET PER SECOND THAT.
BRIAN: STILL SECOND.
THE THROW GETS AWAY.
GOING TO GO TO THIRD.
THE DYLAN MOORE MAKING IT HAPPEN
ON THIRD BASE.
WHERE ARE YOU ON ADDING THE FAT
PART OF FIRST BASE, MEANING YOU
TRY THIS IN CERTAIN MINOR
LEAGUES, YOU ADD FIRST BASE --
TWO FOR SPACES, AND YOU ARE
CLOSEST TO SECOND.
AND YOU HAVE AN EDGE STEALING.
>> SCAM.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
BRIAN: YOU ARE ENCOURAGING
STOLEN BASES.
MARK: CAN WE COME UP WITH SOME
KIND OF BASE THAT IS NOT THIS
PLASTIC HARDSHELL YOU CAN POP UP
OFF OF?
WITH ALL THE TECHNOLOGY, WE
SHOULD HAVE A WAY TO HOLD THE
BAG.
SLIP ON IT.
BRIAN: YANKEES WINNING IN THE
40'S AND 50'S.
DUSTIN'S STUFF FLIES OUT OF THE
BAG BECAUSE IT IS NOT HARD AS A
ROCK.
IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE.
MAN ON THIRD, TWO OUTS.
2-0.
IT IS AN 18 INCH BASE INSTEAD OF
A 15 INCH BASE.
THREE INCHES ON BOTH SIDES.
SIX INCH ADVANTAGE TOWARDS
SECOND BASE AND IT WILL
ENCOURAGE STOLEN BASES.
DO YOU LIKE THAT?
RYAN: I LIKE THE FACT THAT YOU
ARE TRYING TO PUSH STOLEN BASES
AND THIS GOES BACK TO THE SAME
ARGUMENT.
IF SOMETHING -- I TALKED ABOUT
THIS TO YOU GUYS YESTERDAY ON
"MLB NOW."
IF YOU SEE A TREND IN THE
PLAYOFFS, CENTER STAGE, YOU
START SEEING A GUY WHO MAKES A
HUGE IMPACT WHO CAN RUN AT A
HIGH LEVEL.
I THINK THE GAME CORRECTS
ITSELF.
IT'S A BIT OF A PLUS RIGHT NOW
AS OPPOSED TO HAVING TO BRING IN
THIS SYSTEM, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
SHIFTS.
BRIAN: THAT SELF-CORRECTING
THING SOMETIMES DOES NOT HAPPEN.
RYAN: SLOWLY SELF-CORRECTING --
IT IS CORRECTING ITSELF.
YOU START TO SEE A LITTLE BIT
MORE AGGRESSIVE --
>> WE ARE TONIGHT.
SARAH, PLEASE TELL HIM, THE GAME
IS BEING SWALLOWED WHOLE BY THE
OUTCOMES.
IT IS THE SABERMETRICS FAULT.
>> NO ONE TO BLAME BUT YOURSELF.
>> IS LIKE THE NBA, A THREE
POINT SHOOTERS ON --
SHOOT-A-THON BECAUSE IT MAKES
SENSE.
4-3 BALLGAME.
STRIKE OUT ON TRAMMELL.
WE WILL SOLVE ALL OF THIS,
ESPE4-3 GOING TO THE BOTTOM OF E
FOURTH.
♪
>> ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW IS THE
STORY OF SIX-YEAR-OLD BRANDON
KELLY CAN'T UNDERSTAND THAT
GEORGE SPRINGER IS ON A MISSION.
>> THERE'S SO MANY BRIGHT YOUNG
KIDS OUT THERE WITH EXTREMELY
VIBRANT PERSONALITIES THAT ARE
SITTING IN THE BACK OF CLASS AND
HIDING.
>> SPRINGER KNOWS BECAUSE HE WAS
ONE OF THEM.
HE GREW UP WITH A STARTER WHICH
LED TO TEASING AND ANXIETY AND
SPRINGER SPENDING MUCH OF HIS
CHILDHOOD IN A SHELL.
>> IT WAS BRUTAL TO PUT IT
POLITELY.
I LOOK BACK ON IT AND IT IS SAD.
>> IN ANAHEIM, WHEN SPRINGER SAW
THIS, HE WENT RIGHT OVER, SIGNED
SOME AUTOGRAPHS, HAD A VERY
PERSONAL CONVERSATION, AND GAVE
AWAY HIS BATTING GLOVES.
THAT NIGHT, BRANDON WERE THEM TO
SLEEP.
-- WORE THEM TO SLEEP.
>> YOU CAN BE WHO YOU WANT TO BE
AND DO WHAT YOU WANT TO DO IN
LIFE.
IT'S JUST GOING TO TAKE YOU A
LITTLE BIT LONGER TO SAY WHAT
YOU WANT TO SAY AND THERE ISN'T
ANYTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
>> DETERMINED TO SPREAD HIS
MESSAGE, SPRINGER IS NOW THE
NATIONAL SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
STUTTERING ASSOCIATION
FOR THE YOUNG, A ROLE THAT HAS
FORCED HIM TO TRUST HIS VOICE.
>> THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY THE AUTHORITY OF
THE OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER
OF BASEBALL AND MAY NOT BE
REPRODUCED OR RETRANSMITTED IN
ANY FORM.
THE ACCOUNTS AND DESCRIPTIONS OF
THIS GAME MAY NOT BE
DISSEMINATED WITHOUT THE EXPRESS
WRITTEN CONSENT.
MLB ORIGINAL SEASON TWO IS LIVE
NOW ON YOUTUBE.
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE ON YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
A WIDE-RANGING CONVERSATION IN
THE MIDDLE OF A VERY NICE
BALLGAME.
4-3.
WE HAVE SEEN AGGRESSIVENESS ON
THE BASES.
FIVE OR SIX SINGLES ALREADY IN
THIS GAME.
LOURDES GURRIEL WILL START
THINGS OFF IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
FOURTH.
GURRIEL.
ADAMS AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
ORDER.
MARCUS SEMIEN.
IT HAS BEEN AN ENJOYABLE
BASEBALL GAME SO FAR.
4-3 GAME.
I'M SORRY, I LOST TRACK NOW.
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH SO MANY
THINGS.
WHAT WERE YOU BEATING ABOUT?
WHAT WAS I BEEFING
ABOUT?
MARK: WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
INCENTIVIZING THE HITTERS.
YOU HAVE CREATED THE SHIFT AND
PERCENTAGE PLAYS AND WE GUYS HIT
THE BALL AND IT WORKS.
THERE IS NO DENYING THE FACT
THAT IT WORKS.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS YOU FORCED A
GUY LIKE MYSELF, WHO IS NOT A
GUY THAT IS TRAINED OR GETS PAID
TO HIT 30 HOME RUNS IN A YEAR,
YOU FORCED ME NOW TO TRAIN
DIFFERENTLY IN THE OFF-SEASON
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO KNOCKS
ANYMORE.
I USED TO HIT DOWN ON THE
BASEBALL, SHOOT IT THROUGH THE
4-3 WHOLE. -- HOLE.
I CANNOT LEARN HOW TO PULL.
IT WAS NOT MY RHYTHM SWING.
I START THINKING I GOT TO GET
LAUNCHED.
BRIAN: DID THAT HAPPEN?
MARK: I WAS SHIFTING BARRY BONDS
YET I REMEMBER PLAYING SHORT
RIGHT FIELD AT ORACLE.
NOT MANY GUYS --
BRIAN: I WOULD THINK THAT YOU
WOULD BE A GUY -- WERE YOU
SHIFTED?
MARK: I ALWAYS PLAYED STRAIGHT
UP.
BRIAN: BECAUSE OF YOUR
ALL-AROUND GAME --
MARK: I WOULD NOT BE PLAYING
STRAIGHT UP IN TODAY'S GAME.
BRIAN: THERE WERE GUYS WHO
PLAYED STRAIGHT UP.
THERE ARE GUYS WHO WERE SHIFTED
AT NOT QUITE 0% BUT VERY, VERY
RARELY -- LIKE DJ LEMAHIEU IS
ONE OF THOSE GUYS.
DEREK JETER WAS NOT SHIFTED.
THE DEFENSE JUST, YOU HAVE TO
PLAY STRAIGHT UP.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE PLAYERS
LIKE THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM COME UP
BRING THE BALL -- SPRAYING THE
BALL.
HE IS LAUNCHING.
HE KNOWS WHAT YOU WANT.
YOU SAY YOU WANT ME TO HIT
SINGLES BUT YOU WANT ME TO
LAUNCH AND HIT BALLS.
ENCOURAGE THE KIDS TO HIT
SINGLES.
HE HITS BOMBS, RIGHT?
VICIOUS.
VICIOUS ANGLOS, STRAIGHT UP,
THIS KID.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT VISIO,
BICHETTE, GUERRERO, AND IT'S A
DIFFERENT MINDSET TO THE WAY I
TALK TO MY SON TO THE WAY
MY FATHER TALKED ABOUT THE GAME.
RYAN: YOU MAKE A GREAT POINT.
YOU MENTIONED THE WAY YOU
TRAINED THE OFF-SEASON.
GOOD CAREERS FIVE YEARS IN.
YOU HAVE TO GO OUT AND SHOUT OUT
THE VELOCITY AND SPIN IT AS HARD
AS THEY CAN.
NOT ANYTHING OF IMPORTANCE.
BRIAN: A HUGE KNOCK FOR RILEY
ADAMS HERE.
SECOND DOUBLE OF HIS CAREER.
RYAN, DERO, SARAH, HERE ARE
PLAYERS WHO ARE NOT SHIFTED
AGAINST.
I WANT YOU TO THINK OF THESE
PLAYERS HAD WHIT MERRIFIELD, --
PLAYERS.
WHIT MERRIFIELD, NICK MADRIGAL,
BO BICHETTE, THESE ARE THE
PLAYERS YOU WANT TO ENCOURAGE
AND INCENTIVIZE TO PLAY MAJOR
LEAGUE BASE AND YOU ARE LOOKING
TO PROTECT BRIAN MCCANN,
FRIENDS.
MARCUS SEMIEN STEPS UP TOP OF
THE ORDER.
MAN ON SECOND.
THESE ARE THE TYPE OF PLAYERS
YOU WANT.
YOU WANT THE YOUNG WHIT
MERRIFIELD OF THE WORLD TO PLAY
STRAIGHT UP.
IT'S LIKE TARIFFS.
YOU MAY NOT PLAY THE SAME WAY
AGAINST THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNABLE TO HIT IT THE OTHER WAY
YOU KNOW.
NO, I SAY.
HE HAS THE LOWEST SHIFT RATE IN
THIS GAME.
1%.
BARELY SHIFTED AGAINST.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE
PLAYERS.
SARAH: NICK MADRIGAL, ANOTHER
ONE BEFORE HE GOT HURT.
DAVID FLETCHER, ANOTHER.
BRIAN: ANOTHER BIG CONTACT THAT.
SHEFFIELD IS STILL IN THIS
BALLGAME.
THAT WAS NOT IN COLORADO.
AGAINST THE TWINS, GAVE UP SEVEN
RUNS IN FIVE INNINGS.
MARK: YOU THINK HE'S TRYING TO
SHOOT SOMETHING TO RIGHT FIELD
HERE?
>> DOES NOT LOOK LIKE THAT.
BRIAN: HE IS REACTING TO YOUR
INCENTIVES TO HE KNOWS WHAT YOU
WANT.
KIND OF A STRIKE.
2-1.
BY THE WAY, DAVID RADCLIFFE
BEHIND THE PLATE HAS BEEN A
PRETTY GOOD UMPIRE.
HE'S GOING TO MISS A FEW.
YOU ARE ON TWITTER MORE THAN ANY
OF US.
IN A PLAYOFF GAME, SOMETIMES,
I'M WATCHING A GAME AND I AM NOT
ON TWITTER AND ONLY LATER DO I
LEARN, HE'S GETTING CRUSHED ON
TWITTER.
I THOUGHT HE WAS DOING FINE YOU
MISS ONE OR TWO CALLS, YOU GET
CRUSHED.
THE LEVEL OF SCRUTINY IS FAR TOO
MUCH ON UMPIRES NOW.
SARAH: THAT IS THE NATURE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA AND THAT'S ANOTHER
PART OF IT AND THE BOX YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT, THAT PLAYS A
ROLE.
IF THERE IS NOT A BOX
NECESSARILY, PEOPLE SITTING ON
BOXES DON'T 100% KNOW UNLESS THE
BATTER GETS UPSET OR THE PITCHER
GETS UPSET BUT WHEN IT'S RIGHT
THERE, EVEN THOUGH EVERY STRIKE
ZONE IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT,
I THINK THAT MOTIVATES SOME OF
HIS REACTION SOMETIMES.
BRIAN: 2-2 TO SEMIEN.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO, DERO?
YOU GOING TO BAN THE BOX?
YOU LIKE BANNING BOOKS?
IT'S A SCHOOL LIBRARY.
YOU CANNOT DO THAT.
YOU CANNOT GO BACKWARDS, DERO.
AS A FAN, I WAS THE SAME WAY.
WHEN IT FIRST HAPPENED A FEW
YEARS BACK, IT'S CONTROVERSIAL.
DO YOU PUT THE BOX ON THE SIDE
OR RIGHT AT THE PLATE?
NOW, WE PUT IT RIGHT ON THE
PLATE AND THAT'S HOW YOU FOLLOW
THE GAME.
OF COURSE IT IS GOOD.
MARK: -- RYAN: IT IS A TOUGH
TIME TO BE IN UMPIRE.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS GOOD THAT THEY
CAN DO THIS.
EVERYONE WATCHING THIS GAME
KNOWS EXACTLY IF THIS IS A BALL
OR A STRIKE.
THERE IS NO GRAY AREA.
BRIAN: THE 3-2.
SWUNG AT THAT HIGH IN THE ZONE.
RYAN: THEY WILL BE DOING THEIR
FORENSIC CHECKS EVERY TIME A
PITCHER WALKS OFF THE MOUND,
TOO.
NOT TO MENTION TO YOUR POINT
WITH THE ROME ARMS -- ROBO ARMS.
IT'S A TOUGH GIG RIGHT NOW.
BRIAN: YOU TAKE THE PRESSURE OFF
THE UMPIRE TO CALL BALLS AND
STRIKES AND THEY CAN ENFORCE THE
LAW IN A VARIETY OF WAYS.
THESE GUYS ARE COPS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO.
YOU LOOK AT THESE GUYS, YOU KNOW
3-2 AGAIN.
THERE IS THAT BOUNCED FOUL.
THERE IS THAT TRADITION.
JOKING, HOWEVER, 19TH-CENTURY
BASEBALL, YOU HAD A VERY
PHYSICAL GAME.
A DANGEROUS GAME, PLAYED OUT.
THE HOLE KILLED THE UMP -- THE
WHOLE KILL THE UMP THING.
THEY WERE LARGE COPS WHO COULD
FISTFIGHT AND CONTROL THINGS.
BY THE WAY, YOU HAVE SEEN SOME
OF THOSE GUYS.
LET THEM PUSH THE PITCHER ALONG
AND THEN INSPECT THEM.
SARAH: I WAS ON A RETRO CHIC DAY
AND THE REASONS THAT GUYS GOT
EJECTED ARE CRAZY.
THESE DAYS, BALLS AND STRIKES,
ARGUING BALLS AND STRIKES,
ARGUING A CALL.
I AM NOT CONDONING ANY OF THIS
BUT IT'S CRAZY.
WE HAVE RECORDS FROM THE 1910S
AND SAYING THAT IS WHY A GUY WAS
EJECTED FROM THE GAME SO TO YOUR
POINT, IT WAS A VERY DIFFERENT
MIND NURSING WORD OF
ENVIRONMENT.
BRIAN: DIFFERENT ERA, KIDS.
3-2 AGAIN TO MARCUS SEMIEN.
THE BALL IS HIT HARD LEFT FIELD.
OFF THE WALL.
DIDN'T GO OUT.
THAT WILL DRIVE IN A RUN.
>> KEEP US THERE.
KEEP COMING AT YOU.
BRIAN: MARCUS SEMIEN DRIVES AND
ANOTHER RUN.
MARK: HE IS AN INTERESTING
PLAYER, MARCUS SEMIEN.
HE IS GOING TO GO OUT ON THE
OPEN MARKET AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR WITH THE LIKES OF STORY AND
CORREA AND SEAGER AND ALL THESE
MONSTERS.
BRIAN: BAEZ.
YOU KNOW IT'S FUNNY?
THE PREGAME SHOW, OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS, HE IS BETTER.
HIGHER THAN ALL OF THOSE GUYS.
BIG FIVE SHORTSTOPS.
THE ONLY GUY THAT'S ACTUALLY
HITTING WITH HIM OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS NOW IS CORREA.
SEAGER DOES, TOO.
ALL HIT ABOUT THE SAME LEVEL.
HIM HAVING THE SEASON NOW, IT'S
GOING TO BE WORTH $100 MILLION.
I MEAN AN EXTRA 100 MILLION.
HE'S GOING TO BE GETTING PAID.
SARAH: HE SHOWED SO MUCH
VERSATILITY.
HE LEARNED A NEW POSITION SO HE
CAN PLAY SHORT OR SECOND.
HE IS PROBABLY BETTER
DEFENSIVELY AT SECOND.
>> BO BICHETTE, INSIDE-OUT
SWING, GROUNDS OUT TO FIRST.
TY FRANCE GETTING MIKED UP.
LET'S LISTEN TO HIM WITH VLAD
JR..
>> NOW, YOU GOT TO STEAL SECOND.
YOU GOT TO TAKE SECOND NOW.
FIRST MOVE.
I WILL TELL THEM NOT TO PICK UP.
>> IN AND KIDDING, BRO -- I
AIN'T KIDDING, BRO.
>> YOU GOT TODAY.
-- TO DIG.
>> SAFE!
>> THAT IS GREAT.
BRIAN: TY FRANCE, ENGAGING FIRST
BASEMAN.
HERE IS VLAD GUERRERO JR.
WALKED THE LAST TIME UP BUT THEN
HE SAW THE EXPLOSION AROUND THE
BASES.
MARK: THIRD AT-BAT -- RYAN:
THIRD AT-BAT.
HE GOT THE FIRST ONE WITH THE
SLIDER.
0-2.
VLAD GOT A PRETTY GOOD LOOK.
THIS IS A TOUGH MATCHUP FOR
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD.
>> MISSES THE INFAMOUS THIRD --
THIS IS THE INFAMOUS THIRD TIME
THROUGH.
HE IS 2-0.
THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE HITTER IN
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
LOOK AT THE SLUGGING WITH
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
HE IS BELOW BARRY BONDS, SINCE
1995.
HE IS THERE WITH MAGUIRE.
BY THE WAY, HE MIGHT BE IN HIS
OWN CATEGORY IF YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M SAYING.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
IT'S A DIFFERENT TIME THEN TOO.
2-0 TO VLAD JR..
WHAT AM I IMPRESSED WITH IN THIS
GAME?
VLAD JR. GOING FROM FIRST TO
HOME.
BASERUNNING IS EXCITING.
MITCH HANIGER THROWING TO THIRD.
BASE RUNNING, THROWING, IT'S
EXCITING.
>> TAYLOR TRAMMELL HIT A ROCKET
OFF THE WALL.
BRIAN: THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE IT
TO HIM NOW.
IS THAT SCOTT SERVAIS?
PART OF THAT MARINERS BULLPEN
THAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT'S BEEN PRETTY GOOD.
THAT IS A STRIKE.
RYAN: I WILL BE HONEST, I'M KIND
OF SHOCKED.
ANYWHERE NEAR THE STRIKE ZONE.
PLAYING WITH FIRE.
TRYING TO BATTLE BACK.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
TWO OUTS.
GET HIM TO CHASE THAT SLIDER,
TYPICAL 0-2 SLIDER.
BRIAN: ESCALATES.
THE O.P.S. AGAINST.
3-1, TWO OUTS, MAN ON THIRD,
BATTLING BACK.
3-2.
I ADMIRE THE CHUTZPAH OF HIM
HERE.
I THINK I'M GOING TO GET AFTER
YOU RIGHT NOW.
PUT HIM ON.
YOU HAVE TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ
ON-DECK AND THEN GEORGE PRINTER.
YOU ARE GOING TO DEAL WITH
SOMEBODY.
SHEFFIELD HAS NOT GIVEN IN ON
THIS AT-BAT.
THERE IS THE BREEZE 0-2 LEFT.
SIXTH PITCH OF THE AT-BAT.
3-2.
GOT IT ON THE INSIDE.
JUST ENOUGH.
RYAN: I HAVE A FEELING YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO SEE IT.
3-2.
JUST DON'T HANG IT.
BRIAN: MARCUS SEMIEN AROUND
THIRD.
TWO OUT BALLGAME, TIED UP 4-4
NOW.
TAFT PITCHED ONCE AGAIN.
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD BATTLES BACK.
3-1 AND STRIKES OUT VLADIMIR IM.
MOST IMPRESSIVE.
WE HAVE A TIE BALLGAME.
BACK IN BUFFALO FOR A MOMENT.
-- IN A MOMENT.
♪
>> THE BRAVES BLOWING OUT THE
METS NOW.
8-1.
2-2 PITCH.
A RUN WILL SCORE.
THAT MAKES IT AN 8-2 GAME.
>> PIAZZA SCORES AND IT IS 8-3.
>> BALL FOUR FORCES HOME A RUN.
FORCES HOME ANOTHER RUN.
OUTSIDE, BALL FOUR.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS?
A THIRD CONSECUTIVE BASES LOADED
WALK.
>> BASES-LOADED.
IT IS AN 8-6 ATLANTA LEAD.
>> BASE HIT INTO LEFT FIELD.
THE GAME IS TIED.
>> HE RIPS IT.
GOODBYE HOME RUN.
CENTER FIELD WHAT A COMEBACK.
THE METS WIN IT 11-8.
♪
BRIAN: EACH WEEK THIS SEASON ON
OUR BROADCAST, WE WILL FOCUS ON
A YOUTUBE CONTENT CREATOR
FEATURED IN OUR LIVE GAME
COMMENTARY SECTION.
OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT SHINES ON
FIVE POINTS VIDS.
THORNTON BACK ON ONCE AGAIN FOR
THE BLUE JAYS.
4-4 BALLGAME.
TOP OF THE ORDER, J.P. CRAWFORD,
MITCH HANIGER, TY FRANCE.
FROM THORNTON GETTING IN THE
WORK, -- TRENT THORNTON GETTING
IN THE WORK.
1-1.
RYAN: A COUPLE INNINGS, A TOUGH
MONTH OF JUNE, 6.97 E.R.A. FOR
THORNTON.
A CHANCE TO GET TO THREE UNDER
YOUR BELT, GET BACK ON TRACK.
BRIAN: HIS CURVEBALL SPIN RATE,
TOP FIVE IN BASEBALL.
DID NOT KNOW THAT.
STATCAST RESEARCH TEAM.
THAT'S. PART OF THE MODERN GAME
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS -- THAT
IS PART OF THE MODERN GAME OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
DOES NOT HAVE TO HAVE SUCCESS.
DOES HE HAVE SOMETHING ON ONE
PITCH?
AND THEN HE CAN WORK AROUND THAT
BUILD OFF?
RYAN: YOU SEE THAT COMPLETELY
CHANGE.
THE GUY HAS HAD A TON OF SUCCESS
, COMPLETELY ELIMINATE THE
TWO-SEAM FASTBALL, GO STRAIGHT
FOUR-SEAM.
WHY ARE YOU WASTING YOUR TIME
WITH THIS PITCH?
IT'S BEHAVING MEDIOCRE, IF YOU
WILL, FORCING THE FASTBALL THE
TOP OF THE STRIKE ZONE.
AND THEN THIS IS THAT
GENERATION, TOO, WHERE YOU SEE
60% CURVEBALLS.
BRIAN: SLAPPED THE OTHER WAY,
ANOTHER BASE HIT.
MARK: WE HAVE TO START LOVING ON
MR. J.P. CRAWFORD HERE A LITTLE
BIT.
RYAN: THAT APPROACH, TOO.
WHEN WE TALKED TO HIM BEFORE THE
GAME, ALL OF A SUDDEN, OUT OF
LEFT FIELD.
BRIAN: THE WAY HE APPROACHES IT
--
MARK: THAT'S PLAYING PEPPER WITH
THE BASEBALL.
HE IS A TABLE SETTER AND HE
KNOWS IT.
HE WILL OCCASIONALLY TRY AND
JUMP YOU.
BRIAN: BRINGS UP MITCH HANIGER,
STRUCK OUT HIS LAST TIME UP,
MADE THE BIG THROW FROM RIGHT
FIELD.
RYAN: THE PHILLIES COULD USE
J.P. CRAWFORD RIGHT NOW.
BRIAN: JUST NOT PERFORMING.
IN FOR A STRIKE FROM THORNTON.
ALSO, HIS SPIN RATE HAS NOT GONE
DOWN SINCE THE CRACKDOWN.
IF YOU WILL.
SO PERHAPS HE FOUNDED HONESTLY.
J.P. MOROSI IS IN BUFFALO.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
J.P.: YES, BRIAN, AND WE HAVE A
DRIVE TO LEFT.
BRIAN: AND THAT BALL IS GONE.
MITCH HANIGER WITH A TWO-RUN
SHOT.
HOLD THAT THOUGHT.
HANIGER LAUNCHES ANOTHER HOME
RUN.
SARAH: 419 FEET.
BRIAN: HE IS HIT FOR REAL POWER
THIS YEAR.
MARK: HE HAS BEEN STRUGGLING OFF
BREAKING STUFF AND HAS BEEN ALL
OVER THE HEATER AND THIS IS A
BREAKING BALL SITTING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PLATE 0-0 AND HE
DESTROYS IT.
BRIAN: 18TH HOMER OF THE YEAR
FOR MITCH HANIGER.
MARK: DOESN'T MATTER.
-- RYAN: DOESN'T MATTER, TOO.
TALK ABOUT THE STRUGGLES AGAINST
BREAKING BALLS, YOU HAD THE
BREAKOUT IN 2019.
HE CAN GET BEAT ON THAT GOOD
BREAKING BALL WITH THE CHANGEUP
OUT IN FRONT AND STILL HAVING TO
DRIVE IT.
BRIAN: 6-4, SEATTLE UP ON TOP.
HANIGER THIS YEAR, NOT LIKE HIS
BREAKOUT YEAR.
ADDING AVERAGE IS FAIRLY THOUGH.
I KNOW IT'S LOW ALL AROUND THE
LEAGUE.
HIS ON-BASE IS .302, BUT HE IS
SLUGGING .490 COMING INTO THE
GAME.
THAT IS HIS 18TH HOME RUN, NOT
NEAR THE ALL-STAR BREAK YET.
THERE IS A BASE HIT TO RIGHT AND
SEATTLE TAKES A 6-4 LEAD BUT
HANIGER AGAIN, STILL AND
EXTRACTIVE CORNER OUTFIELDER.
RYAN: 2019 IS WHEN HE WAS
DEALING WITH SOME INJURIES,
TRYING TO PLAY THROUGH IT.
THE ENTIRE YEAR OF 2020.
SPRING TRAINING, HE DID NOT MISS
A BEAT.
COMING BACK, NO TIMING ISSUES
WHATSOEVER.
TORE IT UP IN SPRING TRAINING,
AND OFF HE GOES.
BRIAN: THEY WENT TO THE WELL
WITH THORNTON GOING FOR A THIRD
INNING.
MAKES THE PITCHING CHANGE.
AND AGAIN, YOU HAVESO ANTHONY KE
LEFT-HANDER.
WE STEP AWAY FOR A MOMENT.
6-4, MARINERS IN THE FIFTH.
>> WHO IS YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS
-- PUSH YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS TO
THE TOP.
THE GOOGLE MLB ALL-STAR BALLOT.
>> SOMETHING TO CHEER ABOUT.
>> GO TO MLB.COM/VOTE OR SEARCH
FOR YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS ON
GOOGLE.
VOTE BAILEY, TURNING THE MAJOR
STARS INTO ALL-STARS.
>> WHAT CAN'T HE DO?
>> THE TOP THREE OF EACH
POSITION WILL ADVANCE.
AND THEN IT'S TIME TO GET THEM
TO THE PEAK BY VOTING FOR THE
ALL-STAR STARTER.
HELP PUT YOUR TEAM ON TOP.
>> WHAT A GAME.
>> FANS, THE SECOND ROUND OF
ALL-STAR VOTING HAS BEGUN.
>> IT'S TIME TO VOTE.
NO EXCUSES.
GET ON YOUR PHONES AND VOTE.
>> VOTE NOW.
>> YOU HEARD THEM.
HEAD TO THE BALLPARK OR VISIT
BLUEJAYS.COM/ALL-STAR AND MAKE
THESE GUYS ALL STARTERS.
THERE'S NO TIME FOR EXCUSES.
IT'S TIME TO SEND THEM TO
COLORADO FOR THE 2021 ALL-STAR
GAME.
BRIAN: KYLE SEAGER HOMERED HIS
LAST TIME UP.
STATCAST IS POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT THIS. TOP
OF HIT FIELD, 98 MILES PER HOUR.
ONLY .350.
HE BARELY GOT IT OUT.
A TWO-RUN HOME RUN FOR SEAGER.
HE STEPS UP AND THEY BRING IN
THE LEFT-HANDER, ANTHONY KAY.
HE PITCHED LAST THURSDAY.
HE STARTED AND PITCHED FIVE
SHUTOUT INNINGS.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
RYAN: BIG PROSPECT OVER THE
MARCUS STROMAN DEAL.
E.R.A., 5.19.
PITCHING OUT OF THE BULLPEN,
2021.
BRIAN: YOU KNOW, HE WENT TOWARD
MILLVILLE HIGH SCHOOL OUT ON
LONG ISLAND.
I ONLY KNEW THAT BECAUSE I
STUDIED -- AND I SEE ANTHONY KAY
IS FROM STONY BROOK.
WHO KNEW?
SARAH: MARCUS STROMAN IS ALSO
FROM LONG ISLAND AND PITCHED
AGAINST HIM IN HIGH SCHOOL.
BRIAN: 1985.
I'M COVERING THE STORY AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL AND OUT ON THE EAST
END OF LONG ISLAND, THERE IS
WALT WHITMAN HIGH SCHOOL.
1-0 TWO KYLE SEAGER.
HIT HARD RIGHT FIELD AND DROPS
DOWN FOR A BASE HIT.
MEN ON FIRST AND SECOND.
I GET OUT THERE FRESH OUT OF
SCHOOL.
I'M INTERVIEWING PEOPLE AND THEY
SAY, BRIAN, YOU PROBABLY WANT TO
TO THIS IS WORD MILLVILLE.
I'M LIKE, FROM THE 1800S?
[LAUGHTER]
THE SCHOOLS ARE LIKE WALT
WHITMAN FROM WHALING TIMES ON
THE EASTERN END OF LONG ISLAND.
TURNS OUT HE WAS A BUSINESSMAN
IN THE 1940'S AND 1950'S, RAN
THINGS, AND DONATED LANDS,
HELPED BUILD STONY BROOK
UNIVERSITY, AND HAD A HIGH
SCHOOL NAMED AFTER HIM.
SHE WAS AN OLDER WOMAN BUT SHE
WAS NOT FROM THE 1800S.
THAT IS MY STORY.
MARK: I THINK YOU SHOULD TELL
EVERYBODY YOU WERE BABYSAT.
BRIAN: TWO ON, NOBODY OUT
AGAINST ANTHONY KAY.
J.P. MOROSI IS STILL OUT THERE.
J.P., YOU ARE SAYING?
J.P.: BEFORE MITCH HANIGER
RUDELY INTERRUPTED US, MY STORY
ABOUT CRAWFORD.
JACOB NOTTINGHAM, WHO IS A
FORMER MILWAUKEE BREWER, COMES
OVER TO THE MARINERS EARLIER
THIS YEAR.
THEY HAD KNOWN EACH OTHER FROM
PLAYING TRAVEL BALL TOGETHER IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND COME TO
FIND OUT, J.P. REALIZED HE WAS
ACTUALLY USING A LARGER BAT THAN
NOTTINGHAM AND NOTTINGHAM SAID
MAYBE YOU CAN ACTUALLY USE A
LITTLE SMALLER BAT AND HOW ABOUT
YOU TRY MY MODEL.
TURNS OUT HE TRIES IT THAT NIGHT
, HAS A BIG NIGHT, AND HE STAYS
WITH IT, AND AFTER A FEW DAYS OF
USING BE NOTTINGHAM MODEL, IT IS
CALLED THE NEW J.P. CRAWFORD
MODEL AND HE HAS KEPT HITTING SO
A BIG ASSIST BY JACOB NOTTINGHAM
IN WHAT HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS
RUN OF HITTING BY J.P. CRAWFORD.
BRIAN: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M GOING TO CALL ON JON MOROSI
NOW.
STARTED THIS INNING WITH A BASE
HIT, SCORED ON THE MITCH HANIGER
HOME RUN.
NOW YOU HAVE SECOND ON THIRD ON
THE BALL THAT GOT AWAY AND IT IS
2-0 TO LUIS TORRENS.
JAKE BAUERS IS ON DECK FOR
SEATTLE.
I THINK IT WILL BE A SCRAPPY
GAME AND IT IS.
SEE THIS AGAIN.
A WILD PITCH.
I HAD NO IDEA.
LOST FEELING.
IT DOES CHANGE YOUR THINKING,
TOO.
YOU BRING IN A LEFT-HANDER TO
FACE SEAGER.
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
YOU HAVE TO FACE THREE-BAGGERS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M FINE WITH
IT NOW.
KIND OF MAKES SENSE.
SARAH: I DON'T THINK YOU ARE
THAT AWARE WITH IT.
>> I DON'T THINK IT WAS A HUGE
DEAL TO BEGIN WITH.
BRIAN: IT WAS THIS ARTIFICIAL
IMPOSITION OF STRATEGY.
BAUER IS THE LEFT-HANDER ON DECK
.
HOWEVER, YOU CAN DO IT -- YOU
DON'T HAVE TO FACE RE-.
YOU CAN END -- THREE.
YOU CAN END IN INNING.
I DON'T MIND.
MARK: I USED TO BE ON THE
ON-DECK CIRCLE.
AND I WOULD BE LIKE, COME ON.
BRING THEM IN.
PLEASE DON'T, PLEASE DON'T,
PLEASE DON'T.
IT IS ALL MATCH UPDATES.
IF, RIGHT-HANDED HITTER AND I
SAY BRING THE LEFTY IN FOR
SEAGER, I KNOW I GET UP.
RYAN: FROM A PITCHER'S
STANDPOINT, YOU HAVE TO DEVELOP
THAT THIRD PITCH.
YOU HAVE TO DEVELOP SOME WEAPON
TO GET RIGHTIES OUT.
BRIAN: IT IS A SMALL THING BUT
IT HAS LED TO BIG THINGS AND
GOOD THINGS.
THAT IS A RULE I INITIALLY DID
NOT LIKE.
I KIND OF LIKE SEVEN INNING
BALLGAME'S TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
DOWN LOW.
3-2.
BY THE WAY, ANTHONY KAY AND
STEVEN MATZ ARE THE ONLY MAJOR
LEAGUERS.
AND I KNEW HER.
>> HE TOLD ME ANTHONY KAY HAS
ADDED THAT THIRD PITCH.
HE ADDED MORE OF A CUTTER, 14 TO
15% OF THE TIME, KIND OF KEEP
THOSE FRIDAYS ON THIS YOU SEE A
LOT OF LEFTIES WANT TO POWER
THAT BALL IN ON RIGHT-HANDERS.
BRIAN: 3-2 TO TORRANCE NOW.
A DEFENSIVE OUTLOOK FOR YOU.
SWING AND A MISS.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS SOBERING, DERO?
I TOLD YOU THIS STORY, 1985.
ANTHONY KAY, BORN 1995.
[LAUGHTER]
OH MY GOD.
THAT TOOK THE AIR OUT OF ME.
SARAH IS THINKING, IN 1985, WERE
THOSE YE OLDE WHALING TIMES?
SARAH: TO ME, IT IS, BUT I WAS
NOT GOING TO SAY.
BRIAN: IT BRINGS UP JAKE
BAUERS'S LEFT-HANDER.
SINGLED AND STRUCK OUT, TAKES A
STRIKE.
TOM MURPHY IS ON DECK.
I WILL POINT OUT, THE MARINERS
ARE -49 IN RUN DIFFERENTIAL
COMING IN AND YET THEY ARE TWO
GAMES OVER 500, THEY HAVE WON
10-14.
INFIELD COMES IN NOW AND SCOTT
SERVAIS HAS DONE A NICE JOB.
HE HAS HAD BIG TEAMS THAT
UNDERPERFORMED.
A SCRAPPY TEAM THAT OVER
PERFORMS.
I LIKE THAT.
A LOT OF IT COMES DOWN TO, YOU
KNOW, WE DID AND ALL MLB NOW
TEAM, DERO.
I WILL INTRODUCE THAT TO YOU.
AND IT IS GUYS WITH NOT A LOT OF
POWER.
LET'S BUILD A TEAM.
A LOT OF IT WAS PLATE
DISCIPLINE, CONTACT,
BASERUNNING, FIELDING, AND
FIELDING MULTIPLE POSITIONS.
ONE THING WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
IS POWER BUT YOU CAN GET A LOT
OF THOSE GUYS MULTI-POSITION
PLAYERS WHO CAN RUN AND IF THEY
HIT FOR CONTACT, BIG STRIKEOUT.
HE HAS TO OUTS.
YOU CAN PUT TOGETHER A TEAM.
MARK: I WAS ON A SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS TEAM THAT WON THE WORLD
SERIES.
YOU CAN BE PITCHING GOOD DEFENSE
UP TO SHOOT.
I WILL FIGURE OUT A WAY TO SCRAP
THREE ACROSS.
BRIAN: WHAT YEAR WAS THAT?
MARK: 2010.
HE WAS A GODSEND.
BRIAN: EVEN THE GIANTS DID THAT
A FEW YEARS LATER.
LET'S GET THEM CONTACT.
IT IS AN EXPENSE EFFECT.
YOU STILL NEED THE STARS.
YOU NEED GUYS TO HIT FOR POWER.
YOU CAN GET BY WITH MUCH MORE.
TOM MURPHY STEPS IN.
HE IS 0-2.
>> THEY HAVE THE ABILITY.
THEY ARE 18-7 IN ONE RUN GAMES.
THE RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
THEIR NUMBERS GO THROUGH THE
ROOF.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A TWO
STRIKE APPROACH, RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION APPROACH, BUT
FIND A WAY TO GET THE BIG HIT,
THE CLUTCH.
SEATTLE HAS GOT IT.
BRIAN: WOULD YOU LIKE TO WAY AND
ON THAT?
-- WEIGH IN ON THAT?
MARK: I THINK YOU ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE CLUTCH IF YOU HIT
FOR CONTACT, IF YOU PUT THE BALL
IN PLAY.
BETTER THINGS CAN HAPPEN.
WHAT IS THE ANALYTIC?
BRIAN: WIN PROBABILITY.
MARK: THERE IS A CLUTCH --
SARAH: WE CAN MEASURE IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN SAY YOU
ARE MORE CAPABLE OF IT THAN
SOMEBODY ELSE, BUT WE CAN
MEASURE IT AFTER THE FACT.
BRIAN: MIKE YASTRZEMSKI LEAD THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE IN WIN
PROBABILITY LAST YEAR.
MARK: DAVID ORTIZ WAS PRETTY
CLUTCH.
BRIAN: VERIFIABLE.
AND BILL JAMES WROTE ABOUT IT,
GODFATHER OF THE SABERMETRIC
MOVEMENT, SAYING THIS SHOULD NOT
BE HAPPENING.
IT IS HAPPENING.
THREE OUT OF FOUR YEARS, BIG
PAPI --
THERE ARE GUYS WHO ARE ROUTINELY
A LITTLE HIGHER THAN THEY SHOULD
BE.
FREDDIE FREEMAN IS ONE OF THOSE
GUYS.
MARK: I WANT TO SEE WHICH GUYS
STAY COOL.
BECAUSE YOU DO SEE THAT AS WELL.
BRIAN: STRIKE OUT THE SIDE.
YES, HE DID.
ANTHONY KAY AFTER SOME EARLY
DAMAGE, STRIKES OUT BOWERS AND
MURPHY IN A ROW TO GET OUT OF
IT.
DID HE GO?
NOW, DID THE HOME PLATE UMPIRE
GET THAT?
THEY POINTED TO FIRST.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY GOT THAT.
SWINGS, ALSO NONSENSE.
IT'S A BALL.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT AFTER.
♪
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE!
♪
>> HANIGER OUT TOWARDS THE
TRIANGLE, OUT TOWARDS --
GOODBYE, GONE!
HOME RUN!
WHAT A BOMB IN THE 10TH!
IT COMES WITH TWO MEN ABOARD AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE MARINERS
HAVE BLOWN THE DOORS OFF OF
FENWAY AT 7-3.
THIS IS TORCHED.
WAY, WAY BACK, NUMBER ONE!
FIRST HIT, FIRST HOME RUN OF THE
SHOW, JARRED KELENIC, WELCOME TO
SEATTLE.
>> 1-1.
HIT WELL.
THAT IS GOING TO GET IT DONE!
GRAND SLAM TO WALK IT OFF.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
6-2 FINAL.
>> THE MARINERS HAVE SWEPT THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE DEFENDING
CHAMPION TAMPA BAY RAYS FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY.
>> WHO IS WRITING THE SCRIPT?
♪
BRIAN: TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ, GEORGE
SPRINGER, AND RANDAL GRICHUK.
STATCAST IS POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD, TONIGHT'S ENHANCED
STATCAST BROADCASTS.
BRIAN HERE WITH SARAH LANGS.
JON MOROSI IS WITH US IN BUFFALO
AND TASKER HERNANDEZ IS MIKED UP
-- TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ IS MIKED
UP.
>> MY BAD.
I SHOULD HAVE GONE EARLIER.
>> IT IS OK.
WHAT HAPPENS BY HIT THE BALL IN
THE GAP?
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT'S GREAT, TOO.
BRIAN: THE NATURAL REACTION,
COME ON.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
I'LL BE SORRY.
STEALING A BASE.
MARK: SAID, I SHOULD HAVE GONE
EARLIER.
IT CAN KIND OF MISS YOU -- MESS
WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT.
BRIAN: HE'S GOT SOME HIGH
LEVERAGE, DOESN'T HE?
RYAN: HERE IS ANOTHER GUY FOR
THE BULLPEN.
HE HAD A COUPLE YEARS D.F.A.
THROWS 74% SLIDERS.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IDENTIFYING A PITCH.
SOME OF THE GUYS WITH THE PITCH
USAGE.
COMES OUT WITH SECONDARY STUFF,
LITERALLY SLIDERS ALL DAY LONG.
BRIAN: PITCHED TO JAPAN LAST
YEAR AND THE DODGERS BEFORE
THAT.
21 INNINGS, 22 STRIKEOUTS, THREE
WALKS.
THAT IS GOOD IN ANY LEAGUE.
RYAN: HE FEELS BETTER COMMANDING
THAT SLIDER THAN HE DOES WITH
THAT FASTBALL.
MARK: LAYING IT UP RIGHT THERE.
BRIAN: HERNANDEZ TO RIGHT FIELD.
HANIGER BRINGS THAT IN.
ONE OUT.
WE ASKED YOU WHICH TEAM HAS THE
BEST OFFENSE.
THE ASTROS AND THE TWINS AND THE
YANKEES.
HERE IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY.
WE HAVE A LITTLE BIASED GOING.
64% FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
ASTROS, I THINK THE BLUE JAYS
ARE A TEAM -- HE WASN'T DOGGING,
SO TO SPEAK, THE BLUE JAYS.
SAY NOTHING.
I WATCH THESE GUYS ONCE, AND I
ALREADY KNOW I'M GOING TO WIN.
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE THESE GUYS IN
THE SECOND HALF.
BLUE JAYS GETTING TOGETHER,
SPRINGER IS BACK DOWN.
1-2 IN THIS GAME.
IF THEY GET THE BULLPEN PUT BACK
TOGETHER, NOT THRILLED WITH
THEIR ROTATION.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, THE RAYS
ARE DOING IT WITH SMOKE AND
MIRRORS.
THE YANKEES ARE A FLAWED CLUB
AND THE RED SOX ARE NOT THAT
GOOD.
THESE GUYS WILL WIN THIS
DIVISION.
MARK: I AM 100% WITH YOU.
I THINK THE RED SOX ARE A LOT
BETTER.
THE EFFECT IS REAL AND IF THEY
GET HIM BACK, THEY BECOME A
MAJOR PROBLEM.
THE YANKEES ARE FLAWED.
THE ROTATION IS FLAWED.
THEIR DEFENSE IS FLAWED.
THERE BASERUNNING IS FLAWED.
THERE IS A LOT THERE.
AND TAMPA, I FEEL, EVENTUALLY --
I DON'T KNOW.
THEY ARE ABLE TO GET RID OF
CHARLIE MORTON AND BLAKE SNELL.
IF GLASNOW DOES NOT GET HURT, I
THINK IT IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
THEY HAVE TO FEEL THE EFFECTS OF
THAT AT SOME POINT.
BRIAN: THE RAYS ARE A
REVELATION.
THEY ARE OUTSTANDING.
RED SOX I THINK, YOU ARE
PROBABLY RIGHT.
LONG WAY TO GO.
SARAH: THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS WITH THEIR PITCHING.
I THINK ALL THE QUESTIONS WE HAD
-- THE BLUE JAYS AS WELL.
THAT IS KIND OF THE STORY OF A
LOT OF THIS VISION.
WITH THE RED SOX, THEIR PITCHING
PROBABLY OVER PERFORMED IN THE
FIRST 1.5 MONTHS OR SO.
THE REAL ANSWER IS SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN.
J.D. MARTINEZ, HAVING GREAT
YEARS, CENTER BOGAERTS, RAFAEL
DEVERS, GUYS BOUNCING BACK, BUT
PITCHING QUESTIONS, JUST LIKE
THIS TEAM.
BRIAN: 2-2, SPRINGER.
HIT HARD LEFT FIELD.
HE HAS A GLOVE ON IT AND WAS
ONLY ABLE TO KNOCK IT DOWN.
THAT BALL WAS PROBABLY WAFFLING
IN HIS DIRECTION, SMOKED.
RYAN: THAT BALL WAS ABSOLUTELY
CRUSHED.
MARK: YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
PITCHING AND WE ARE GOING TO
SHOW GEORGE SPRINGER ABSOLUTELY
HAMMERING.
BRIAN: I WANT TO SEE HOW HARD IT
WAS HIT HERE IN CATCH
PROBABILITY IS NOT GOING TO DO
IT.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT BALL WAS
KNUCKLING.
THEY ARE ALL HITS.
DERO, WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT?
STILL.
MARK: JAKE BAUERS IS A FIRST
BASEMAN BY TRADE.
IS THE BALL KNUCKLING?
THERE'S A LOT OF VARIABLES.
BRIAN: IT IS NOT A MAJOR LEAGUE
PARK.
THERE COULD BE A WEIRD LIGHTNING
THING.
SARAH: TALKING ABOUT THE WEIRD
WIND OFF THE LAKE.
BRIAN: LOOK AT THAT.
LOOK AT THAT.
BY THE WAY, WHEN WE PLAY HITTER,
WE WILL BRING YOU ON "MLB NOW."
YOU WOULD BE AMAZED -- THEY JUST
GIVE THEM HITS.
THAT'S BASICALLY 109 MILES PER
HOUR.
SMOKED.
RYAN: IF I'M PITCHING RIGHT NOW,
YOU CANNOT HELP YOURSELF BECAUSE
I GET IT.
GLANCING UP AT THAT SCOREBOARD.
STEAMING.
BRIAN: I GO BACK TO 19TH-CENTURY
BASEBALL.
YOU CAN LEARN A LOT ABOUT
BASEBALL WHEN YOU LEARN ABOUT
HOW IT ORIGINATED.
12 ERRORS A GAME AT ONE POINT IN
THE MAJOR LEAGUES.
12.
AT THAT POINT, THE MAJOR THING
TO KNOW IN A BALLGAME WAS WHAT
IS A SINGLE, WHAT IS AN ERROR?
NOW, WE ARE DOWN TO ONE ERROR
PER GAME, PER TEAM.
MOST HITTER ERRORS ARE JUST LIKE
THAT.
HE COULD HAVE MADE THE PLAY BUT
IT WAS HIT HARD.
THEY ARE ALL HITS.
IT'S A BASE HIT.
YOU CAN PUT THE BAT ON THE BALL.
THAT WAS A TOUGH PLAY.
MOVE OVER, SLIDING TO THE LEFT.
MARK: A BIG-LEAGUE OUTFIELDER
PUTS THIS IN HIS BACK POCKET.
BRIAN: IF YOU ARE ACTUALLY
EVALUATING THAT DEFENSIVELY,
THAT IS A MISPLAY.
RYAN: -- SARAH: THAT IS THE
THING.
YOU JUST NEED DIFFERENT
TERMINOLOGY.
MIS-PLAY IS A PERFECT WAY TO PUT
IT.
TALK ABOUT MENTAL ERROR, NOT THE
WAY YOU SHOULD PLAY THAT, IT IS
STILL DIFFERENT FROM ERROR TO
ME.
MARK: YOU CAN BASE IT OFF EXIT
VELOCITY.
BRIAN: NOW YOU ARE GETTING
SOMEWHERE.
THE CROWD GETS EXCITED.
GRICHUK FLIES OUT.
I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO HEAR IT
FROM THE FANS.
BY THE WAY, NEW TO THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK FOR 2021 IS THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME WHERE
FANS WATCHING ON MOBILE DEVICES
CAN VOTE FOR WHICH PLAYER WILL
RECEIVE THE TROPHY DURING THE
POSTGAME SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE OPTIONS LATER
DURING THIS PROGRAM.
MATT CHAPMAN, SHOHEI OHTANI.
SHOHEI OHTANI, SHOHEI OHTANI,
SHOHEI OHTANI.
HERE IS CAVAN BIGGIO, WHO HAD
THE PLAY OF THE GAME.
A QUALITY TAKE EARLIER IN THIS
CONTEST AND A WALK BACK IN THE
SECOND.
PROBABLY A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
VOTE THAT WAY.
DO THAT ON YOUTUBE.
QUALITY TAKE OF THE DAY.
COME ON, KIDS.
PLAY ALONG.
SEE HIS NUMBERS, LESS THAN
IMPRESSIVE BELOW LEAGUE AVERAGE.
COMES BACK FROM HIS INJURY FOR A
VERY DIFFERENT HITTER.
SARAH: HE HAS BEEN HITTING .288.
BRIAN: KIND OF LOOKING AT THE
BALL.
THEY ARE ALL HITS.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT CHECK
SWINGS.
ONE OF THE RULES WAS FOR THE
ATLANTIC LEAGUE, NO MORE CHECK
SWINGS, MEANING YOU EITHER SWING
THROUGH, BUT IF YOU HOLD UP,
IT'S NOT A SWING.
I HAD NOT EVEN -- IT BLEW MY
MIND.
LET'S STOP TRYING -- YOU SWING
AND SWING THROUGH OUR YOU HAVE
CHECKED YOUR SWING.
IT MAKES LIFE EASIER.
>> I ASKED SO MANY UMPIRES OVER
THE COURSE OF MY CAREER WHAT
CONSTITUTES GOING AND THEY ALL
HAVE A DIFFERENT ANSWER.
BRIAN: 2-1 TO BIGGIO AS HE
PONDERS THAT TAKE.
RYAN: CEMENT MIXING A LITTLE
BIT.
THAT'S USUALLY A PITCH, LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE NUMBERS.
100 AGAINST THAT PITS, THROWING
IT 74% OF THE TIME.
SARAH: I LOVE THAT BECAUSE THE
BLUE JAYS ARE THE BEST TEAM IN
BASEBALL SLUGGING.
WE WILL FIND WHICH ONE IS MORE
TRUE.
RYAN: IT WON'T BE 6-4 FOR MUCH
LONGER.
BRIAN: SO MUCH SCORING, YOU CAN
SMELL IT.
GOOD HITTING BY BIGGIO.
SPRINGER STAYS AT THIRD.
I WAS SURPRISED AND DISAPPOINTED
BY CAVAN BIGGIO'S SWING CHART.
170 POUNDS, CAN YOU HIT THE BALL
THE OTHER WAY?
I DID NOT THINK HE WAS A POLE
HITTER.
MARK: YOU KNOW THIS GUY HAS A
75% SLIDER, GETS A 2-0 COUNTS,
TAKES A CEMENT MIXER AND IS ABLE
TO DRIVE THE NEXT ONE THE OTHER
WAY.
PROCESSING PITCH TO PITCH.
THERE IT IS.
BRIAN: THERE IS THE CHART.
10% AND 4% TO THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE FIELDS.
NOT MUCH OF ANYTHING.
THEY ARE PLAYING IT THAT WAY.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE IS COMFORTABLE
SLAPPING AT THE OTHER WAY.
I AM SURPRISED WE DON'T SEE MORE
OF THAT.
HE IS TRYING TO DO THAT.
THAT IS NOT HAPPENSTANCE.
RYAN: I FEEL WE ARE SEEING MORE
AND MORE OF THIS.
GUYS GET TO TWO STRIKES, THE TWO
STRIKE APPROACH.
BRIAN: DERO SAYS HE CAN DO THAT
AGAINST MODERN PITCHING.
CLEARLY YOU CAN.
MARK: THEY HAVE TO INCENTIVIZE
IT.
I AM WATCHING JAVY BAEZ SWING
FROM HIS HEELS.
BRIAN: LOURDES GURRIEL TAKES ONE
ON THE INSIDE PART OF THE PLATE.
HIS PROCESS IS NOT
STATE-OF-THE-ART.
HIS TALENT, BUT NOT PROCESS.
1-3, TWO OUTS.
YOU SEE SPRINGER AND BIGGIO.
A BASE HIT DRIVING IN A RUN.
A 6-5 GAME.
FINDING A HOLE ON THE RIGHT
SIDE.
GOOD HITTING BY GURRIEL.
MARK: -- RYAN: A LITTLE
PROTECTING SWING BY THE
FASTBALL, CATCHING OFF BALANCE.
JUST ENOUGH.
HE IS USING THE FASTBALL WAY
MORE TONIGHT.
BRIAN: WE HAVE 10 SINGLES IN
THIS GAME.
RAPIDLY APPROACHING THE ALL-TIME
RECORD THE LAST TWO SEASONS.
SEES -- IT IS AT AN ALL-TIME
LOW.
TO SEE 10 SINGLES, YOU ARE
SEEING SOMETHING EXCELLENT.
SINGLES WE HAVE SEEN GUYS GO
FROM FIRST TO THIRD AND FROM
THIRD TO HOME.
A LOT OF OLD TIME HE BASEBALL
STUFF.
RILEY ADAMS DOUBLED HIS LAST
TIME UP.
MARK: THESE ARE THE MOMENTS.
BRIAN: TWO ON, TWO OUTS.
RYAN: GETTING THE LINEUP MORE
OFTEN.
MARK: YOU HAVE TO MAKE A NAME
FOR YOURSELF.
SOME GUYS ARE GETTING TO COME
BACK UP, THAT JANSSENS OF THE
WORLD.
BRIAN: TONIGHT, COURTESY OF
FANDUEL.
THE OVER-UNDER 10.5.
IN THE SIXTH, 6-5, MARINERS --
IN THE FIFTH, 6-5, MARINERS.
I AM HAVING A GOOD TIME.
TATIS, THREE HOMER GAME.
I THINK IT WAS ON "MLB TONIGHT."
JOEL SHERMAN SAID, HE HAS THREE
HOME RUNS.
IT IS THE FOURTH INNING.
A TON OF BASEBALL IN THE EARLY
GOING.
THIS ONE HAS A LONG WAY TO GO.
THIS IS WHY I AM A FAN OF THE
SEVEN INNING GAME.
YOU SEE THE WIN PROBABILITY 60%
FOR THE MARINERS.
A SEVEN INNING GAME, THIS GAME
IS ON AND BEING DECIDED RIGHT
NOW.
MARK: STOP TRYING TO CHANGE MY
GAME.
STOP.
YOU LIKELY GUY ON SECOND, TOO.
BRIAN: I DID NOT LIKE THE IDEA.
I ENDED UP LIKING IT LAST YEAR
AND I DISLIKE IT THIS YEAR.
IT IS TOO GIMMICKY.
SEVEN INNING BALL GAMES THEY
PLAY IN TWO AND A HALF HOURS.
MARK: I NEVER ONCE LOOKED AT :00
AT DODGER STADIUM AND SAID, I
HAVE BEEN OUT HERE THREE HOURS.
BRIAN: NO FAN THINKS THAT IN THE
PARK.
HOWEVER, MOST OF THE FANS ARE
WATCHING ON YOUTUBE.
DO I HAVE FOUR AND A HALF HOURS
TO WATCH A BALLGAME?
BASES ARE LOADED.
TOP OF THE ORDER, MARCUS SEMIEN.
NOT JUST FOR YOUNG FANS WITH AN
ATTENTION DEFICIT, BUT OLDER
FANS SAYING, I WANT TO WATCH A
BALLGAME TONIGHT AND I KNOW IT
WILL TAKE TWO HOURS.
I CAN DO THAT.
FOUR AND A HALF?
NO, I WILL GO CLEAN THE GARAGE
BETWEEN THE THIRD AND THE SIXTH
INNING.
GAMES ARE TOO LONG.
SARAH: THERE ARE SO MANY WAYS TO
KEEP TRACK.
YOU GO TO THE GARAGE, YOU TAKE
YOUR PHONE, YOU GET ALERTS.
BRIAN: I AM NOT REALLY CLEANING
THE GARAGE.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH: JUST SAYING.
BRIAN: BASES LOADED FOR MARCUS
SEMIEN.
BIG SPOT.
YOU SEE THE OFFENSIVE NUMBERS
ARE TREMENDOUS FOR SEMIEN THIS
YEAR.
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME YOU
WATCHED A GAME FROM BEGINNING TO
END?
MARK: I WATCH FOUR A NIGHT.
BRIAN: SO YOU'RE NOT WATCHING
BEGINNING TO END.
MARK: I HAVE THE FOUR BOX ON MY
COMPUTER AND YANKEES ARE METS ON
THE BIG SCREEN.
THANK YOU, DODGER FILMS.
BRIAN: YOU ARE NOT WATCHING A
SINGLE GAME BEGINNING TO END,
YOU ARE WATCHING FOUR AT ONE
TIME.
YOU ARE DOING YOUR JOB.
YOU ARE TO BE LAUDED FOR IT, BUT
YOU ARE NOT WATCHING A SINGLE
GAME, BEGINNING TO END.
MARK: THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH
THE YOUTH RIGHT NOW, EVERYTHING
IS IN SHORT BURSTS.
I SEE IT WITH MY OWN CHILDREN.
UNLESS HE GETS TO FIST POUND
FREDDIE FREEMAN AND THE ON-DECK
CIRCLE, HE JUST WANTS "QUICK
PITCH," HIGHLIGHTS.
I SAT DOWN AND WATCHED EVERY
GAME.
BRIAN: 0-2 TO SEMIEN.
CHARGOIS TRYING TO GET OUT OF
THIS SPOT.
WOBA DECK -- BO BICHETTE
ON-DECK.
RYAN: I AM LIKING THAT FASTBALL.
MARCUS SEMIEN, 51 AGAINST
BREAKING BALLS.
BRIAN: GIVE ME THE MINDSET, YOU
ARE FACING ONE OF THE BEST
HITTERS IN THE LEAGUE, 1-2 IN
THIS SPOT.
IS THERE ANY CHANGE OF
ADRENALINE OR APPROACH?
RYAN: ABSOLUTELY, J.T. THROWS
70% BREAKING BALLS.
YOU KNOW IT IS COMING, THERE IS
ANOTHER ONE.
HE DOES NOT HAVE A FEEL FOR THAT
PITCH WHATSOEVER.
IT COULD BE YOUR HEART RATE IS
UP, YOU ARE TRYING TO FIND THE
GRIP ON THE SLIDER, WHATEVER IT
MIGHT BE.
IT IS THAT LONELY FEELING, LONG
-- LOADED BASES.
YOU DON'T WANT TO CREEP BACK
INTO THE COUNT.
BRIAN: 2-2 TO SEMIEN.
THE COUNT IS FULL.
RYAN: THAT SLIDER IS HIS
BREAD-AND-BUTTER.
86% OF THE TIME HE WILL THROW
THAT PITCH.
THAT IS HIS COMFORT ZONE.
HE GOT BELOW THE BASES.
MARK: HE DOES NOT WANT TO THROW
A TWO-SEAMER.
MARCUS SEMIEN HAS SOME OF THE
QUICKEST HANDS.
BRIAN: CHARGOIS 21 INNINGS, ONLY
THREE WALKS.
HE DOES NOT WALK MANY BATTERS.
0-2 ON SEMIEN.
THE COUNT IS FULL WITH THE BASES
LOADED.
BIG PITCH.
SMOKED HIM.
96 UP TOP.
THE MARINERS ESCAPE.
THAT WAS A LITTLE SOMETHING
EXTRA.
WE PLAYED FIVE.
MARINERS UP 6-5.
♪
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
THIS ONE IS OUTTA HERE.
♪
>> 2-1.
SWING AND A DRIVE.
GET ON OUT OF HERE AND GRAND
SLAM FOR VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR.
>> THE 3-2 PITCH.
SWING AND A DRIVE DEEP TO
CENTER.
GET ON OUT OF HERE, GONE.
THE SECOND HOME RUN OF THE NIGHT
TO STRAIGHTAWAY CENTER.
>> THEY ARE SEEING THIS
FIRSTHAND.
>> SWING AND A DRIVE.
GET ON OUT OF HERE.
A THREE HOMER NIGHT FOR VLADDY.
>> THE SOLO HOME RUN WENT TO
CENTER AND THIS HOME RUN WILL GO
TO THE RIGHT.
HE CAN HIT IT OUT AT ANY PART OF
THE BALLPARK.
>> BREAKING BALL HIT HIGH AND
DEEP TO LEFT FIELD.
TIED GAME.
THE BEST HITTER ON THE PLANET
RIGHT NOW HAS DONE IT AGAIN.
IT IS A BRAND-NEW BALLGAME AT
FENWAY.
>> WHAT CAN YOU SAY, OTHER THAN
WOW?
♪
>> WE ARE REALLY GOOD AT PLAYING
LONG GAMES.
WE ARE ANYWHERE BETWEEN THREE
AND FOUR EVERY GAME.
WE HAD A SEVEN INNING GAME GO
THREE.
I WOULD LOVE NOTHING MORE THAN
TO SPEED THAT ONE UP.
BRIAN: MIC'D UP, HILARIOUS WITH
THE FIRST BASE UMPIRE.
RYAN: THEY HAVE HAD SOME
MARATHONS THIS YEAR.
YOU WOULD THINK IT WAS A 15-14
GAME.
BRIAN: I LIKE A CHATTY FIRST
BASEMAN.
DYLAN MOORE LEADS OFF AGAINST
ANTHONY KAY.
IT WILL BE MOORE, TYLER
TRAMMELL, AND TOP OF THE ORDER,
J.P. CRAWFORD.
YOU SEE THE UNIFORM HAS GOTTEN
DIRTY FOR DYLAN MOORE.
2-2.
STOLEN BASE.
AN INFIELD SIGNAL.
HE IS IN THE SCRAPPY GAME.
HE HAS GOOD SPEED.
IS HE IMPRESSIVE SPRINT
SPEED-WISE, OR IS HE EFFICIENT?
HE HAS BEEN VERY GOOD ON THE
BASES.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS RAW SPEED
GETTING HIM THERE.
SARAH: HE IS ABOVE AVERAGE, 79TH
PERCENTILE.
HE WAS MOTORING ON THOSE PLAYS,
CLOSE TO THE 30 FEET PER SECOND
ELITE THRESHOLD.
RYAN: I THINK HE WAS AROUND 27
OR SO.
LAST YEAR WAS A SHORTENED YEAR,
BUT HAD A BREAKOUT AND WAS
HITTING WITH POWER TO RIGHT
FIELD.
BRIAN: 28.2 THIS YEAR, SO HE HAS
PICKED UP SPRINT SPEED.
SARAH: THAT IS ABOVE THE
AVERAGE, THE AVERAGE IS 20
SEVEN.
IT IS BETWEEN 27 AND 30 WE ARE
LOOKING AT.
BRIAN: HIS SPEED IS AT JOSE
ALTUVE LEVEL.
RYAN: THAT IS A PITCH HE
STRUGGLED WITH, 90 FIVE PLUS
VELOCITY UP IN THE STRIKE ZONE.
JUST HAD NO ANSWER FOR IT.
BRIAN: YOU ARE OFTEN SURPRISED,
EXTRA BASES TAKEN, MAYBE IT WAS
BO BICHETTE, I REMEMBER DOING MY
HALL OF FAME RESEARCH -- BOUNCED
TO THIRD, CAVAN BIGGIO.
TRAMMELL'S EXTRA BASES TAKEN WAS
56%, ABOUT WHAT RICKEY
HENDERSON'S WAS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE BLAZING
SPEED.
A LOT OF IT IS YOUR GILE AND HOW
-- GUILE AND HOW QUICK YOUR
BURST IS.
MARK: ONE OF THE BEST BASE
RUNNERS I PLAYED AGAINST WAS
BAGWELL.
BRIAN: THERE WERE YEARS WHERE
TAYLOR TRAMMELL STEPS IN, YOU
REMEMBER THE HEYDAY OF THE
HIGH-SCORING ERA.
HE WOULD SCORE 150 RUNS THE YEAR
WERE EVEN MCGUIRE IS SCORING 100
-- SCORING 100 BECAUSE THE
BASERUNNING IS BETTER.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ABOUT
BAGWELL.
BAGWELL WAS ALSO A SLOT BELOW
THE DON MATTINGLY LEVEL.
I WOULD SAY TEAMS NOT BUNT
BECAUSE HE WAS COVERING THIRD
BASE.
HE WOULD COVER UP THE THIRD-BASE
LINE.
YOU COULD NOT BUNT ON HIM.
RIZZO IS GOOD AT FIRST BASE.
SARAH: IT IS INTERESTING, WE
WERE AT THE DRAFT COMBINE.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
DRILLS THEY ARE HAVING GUYS
DOING, THE RUNNING THEY ARE
MEASURING, IT IS NOT A 40 YARD
DASH, IT IS 60 FOR BASEBALL.
THEY ARE MEASURING THE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THAT.
BRIAN: ANOTHER STRIKEOUT FOR
KAY.
TWO OUTS QUICKLY.
BASEBALL IS FULL OF RITUALS.
TENDING TO THE MOUND.
BAUTISTA, THROW IT.
♪
BRIAN: LOOK AT THIS, TENDING TO
THE MOUND.
THIS WILL MAKE SENSE.
WHAT IS THE VELO ON THAT?
WE ARE ASKING YOU WHICH BASEBALL
RITUAL WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE A
STAT FOR?
THE HEIGHT OF THE BAT FLIP, THE
HEIGHT OF THE DIRT PILED UP ON
THE MOUND, THE ROSIN BAG?
RYAN: UNIFORM ADJUSTMENT.
BRIAN: I THOUGHT IT WAS TIME
BEFORE PITCH.
HARGROVE WOULD FIT RIGHT INTO
TODAY'S GAME.
THE HUMAN RAIN DELAY.
NOW HE IS A NORMAL PLAYER.
MARK: THAT IS A BAD NICKNAME TO
HAVE.
BRIAN: J.P. CRAWFORD STEPS IN.
TWO OUTS, 2-1 TO CRAWFORD.
HE HAD AN EXCITING GAME, A BUNT
SINGLE EARLY IN THE GAME.
HE HAS A BUNT, BUNT BASE HIT,
AND HE SMACKED ONE OPPOSITE
FIELD TO GET ON THE LAST AT-BAT.
CRAWFORD, HIS FIRST SEASON.
NOW HE HAS EMERGED.
HE IS 15TH AND CONTACT RATE, 2-3
WITH A DOUBLE.
LAST YEAR PLUS SIX IN DEFENSIVE
RUNS SAVED.
IT IS CUMULATIVE.
THIS YEAR IT IS PLUS 11.
THAT IS AN EXPONENTIAL EFFECT IN
THIS ERA, CONTACT RATE MAKES A
BIG DIFFERENCE.
THE 2-2.
GOT A PIECE OF THAT AT 97.
SARAH: WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
DRAFT PICKS EARLIER.
HE WAS A FIRST ROUND PICK, THE
FUTURE OF THE PHILLIES AT ONE
POINT.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE HIM COMING
INTO HIS OWN AFTER THE TRADE.
THIS IS THE PLAYER HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE, IT JUST TOOK
LONGER.
THAT HAPPENS.
NOT EVERYONE IS FERNANDO TATIS
JR. AT 22 YEARS OLD.
RYAN: WHEN HE CAME OVER IN THE
TRADE, THEY HAD GIVEN UP ON HIM.
PERRY HILL CAME IN AT THE SAME
TIME.
THEY WENT TO ARIZONA AND SPENT
THREE DAYS TOGETHER AND PERRY'S
CAREER TOOK OFF.
BRIAN: GURRIELR THE BLUE JAYS.
WE WILL GO TO THE BOTTOM HALF OF
THE INNING.
BICHETTE, GUERRERO, HERNANDEZ,
PART OF THE ORDER.
♪
>> IT IS COOL TO SEE THOSE
COMPARISONS.
THOSE THINGS HAPPEN A LOT.
I TAKE THEM IN STRIDE AND KEEP
IT GOING SO I CAN CONTINUE TO
WRITE MY STORY.
EVERYBODY HAS THEIR OWN STORY TO
RIGHT, AND I HAVE MINE.
♪
>> CAN WE GET A SOUND CHECK?
>> TESTING, 1, 2, 3.
ARE WE GOOD?
>> WE HAVE JUST A FEW QUESTIONS.
KYLE, YOU READY?
>> LET'S HIT IT.
♪
BRIAN: THE FINAL WEEK OF THE
2020 GOOGLE ALL-STAR BALLOT IS
HERE.
DETERMINE WHO WILL START IN
COLORADO.
BOAT DAILY AT MLB.COM/VOTE.
SEARCH MLB ALL-STAR BOAT ON
GOOGLE.
THE BLUE JAYS ARE WELL
REPRESENTED GETTING INTO THE
FINALS.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ, VLAD JR.,
MARCUS SEMIEN, GRICHUK, BO
BICHETTE, ALL AMONG THE
FINALISTS.
JON MOROSI HAS MORE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
>> I HAVE A SHIRT, MY FRIEND,
WITH THE NAMES OF THE FIVE
FINALISTS OF THE TORONTO BLUE
JAYS HERE AT THE BALLPARK AND I
HAVE NEWS TONIGHT OF AN ALLIANCE
THAT HAS BEEN FORMED BETWEEN THE
BLUE JAYS AND THE PADRES TRYING
TO POOL THEIR RESOURCES.
IT IS #VOTEPODJAYS, TO UNITE
BOTH TEAMS.
ANNOUNCED FROM FERNANDO TATIS
JR. URGING PADRES FANS TO
SUPPORT VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR.
AND THE JAYS.
UNIQUE UNION DEVELOPING RIGHT
NOW.
BRIAN: IS THAT LEGAL?
SOUNDS LIKE IT IS RIFE WITH
VOTER FRAUD.
THANK YOU, JON.
I AM JUST KIDDING.
BO BICHETTE STEPS UP.
HE HAS HAD AN EXCITING BALLGAME.
2-0.
PAUL SEWALD COMING ON THE PITCH.
RYAN: ANOTHER ONE OF THESE GUYS,
HE STRUGGLED WITH CUPS OF COFFEE
WITH THE NEW YORK METS.
SCORED .186, 19.1.
MARK: LOOK AT THE OPPONENT OPS.
BRIAN: MICROSCOPIC.
38 STRIKEOUTS IN 19 INNINGS GETS
YOUR ATTENTION.
BICHETTE, TWO SINGLES, SCORED A
RUN.
HE HAS BEEN ACTIVE ON THE BASES,
FORCING REVIEWS, GETTING DOUBLED
UP.
SUDDEN DISAPPEARANCE IS OUT ON
THE BASES.
NEVER TO BE SEEN OR HEARD FROM
AGAIN.
HE IS EXCITED.
IT SHOWS YOU THE MERCURIAL
NATURE OF RELIEF PITCHING.
SMACKED HARD, BUT FOUL.
HE HAD AN E.R.A. IN THE 4'S,
6'S, NOW SOMETHING CLICKS.
RYAN: THE SEATTLE MARINERS HAVE
DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
THEY HAVE BEEN IDENTIFYING WHAT
PITCH WORKS FOR CERTAIN GUYS.
ONE STARTED THE YEAR OFF SO
WELL.
YOU WANT TO THROW THIS CHANGE UP
THIS AMOUNT OF TIMES BECAUSE
THIS IS WHAT IT DOES.
PAUL SEWALD TALKED ABOUT IT AS
WELL.
ALL OF A SUDDEN HE IS THROWING
THAT PITCH AROUND 45%,
COMMANDING THAT FASTBALL.
BRIAN: BO BICHETTE HAD NO SHOT.
THAT MOVEMENT IS STRAIGHT OUT OF
THE STICKY STUFF ERA, YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M SAYING?
WHEN EVERYBODY STARTED THROWING
A BALL LIKE COREY KLUBER, THAT
BALL IS REALLY MOVING.
RYAN: YOU TALK ABOUT THE BLUE
JAYS TRYING TO CLIMB UP IN THE
A.L. EAST.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT DEPTH.
YOU COULD HAVE THAT GROUP OF
GUYS, YOUR A-SQUAD.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE DEPTH, GUYS IN
TRIPLE-A WHO CAN HELP YOU OUT.
OR, YOU HAVE TO IDENTIFY SOMEONE
TO FILL THE GAP.
BRIAN: VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR.
STEPS IN.
HE STRUCK OUT TWICE AND ALSO
WALKED.
MARK: HE HAS AN INTERESTING ARM
ANGLE, LOW 3/4, PUSHES THAT 90
MILES PER HOUR TO THE OUTSIDE
BLACK AND TUNNELS THE SLIDER
RIGHT OFF OF IT.
BRIAN: THERE WE GO.
THE RELEASE POINT.
IT IS DIFFERENT, GOOD POINTS.
RYAN: 4-48 AGAINST THE FASTBALL,
SO HE IS DOMINANT WITH THE
PITCH.
REALLY GOOD COMMAND.
HE IS NOT WALKING GUYS A LOT.
MARK: THAT IS WHAT THE RAYS DO
SO WELL.
WHEN THEY GO TO THE PEN, IT IS
LIKE AN OCTOPUS.
BRIAN: DIFFERENT RELEASE POINT,
DIFFERENT REPERTOIRE.
BY THE TIME YOU ARE TRACKING A
PITCH, YOU SEE IT AT A DIFFERENT
ANGLE AND BEFORE YOU KNOW IT, IT
IS DONE.
BEAUTIFUL PITCH.
SWING AND A MISS.
SARAH: HE ONLY HAS 13 STRIKEOUT
GAME ALL YEAR, VLAD JR., ON JUNE
24, PRETTY RECENTLY.
BRIAN: BETWEEN THAT PITCH AND
THE ONE HE STRUCK OUT ON, HE HAS
SEEN REALLY GOOD PITCHES.
RYAN: YOU TALK ABOUT JUSTUS
SHEFFIELD, HE DID STRUGGLE, WAS
DOING SOME HEAVY LIFTING.
UP AGAINST VLAD GUERRERO IN THIS
GAME, A COUPLE GOOD SEQUENCES.
THE REASON THAT SLIDER WORKS IS
THE COMMAND OF THAT FASTBALL.
BRIAN: IF YOU ARE NOT WATCHING
THIS PITCH BY PITCH YOU ARE
SAYING, VLAD STRUCK OUT, HAD A
BAD GAME.
HE HAS SEEN VERY DIFFICULT
PITCHES IN THIS GAME.
RYAN: GOING AGAINST THE SCOUTING
REPORT, PITCHING DOWN IN THE
STRIKE ZONE.
BRIAN: THAT IS THE ONE TIME HE
WILL SEE PAUL SEWALD ALL YEAR.
HE COMES OUT OF THE PEN, I HAVE
NEVER SEEN THIS GUY BEFORE.
WHAT WAS THAT?
HE WILL NEVER SEE HIM AGAIN.
THERE IS TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ.
HE FOULS THAT BACK.
RYAN: YOU CAN SEE THE PRESENCE
FROM PAUL SEWALD.
STICKING THAT CHEST OUT, HAS THE
GOOD TEMPER.
I GUARANTEE YOU DID NOT SEE THAT
WHEN HE WAS IN A METS UNIFORM.
BRIAN: HE IS UP 10 STRAIGHT
INNINGS WITHOUT GIVING UP AN
EARNED RUN.
IS HE A ONE INNING GUY?
RYAN: HE CAN GET MULTIPLE
INNINGS, BUT AS IT GOES, WHEN
YOU HAVE SUCCESS, YOU GET PUT IN
HARDER SITUATIONS.
YOU GO ONE INNING EVERY TIME.
SARAH: IT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
IF YOU LOOK AT HIS EXPECTED
STATS BASED ON QUALITY OF
CONTACT, IN HIS FOUR YEARS IN
THE MAJORS, HIS EXPECTED E.R.A.
WAS LOWER THAN HIS ACTUAL E.R.A.
LAST YEAR WAS AN ABERRATION AND
IT WAS VERY BAD.
EXPECT AN E.R.A. IN THE 3'S,
4'S, 6'S.
THAT TELLS YOU THERE WAS
SOMETHING HERE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY FIGURED OUT
WITH HIM.
PITCHING IN RELIEF, TOO.
THROW THIS PITCH MORE.
BRIAN: SCOTT SERVAIS TOLD US, WE
HAVE ONE OF A YOUNGER TEAMS IN
THE LEAGUE.
WE HAVE THE BULLPEN, NOT BIG
NAMES, BUT THEY ARE GETTING IT
DONE.
SEWALD WAS ONE OF THE GUYS HE
MENTIONED.
GLOVED AT SHORT.
CRAWFORD MADE THAT PLAY.
SERVICE SPECIFICALLY MENTIONED
CHARGOIS AND SEWALD.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM IN.
THEY HAVE THEM I AND
HAVE SEATTLE CLINGING TO A 6-5
LEAD.
>> BLUE GRIT HAS GOTTEN US TO
THIS POINT.
WE ARE GRINDERS, WE LIVE ALL OUR
EXCUSES AT THE DOOR.
GETTING OUT EVERY AT-BAT, NEVER
GIVING IN, KEEPING BATTERS
GUESSING WITH EVERY PITCH.
DETERMINED TO CLOSE IT OUT,
CLUTCH WHEN IT COUNTS.
REFUSING TO QUIT.
BLUE GRIT RUNS DEEP IN THE VEINS
OF THIS FRANCHISE AND IT IS THE
FUEL THAT DRIVES US ON OUR ONE
AND ONLY GOAL.
TOGETHER THROUGH THE UPS AND
DOWNS WE ARE STRONGER, TOUGHER,
AND MORE RESILIENT THAN EVER.
♪
BRIAN: J.P. CRAWFORD, PLUS 11
COMING INTO THIS GAME.
LET'S GET ANOTHER LOOK AT THIS.
LOVE THAT.
YOU SEE THE RANGE.
AND THE REACTION.
MARK: NICE PRE-PITCH, JUST A
LITTLE HOP TO GET HIM GOING.
STEP INTO A DIVE.
BRIAN: YOU PLAYED SHORT?
MARK: ALL I PLAYED UNTIL THE BIG
LEAGUES.
BRIAN: MITCH HANIGER STEPS INTO
LEAD ING'S OFF, HANIGER, FRANCE,
SEEGER.
-- SEAGER.
YOU CAN GO AN HOUR WITHOUT THE
BALL BEING HIT TO YOU.
I AM AMAZED BY THE AMOUNT OF
ENERGY BEING USED BY INFIELDERS.
YOU KNOW AT ANY MOMENT YOU HAVE
TO EXPLODE.
MARK: YOU ARE EXPECTED TO HIT
EVERY PITCH, ESPECIALLY AT
SHORTSTOP.
YOU SEE A LOT OF BALLS GET
RIFLE. YOU.
YOU WANT TO MAKE A BIG PLAY.
YOU JUST PREPARE.
1-2 HOP.
WHATEVER IT IS TO GET YOU GOING.
BRIAN: BICHETTE FIRES HIGH, BUT
GURRIEL STAYS ON THE BAG.
MARK: THERE IS A SITUATION WHERE
BO BICHETTE COULD HAVE COME
AROUND THE BALL.
HE KNOWS HANIGER HAS BIG-TIME
WHEELS GETTING TO FIRST BASE.
SETS HIMSELF A BACKHAND TO GET A
ROCKET THROW ON IT.
BRIAN: LOOK AT THE VELO ON THAT.
HE DID STAY ON THE BAG AND THEN
CAME BACK DOWN.
I THOUGHT HE STAYED ON IT.
I THINK HE GOT THERE.
RYAN: WAITING FOR SOME ACTION.
ESPECIALLY A GAME LIKE THIS.
PLAYING SHORTSTOP ON YOUR HEELS
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME LONG
INNINGS.
I WILL NEVER FORGET A PLAYER
CAME UP TO ME AS A ROOKIE.
HE SAID, THANK YOU.
FOR WHAT?
YOU ARE QUICK, I LOVE IT.
BRIAN: TY FRANCE BOUNCES OUT.
BO BICHETTE, A BUSY MAN TONIGHT.
TY FRANCE MIC'D UP, TALKING
ANALYTICS, HERE.
>> WAY TO PUT IT WHERE THEY ARE
NOT SEEING IT.
GOT TO LOVE ANALYTICS, RIGHT?
>> ANALYTICS, COACH, ANALYTICS.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN: HE IS HILARIOUS.
WANT TO FOLLOW HIM AROUND.
KYLE SEAGER HOMERED EARLIER IN
THE GAME.
THEY HAD HIM MIC'D UP.
HE IS A PIECE OF WORK, AS THEY
SAY.
HE IS SAYING ANALYTICS, THERE IS
SARCASM THERE.
MAYBE HE IS TALKING ABOUT
ADVANCED SCOUTING AND A SPOTS IN
THE FIELD WHEN YOU ARE HITTING
IT AWAY FROM THE SHIFT.
MAYBE THAT IS WHAT HE IS
REFERRING TO.
MARK: BO BICHETTE FOR A KNOCK.
HE IS A GUY WHO IS UBER
AGGRESSIVE.
YOU HAVE TO FIND IT.
BRIAN: 6-5, MARINERS ON TOP IN
THE TOP OF THE SEVENTH.
RYAN: THERE IS ALWAYS THE BATTLE
AND THE BACK-AND-FORTH.
YOU TALK ABOUT ANALYTICS, WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE SHIFT.
YOU HAVE A DEPARTMENT, A MINIMUM
OF 15 GUYS DICTATING THE TERMS
OF THE GAME.
IF YOU ARE A PLAYER, YOU SEE IT
ON SOCIAL MEDIA A TON.
WHEN ANALYTICS HAS A STRONGHOLD
ON A GAME, A GUY LIKE TY FRANCE
WILL MAKE THOSE SARCASTIC
COMMENTS.
BRIAN: YOU ARE SEEING THE
THIRD-BASEMAN IN THE TOP LEFT,
MOVING OVER AS THE COUNT GETS TO
TWO STRIKES.
CAVAN BIGGIO IS THERE IN A
SECOND BASE POSITION, HIS OLD
SPOT.
KAY WITH ANOTHER STRIKEOUT.
MARK: KAY HE HAS HAD FIVE
STRIKEOUTS IN TWO PLUS INNINGS.
MARINERS BY ONE.
♪
>> I AM 13 YEARS OLD.
I AM HAWAIIAN, THE YOUNGEST OF
FOUR.
I PLAY SOFTBALL, I DO RUGBY,
VOLLEYBALL.
I PLAY SHORTSTOP.
IT IS VERY FAST, AND IN AND OUT
KIND OF THING.
MY MOM WORKS AT A HOMELESS
SHELTER.
SHE HELPS OUT PEOPLE THAT CAN'T
DO IT THEMSELVES.
I LOOK UP TO HER A LOT.
>> SHE IS VERY ACTIVE, SHE IS.
SHE IS A MENTOR TO HER PEERS
AROUND HER BECAUSE SHE IS THE GO
TO KIND OF FRIEND ALL HER PEERS
GO TO FOR HELP, FOR ADVICE.
>> MY COUSINS THAT USED TO GO TO
MY SCHOOL USED TO GET BULLIED A
LOT.
I DID NOT LIKE THAT BECAUSE THEY
ARE FAMILY AND STUFF.
WHENEVER I SEE A BULLY, I HAVE
TO TALK TO THEM, BECAUSE IT IS
HARD FOR PEOPLE SOMETIMES.
>> I AM HOPING ONE DAY SHE CAN
BE A MENTOR FOR THE NEW KIDS
COMING IN NEXT YEAR, MAYBE GET
THE JITTERBUGS OUT OF THEIR
SYSTEM.
I HOPE SHE CAN BE THAT PERSON AS
SHE GETS OLDER, INTO THIS
PROGRAM.
>> I AM A MEMBER OF THE HOMETOWN
NINE.
♪
BRIAN: GOOGLE CLOUD HELPING TO
POWER STATCAST WITH MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF DATA POINTS TO POWER
NEW INSIGHTS, TAKING YOU DEEPER
INTO THE GAME THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
WE HAVE THE RESULTS FROM OUR
SILLY POLL, WHICH BASEBALL
RITUAL WOULD YOU MOST LIKE TO
SEE A STAT FOR?
I WAS HOPING THE ROSIN BAG SLAM.
BUT, 10%.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE THE BAT
FLIP.
SARAH: THOSE ARE ACTUAL STAT
REQUESTS WE GET.
TIM ANDERSON TWO YEARS AGO, WE
GOT ASKED.
BRIAN: THAT IS LEGAL, BY THE
WAY.
MARK: I WOULD LIKE TO ASK RYAN.
I NEVER DURING A PITCHING
CONFERENCE AT THE MOUND EVER
THOUGHT TO GRAB THE ROSIN.
IT NEVER FELT STICKY TO ME.
RYAN: I COULD NEVER USE IT.
IF IT TOUCHED ANY PART OF MY
FOOT OR HAND, I STRUGGLED.
I AM NOT JUST SAYING THIS
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENS NOW.
ANYTHING ON MY HANDS, I
STRUGGLED WITH.
BRIAN: ANTHONY MISIEWICZ, OUR
NEW PITCHER FOR THE MARINERS, ON
FOR SEWALD.
MISIEWICZ, AND 18TH ROUND PICK
OUT OF MICHIGAN STATE, 4.08
E.R.A.
RYAN: HE HAD A LITTLE ROUGH
STRETCH.
WAY MORE CUT FASTBALLS.
HE IS NOT YOUR TYPICAL LEFT ON
LEFT GUY.
IT IS PRETTY MUCH A SPLIT
AGAINST RIGHTIES AND LEFTIES.
BRIAN: DOESN'T THAT LOOK LIKE
YOUR TYPICAL GEORGE SPRINGER
LINE?
TWO RUNS SCORED.
WHEN HE IS IN THIS LINEUP ON A
REGULAR BASIS WITH THE REST OF
THESE GUYS, THEY WILL HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
MARK: I AM SO USED TO SEEING HIM
IN THE LEADOFF SPOT.
HE IS JUST COMING BACK OFF THE
IL, HIDING IN THE FIVE HOLE.
BRIAN: WE ASKED THAT OF CHARLIE
MONTOYO, GIVE ME YOUR
PHILOSOPHY.
I DON'T WANT TO BE CRITIQUING
HIS LINEUP.
SPRINGER WAS AN UNCONVENTIONAL
LEADOFF HITTER.
GRICHUK STEPS IN.
SPRINGER WAS AN UNCONVENTIONAL
LEADOFF CHOICE FOR THE ASTROS,
BUT WAS UNATTRACTIVE LEADOFF,
UNLESS YOU HAVE AN ABSURD ON
BASE GUY.
MONTOYO SAID, HOPEFULLY HE WILL
CAUSE A PROBLEM.
HOPEFULLY SPRINGER WILL BE SO
HOT, WE HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION.
SEMIEN IS NOT A PERFECT LEADOFF
MAN.
MARK: THEY ARE BOTH CRAFTY
VETERANS.
THEY WILL DO WHAT IS BEST FOR
THE TEAM.
THEY TALK ABOUT SEMIEN BEING THE
FIRST GUY OUT FOR EARLY WORK.
BRIAN: SMOOTH OUT IN RIGHT
FIELD.
NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK,
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
FANS WATCHING ON MOBILE DEVICES
AND COMPUTERS CAN VOTE WHICH
PLAYER WILL RECEIVE THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME TROPHY DURING
THE POSTGAME SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME POLLING OPTIONS LATER.
YOU KNOW WHO MY VOTE IS FOR,
CAVAN BIGGIO.
MARK: ONE PITCH.
BRIAN: A TREMENDOUS TAKE.
I THINK JON MOROSI WILL BACK ME
UP.
JON: I ALWAYS BACK YOU UP.
I WANT TO BACK UP SARAH LANGS.
SHE MADE A GREAT POINT TODAY
ABOUT FATHERS AND SONS AND A
SECOND GENERATION MAJOR LEAGUE
PLAYERS.
LOURDES GURRIEL SENIOR BEING A
STAR IN CUBA.
LOURDES GURRIEL SENIOR WON ONE
OLYMPIC GOLD MEDAL 1992.
DID YOU KNOW YOU ARE WORKING
WITH AN OLYMPIC MEDALIST
TONIGHT?
RYAN ROWLAND-SMITH, SILVER METAL
WITH TEAM AUSTRALIA 2004.
RYAN ONE OF THE GREAT
AUSTRALIANS.
THAT IS THE THIRD AUSTRALIAN TO
JOIN THE MAJOR-LEAGUE RANKS THIS
YEAR.
ALEXANDER WELLS WITH THE
BALTIMORE ORIOLES.
RYAN:, THE GREEN AND GOLD 2004.
BEAT JAPAN, 1-0.
I THINK HE PUNCHED OUT 12.
THEN WE WENT ON.
I APPRECIATE THE SHOUT OUT, J.P.
WE GOT BEAT BY CUBA IN THE
GOLD-MEDAL GAME.
BRIAN: THAT BRINGS UP LOURDES
GURRIEL SENIOR.
I SAW YULI GURRIEL PLAYING IN
THE FIRST WBC WHEN HE WAS
SKINNY.
2-2 TO CAVAN BIGGIO.
AT THE TIME I THINK HE WAS 21
YEARS OLD PLAYING SHORTSTOP AND
THERE IS A-ROD, THE NEXT A-ROD.
SKINNY SHORTSTOP, GREAT RANGE,
TOTAL PACKAGE.
RYAN:MARK: MISIEWICZ SAID, NOT A
QUALITY TAKE.
>> IT IS AMAZING.
OBVIOUSLY, THE TEAM HAS
CONFIDENCE IN YOU.
I AM READY TO GO.
WE HAVE A SHOT.
>> THE REGULAR SEASON, HIS
MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT.
>>'S MOM IS HERE, SUSANNA.
EVERYONE IS LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS FIRST PITCH IN THE CAREER
OF ALEX MANOA.
--MANAOH.
>> 0-2.
NASTY STUFF AS HE STRIKES OUT
ODOR.
MANOAH STRIKES THEM OUT.
>> FIVE STRIKEOUTS FOR ALEK
MANOAH.
>> I WANT TO TAKE IT ALL IN.
IT IS A PRETTY AMAZING MOMENT.
>> I THINK EVERYONE WAS HEARING
THE MANOAHS TONIGHT.
BRIAN: YOU CAN GO BEHIND THE
SCENES WITH THEIR FAVORITE
ALL-STARS AND GET EXCLUSIVE
CONTENT ON THE BLUE JAYS YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
SUBSCRIBE TODAY AT
YOUTUBE.COM/BLUEJAYS.
IF WE WERE PLAYING MY BELOVED
SEVEN INNING MAJOR LEAGUE GAME,
WE WOULD BE DONE.
SO I AM GLAD WE ARE CONTINUING.
IT HAS BEEN A LOT OF FUN CALLING
THE GAME WITH YOU GUYS.
I HAVE REALLY ENJOYED IT.
THIS HAS BEEN A GOOD BALLGAME.
6-5 NOW GOING TO THE TOP OF THE
EIGHTH.
I AM JUST SAYING ONE LAST THING
BECAUSE I AM NEVER QUITE DONE.
JAKE BAUERS, LUIS TORRENS, TOM
MURPHY UP FOR SEATTLE.
THIS IS VERY DIGESTIBLE CONTENT.
BICHETTE, 91 MILES PER HOUR HE
THREW.
SARAH: THE FASTEST THROW OF HIS
CAREER.
FOR CONTEXT, WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
IN FIELD THROWS.
BRIAN: NOT LONG AGO, 90 MILES
PER HOUR WAS A GOOD FASTBALL.
IF YOU HAVE HIGH SCHOOL KID
THROWING 90, THAT IS A REAL ARM.
RYAN: IT IS AMAZING HOW FAST IT
IS.
LEFTIES, TOO.
I WAS A LEFT-HANDED PITCHER.
I WOULD HAVE NO SHOT IN 2021.
MARK: BO IS SHOWING YOU
EVERYTHING, THE ABILITY TO
BACKHAND, LIGHT UP THE RADAR
GUN, HIT A BULLET FIRST AT BAT.
I HAVE HIM MAKING SEVEN PLAYS.
BRIAN: MAYBE THERE IS ANOTHER
ONE I MISSED.
MY SCOREKEEPING, SPECIOUS AT
BEST.
I HAVE BEEN MAKING SIX DIFFERENT
PLAYS.
HE HAS BEEN BUSY.
JAKE BAUERS STEPS IN, 1-3.
THE OTHER THING I WILL SAY ABOUT
BO BICHETTE, THERE WAS AN ISSUE
WHEN HE SWUNG VERY HARD AND I
THINK GREG AMSINGER WAS HOSTING
MLB TONIGHT AND HE ASKED, HAROLD
AND DAN PLESAC, YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT?
THEY SAID IN THE 1990'S, 1980'S,
A GUY SWINGS LIKE THAT -- IT WAS
PEDRO MARTINEZ AT THE DESK.
THEY SAID, HE IS DUCKING NEXT
TIME.
HOW IS HE NOT ALLOWED TO SWING
HARD?
BECAUSE HE IS NOT.
HE SWUNG OUT OF HIS SHOES.
MARK: WHY CAN'T YOU HAVE IT BOTH
WAYS?
WHY IS WHAT PEDRO SAID NO, NO,
NO?
WE HAVE TO SAY YES, YES, YES TO
EVERYTHING.
BRIAN: WATCH THIS, JUNE 17, BO
BICHETTE.
MARK: GET LOOSE.
BRIAN: HE STRUCK OUT.
RYAN: THE SITUATION PEDRO WAS
TRYING TO TALK ABOUT, HE IS TOO
COMFORTABLE.
I WILL SHIFT HIS FEET A BIT AS
OPPOSED TO THE DISRESPECT
FACTOR.
BRIAN: ANTHONY KAY IS STILL OUT
THERE.
HE HAS GONE THREE INNINGS, HAD
FIVE STRIKEOUTS.
KAY IS REALLY DOING OUTSTANDING
WORK OUT OF THE BULLPEN.
RYAN: MADE FIVE STARTS THIS
YEAR.
BRIAN: HE HAS EIGHT CONSECUTIVE
SCORELESS INNINGS.
6-5 BALLGAME IN THE EIGHTH.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT CAME DOWN TO
WHEN I WAS WATCHING THAT?
MAD DOG.
"MLB NOW" AND "HIGH HEAT" RIGHT
BY EACH OTHER.
KAY GOING THREE PLUS.
BO BICHETTE, I WOULD PAY TO
WATCH HIM PLAY.
ISN'T THAT THE POINT?
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO PAY TO WATCH
THIS.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE EMPLOYED.
BO BICHETTE IS A GUY, YES,
EXCITING.
MARK: I DO NOT THINK THERE IS A
RIGHT OR WRONG ANSWER TO IT.
WE WERE RAISED A DIFFERENT WAY
WHEN I CAME INTO THE BIG
LEAGUES.
I TOOK A SWING OFF ROGER CLEMENS
AND KISSIMMEE IN SPRING
TRAINING.
BRIAN: LOOK, NEW JERSEY, YOU ARE
GOING TO EAT IT.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE WAS NO REASON.
MARK: I WAS SWUNG FROM MY HEELS.
RYAN: EVEN IN THE LOCKER ROOM,
YOU WALK IN THE CLUBHOUSE.
WHEN I WAS A ROOKIE, 24 YEARS
OLD, I WOULD NOT EVEN COME CLOSE
TO THE COUCH TO CHANGE THE TV.
GUYS NOW HAVE THEIR FEET UP ON
THE COUCH IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
IT IS DIFFERENT.
NOTHING AGAINST IT WHATSOEVER.
BRIAN: THE LINE IS FROM AND
JUBILATION TO TAUNTING.
YOU KNOW WHERE THE LINE IS.
BO BICHETTE TAKING A BIG SWING.
CELEBRATE WITH YOUR TEAMMATES,
DON'T TAUNT.
MARK: PEDRO MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO THAT.
BO BICHETTE CAN GET AWAY WITH
SOME THINGS THAT MAY BE SOME
OTHER GUYS CAN'T IN THAT
SITUATION.
IF HE IS FALLING DOWN, SOMEONE
MIGHT TAKE EXCEPTION TO IT.
SARAH: THAT IS BECAUSE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
RYAN: HE TRIED TO BE BY THE
BOOK.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENS.
BRIAN: AN EVEN BETTER
EXPLANATION.
UNWRITTEN RULES.
DOUBLE PLAY BALL.
IN MY WORLD TOM MURPHY GETS A
SINGLE.
IT IS A LAME SINGLE.
YOU KNOW HOW OFTEN THAT HAPPENS?
ONCE A NIGHT, AT BEST.
MARK: HIS NUMBERS ARE SKEWED,
HIS O.P.S.+ IS SKEWED.
BRIAN: TWO OUTS.
HERE IS ANOTHER PART.
EACH YEAR CERTAIN GUYS REACH ON
MORE ERRORS THAN OTHERS.
DEREK JETER, CAL RIPKEN, GUYS
WHO SMOKED THE BALL TO THE LEFT
SIDE OF THE INFIELD WILL REACH
ON ERROR MORE OFTEN THAN THEIR
COLLEAGUES.
YOU SHOULD GET CREDIT FOR THAT.
JETER WOULD REACH ON BASE FOR AN
ERROR 12 TIMES A YEAR.
TYLER TRAMMELL STEPS UP, TWO ON
TWO OUTS.
MARK: SHOULD NOT GET CREDIT FOR
THE BEST PLAYER IN THE WORLD
MAKING A MISTAKE ON A ROUTINE
PLAY.
BRIAN: IT IS NOT ROUTINE IF YOU
HIT IT HARD TO THE LEFT SIDE OF
THE INFIELD, THAT IS WHERE YOU
MAKE THE LONG THROW.
IT IS ALSO MOSTLY ATHLETIC GUYS
WHO CAN RUN.
YOU ARE FORCING ERRORS.
I AM SEEING IT IS A BYPRODUCT OF
YOUR SKILL.
SARAH: THAT IS THE ARGUMENT FOR
OTHER STATS.
YOU ARE TALKING BASE RUNS.
THAT IS THE ARGUMENT FOR OTHER
STATS AND METRICS THAT CAN
MEASURE THOSE THINGS.
MAYBE IN A SEPARATE BUCKET.
BRIAN: TRAMMELL IN THE AIR,
FRUSTRATED.
GOING TO LEAVE SOME MEN ON BASE
AND THE ERROR DOES NOT FACTOR IN
THE SCORING.
A5 GAME.
WE GO TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
EIGHTH INNING.
BOTTOM OF THE ORDER FOR THE BLUE
JAYS.
STILL DANGER THERE.
♪
>> I WOULD PROBABLY BE IN PARIS
-- I WOULD PROBABLY BE
EMBARRASSED IF I KNEW HOW MUCH I
SPEND ON CHIPOTLE IN A MONTH.
I WILL CALL A FRIEND.
>> I WILL GO ON A LIMB AND SAY,
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD.
I THINK HE WOULD BE A
RESPONSIBLE WITH CHIPOTLE MONEY.
WHO THINKS CHIPOTLE NEEDS A
BURRITO WRAPPING SEMINAR FOR
THOSE WORKERS WHO HAVE NO CLUE
HOW TO WRAP ONE?
>> THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO NEVER
WORK TODAY IN THEIR LIFE,
PROBABLY.
>> SOMEONE SASSY.
>> IS HE GOING ON H A POLI RUN?
-- IS HE GOING ON A CHIPOTLE
RUN?
>> HE WOULD BE SASSY ABOUT
PEOPLE BEING TERRIBLE BURRITO
RAPPERS.
IS IT?
>> IS THIS FROM 2013?
>> THAT IS SO MEAN.
WHY WOULD YOU SAY THAT?
HAVE A LITTLE COMPASSION.
BRIAN: WELCOME BACK TO THIS MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK.
THIS STATCAST BROADCAST BROUGHT
TO YOU BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
BRIAN KENNY WITH RYAN
ROWLAND-SMITH.
AND MARK DEROSA, SARAH LANGS.
JON MOROSI IS REPORTING IN
BUFFALO.
BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH RIGHT NOW.
TWO BIGGEST EVENTS OF THE SUMMER
ARE ON THEIR WAY.
THE HOME RUN DERBY JULY 12, 8:00
P.M. EASTERN.
THE 91ST ALL-STAR GAME JULY 13
ON FOX, COVERAGE BEGINS AT 7:30
P.M. EASTERN.
LOURDES GURRIEL, RILEY ADAMS,
MARCUS SEMIEN.
THAT BALL IS LAUNCHED.
WOW.
TIED BALLGAME DEEP INTO THE
BUFFALO NIGHT.
SARAH: 419 FEET, SAME DISTANCE
AS THE HANIGER HOMER.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH: SHOUT OUT TO STATCAST.
ALL I DID WAS LOOK AT A PAGE.
BRIAN: THAT IS SOMETHING.
LAST TWO YEARS HE SWUNG .530.
TIED BALLGAME 6-6 IN THE EIGHTH.
MARK: HE WENT THROUGH THE BOTTOM
OF THE SEVENTH LIKE THEY WERE
NOT EVEN IN THE BOX.
RYAN: IT IS A TOUGH BREAK.
MISIEWICZ WENT THROUGH A TOUGH
STRETCH.
FIGURED IT OUT, CHANGED HIS
PITCHING A LITTLE BIT.
BRIAN: WOW, LOOK AT THAT
TOMAHAWK UP TOP.
MISIEWICZ, TO UNDERLINE THAT
POINT, WE WONDERED, DOES HE COME
OUT ANOTHER INNING?
HE THREW NINE PITCHES, HAD EASY
WORK, DOMINATED.
IN THIS DAY AND AGE WITH GAME
PLANNING, YOU LEARN.
YOU HAVE TO BE READY.
RYAN: KENDALL IS WARMING UP IN
THE BULLPEN.
HE WILL GET THE TOP OF THE BLUE
JAYS LINEUP.
NOW 6-6 BALLGAME, EVERYTHING
CHANGES.
BRIAN: THAT WAS HIT HARD BY
ADAMS.
GOOD GLOVE BY BAUERS.
ADAMS IS FEELING THE SOMEWHAT --
THE SAME WAY.
TOP OF THE ORDER.
MARCUS SEMIEN STEPS UP.
STRUCK OUT HIS LAST TIME UP TO
READ HE HAS BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN
THIS GAME.
THIS IS A FUN TEAM TO WATCH.
SEMIEN GETS AFTER YOU.
SPRINGER IS DYNAMIC, BO BICHETTE
IS THE MOST EXCITING PLAYER ON
THE FIELD.
VLADIMIR GUERRERO IS THE NUMBER
ONE HITTER IN THE LEAGUE.
THIS IS THE TEAM TO WATCH.
A GOOD, YOUNG, GETTING BETTER BY
THE MONTH TEAM.
RYAN: TIED BALLGAME, 6-6.
LOOKS LIKE HE IS PROBABLY USE --
LOOSE.
MARK: IT IS ALL RIGHTIES.
BRIAN: DOES HE HAVE REVERSE
SPLITS?
RYAN: HE DOES A LITTLE BETTER
AGAINST RIGHTIES, .260 AGAINST
RIGHTIES.
BRIAN: PREVIOUS TWO YEARS HE WAS
BETTER AGAINST RIGHTIES, BUT HE
IS NOT VICTIMIZED.
RYAN: HE HAS HAD TO COVER SOME
INNINGS, FACE RIGHTIES AS WELL.
THIS GAME WAS 6-5.
BRIAN: SWING AND A MISS.
2-1.
MARINERS WITH FOUR PITCHERS
USED.
THE WIN PROBABILITY, 60%, A BIG
SWING TO THE BLUE JAYS HOME
TEAM.
THAT IS ON THE BY AND LARGE, NOT
FACTORING WHO IS IN THE ROSTER.
I DID NOT KNOW LORD US -- I DID
NOT KNOW LOURDES HAD YULI'S
HAIR.
THEY ARE BROTHERS, BUT YOU HAVE
TO TRY TO GET THAT HAIR.
IT DOES NOT JUST HAPPEN.
HE LOST HIM.
ON THIS SET, I THINK RYAN WINS
BEST HAIR.
RYAN: I WORKED ALL AFTERNOON ON
IT.
THANKS.
BRIAN: TAKE A LOOK ON CAMERA.
WHEN RYAN COMES ON THE SHOW ON
"MLB NOW" I ALWAYS THINK, I
SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN A HAIRCUT.
YOU GET IT CUT WHEN YOU GET OUT
OF THE AIRPORT.
RYAN: PRETTY MUCH EVERY MORNING
I AM HITTING THE BARBERSHOP.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN: I HAVE TO LOOK GOOD.
BRIAN: LOOKS TIGHT.
WE HAVE A 6-6 BALLGAME WITH A
MAN ON.
♪
>> WELCOME TO OUR PARTY.
>> SEEING HIM OUT THERE, GOING
THROUGH THE PHOTO SHOOTS, NOT
NECESSARILY MY FAVORITE THING TO
DO, BUT WITH HIM OUT THERE, IT
WAS INCREDIBLE.
HE WAS EXCITED WHEN WE DID THE
GROUNDBALL STUFF THAT I MISSED
ONE AND HE DIDN'T AND HE WAS
THROWING IT BACK FASTER THAN ME.
HE LOVED THE CAMERA, HE ATE IT
UP.
HOW MUCH HE OWNED IT WAS AN
INSPIRATION TO ME.
THEN YOU REALIZE HE IS A LITTLE
BOY, TOO.
HE IS DOING CRAZY STUFF, HAS
CAMERAS ALL OVER, 50 PEOPLE
TAPING HIM.
ALL HE WANTS TO DO IS SHOOT
BASKETS.
YOU GET A SENSE THAT HE IS A
LITTLE BOY.
THAT WAS REALLY SPECIAL.
♪
BRIAN: THE BLUE JAYS, GREAT
HAIR, GREAT SWING.
THAT IS HALL OF FAME HAIR.
MAJORLY CARE?
-- MAJOR LEAGUE HAIR?
NO, HALL OF FAME HAIR.
MISIEWICZ, FIRST PITCH, 419
FEET.
THAT CHANGED THIS WHOLE GAME.
LOURDES GURRIEL JR. WITH THE
HOME RUN.
NOW YOU HAVE A MAN ON.
SCOTT SERVAIS WILL GO TO A GUY
-- KENDALL GRAVEMAN HAS EMERGED
AS THE ACE.
RYAN: BIG-TIME PROSPECT,
STARTING PITCHER, STRUGGLED WITH
INJURIES.
THE MARINERS GOT HIM IN 2020 TO
BE A PART OF THE ROTATION.
IT -- THEY SAID, WE COULD
IDENTIFY YOU AS A BULLPEN GUY.
HE TOOK IT HEAD ON.
NOW HE IS 95, 97.
THE ONLY DAMAGE IS IN JUNE.
THREE RUNS.
BEFORE THAT, ZERO.
BRIAN:  BO BICHETTE2-4, HE HAS
BEEN ACTIVE ON THE BASIS.
1.19 E.R.A., THAT WILL GIVE YOU
THE RELIEF ACE CATEGORY.
THERE IS ONE.
J.P. CRAWFORD GOT THE OUT ON THE
TRANSFER.
GOT THE LEAD RUNNER.
THAT IS INTERESTING.
I GUESS THE BALL IS NOT AS
STICKY FURTHER SHORTSTOPS.
RYAN: KENDALL GRAVEMAN, ONE
THING, HE HAS NOT BEEN PITCHING
BACK TO BACK, BUT HE CAN TURN
MULTIPLE INNINGS.
THE PITCH COUNT WILL GO UP.
HE COULD COME BACK TO THE NINTH.
BRIAN: THAT WAS A SUBTLE MOVE,
SEMIEN GOING TO SECOND BASE.
HE GOT IN CRAWFORD'S WAY A
LITTLE BIT.
YOU CAN'T TAKE HIM OUT ON A
SLIDE, BUT YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
MAKE IT A LITTLE DIFFICULT.
HERE IS BICHETTE.
HE THOUGHT IT WAS A DOUBLE PLAY
AND KICKED IT INTO GEAR.
SEMIEN WENT INTO SECOND BASE
JUST AGGRESSIVE ENOUGH.
YOU WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH MY
BODY, MY PRESENCE.
THAT DID NOT HELP CRAWFORD MAKE
THE TRANSITION.
HE WANTED TO GET THE BALL OUT OF
HIS GLOVE.
SIMEON WAS SLIDING INTO HIM --
SEMIEN WAS SLIDING INTO HIM.
A SMALL, SUBTLE THING THAT
HELPED CAUSE THE DROP.
GUERRERO STRUCK OUT THREE TIMES,
WALKED ONCE.
LOST THAT BALL AND BICHETTE GETS
TO SECOND BASE IN SCORING
POSITION IN THE TIED GAME.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
THROUGH THE NIGHT.
VLAD JUNIOR HAS STRUCK OUT THREE
TIMES AND WE HAVE SEEN
BEAUTIFULLY EXECUTED PITCHES
AGAINST THEM TONIGHT.
RYAN: SOME OF THOSE PITCHES
COULD HAVE BEEN BORDERLINE.
THE OTHER PART OF THIS, JUSTUS
SHEFFIELD, WHO REALLY STRUGGLED
TONIGHT AGAINST VLADIMIR
GUERRERO, AGAINST PITCHES AND
AGAINST THE SCOUTING REPORT.
YOU SAW THE FASTBALL ELEVATED.
BRIAN: SAW JORDAN ROMANO WARMING
UP.
CRAWFORD THIS TIME ENDS THE
INNING.
LOURDES GURRIEL, FIRST PITCH OF
THE INNING, TIES THE BALLGAME
UP.
WE GO TO THE TOP OF THE NINTH,
MARINERS AND JAYS.
BACK IN A MINUTE.
♪
>> THEY JUST GOT I THINK THE
MOST FAMOUS ONE IN THE CLUBHOUSE
TO PRETEND.
>> VERY RECOGNIZABLE STANCE.
THE PANTS ARE EXTREMELY TIGHT.
>> AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, IT
IS LIKE THAT.
>> HE IS ABOUT TO GET THE
HELICOPTER GOING.
>> LITTLE DANCE, HE DOES A
LITTLE DANCE.
>> I DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT.
>> USED TO BE A LOT WORSE.
>> RIGHT HERE.
>> I'M GOING TO GO BO BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK MANY PEOPLE CAN MOVE
LIKE HE CAN.
>> HE WILL GET IN THERE.
PLATE, FOOT.
>> VERY DISTINCT SWING.
>> HEEL UP.
>> THE WAY HIS BODY MOVES, NOT
MANY PEOPLE MOVE LIKE THAT.
>> TURN HIS BACKSIDE LIKE THIS.
>> AND THEN HE DOES THE BIG LEG
KICK AND SOMETIMES, HE HITS IT,
AND SOMETIMES, HE DOESN'T.
>> GET OUT OF HERE.
GO ON.
A WALKOFF HOME RUN FOR BO
BICHETTE.
♪
>> 6-6 BALLGAME.
WE ARE BACK.
HERE IS MARCUS SEMIEN.
THIS IS WHY HE IS SUCH A
VALUABLE PLAYER IN A LOT OF
WAYS.
HE BRINGS HIS BODY OUT TO THE
RIGHT SIDE OF THE BASE.
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
MARK: AS LONG AS YOU'RE WITHIN
AN ARMS LENGTH.
HE CREATED A LITTLE DIVERSION.
BRIAN: WE ARE GOING TO GET
JORDAN ROMANO IN.
HE EMERGED AS THE RELIEF ACE FOR
THE BLUE JAYS.
HE HAS NOT ALLOWED AN EARNED RUN
IN HIS LAST 16 INNINGS.
JUST WANT TO FINISH THAT POINT.
THERE'S A LOT OF SMALL WAYS TO
WIN THE BALLGAME ON THE BASIS.
VERY UNDERRATED.
A LOT OF GUYS, SINCE THE NO
COLLISION -- A LOT OF GUYS GIVE
THEMSELVES UP.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GIVE YOURSELF
UP.
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR THE TEAM
TO MAKE A PLAY.
IT'S NOT DIRTY.
I AM THROWING MY BODY OUT THERE.
YOU CAN DANCE AROUND ME.
MARK: PLAYING MIDDLE INFIELD
PRETTY MUCH MY ENTIRE CAREER,
YOU ARE WELL AWARE OF THE GUYS
THAT ARE GOING TO GET ON TOP OF
YOU IN A HURRY.
BRIAN: YOU KNOW WHO THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE DIET HAS BEEN DOING
THAT HERE -- GUY I HAVE SEEN
DOING THAT HERE?
MAX MUNCY MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
MIDDLE INFIELDERS HIT HE IS NOT
DIRTY.
HE GOES INTO SECOND BASE
EXTREMELY HARD.
IF YOU DON'T DO A LITTLE DANCE
MOVE, HE WILL BREAK YOUR LEG.
YOU HAVE TO GET OVER HIM.
BUT HE IS NOT DOING IT DIRTY.
6-6 BALLGAME NOW IN THE NINTH.
J.P. CRAWFORD, THE LEADOFF
HITTER.
2-4.
HE HAS HAD A BIG GAME.
ROMANO, BY THE WAY, A CANADIAN.
CANADA DAY.
1.5 HOURS, EASTERN TIME.
RYAN: UPPER 90'S.
55% OF THE TIME.
BRIAN: LAST YEAR, LIMITED DUTY.
HE ALSO HAD AN E.R.A. IN THE
ONES.
2-1 NOW.
SO LONG ALLOWED ON FOUR SEAMERS.
MICROSCOPIC.
THAT IS NOT THE BATTING AVERAGE.
ROMANO IS SECOND IN ALL OF
BASEBALL.
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
2-1 SMACKED THE OTHER WAY SOUTH.
THAT IS OPPONENTS SLUGGING 98.
RYAN: HE FIGURED SOMETHING OUT.
SLUGGING .722, SO HE FIGURED
SOMETHING OUT.
BRIAN: BLUE JAYS GO TO JORDAN
ROMANO.
ADAM CIMBER JUST ACQUIRED FROM
THE MARLINS, IS ALSO ON THE
ROSTER NOW AND HE IS AVAILABLE.
SMACKED UP THE MIDDLE, BASE HIT.
CRAWFORD WITH THREE SINGLES.
BRINGING SINGLES BACK.
BRINGS UP MITCH HANIGER, WHO HAS
HOMERED IN THIS GAME.
HE LAUNCHED ONE BACK IN THE
FIFTH INNING.
MARK: I JUST LIKE THE CALM IN
THE BOX, TIMING WITH HIS FRONT
LEGS, STAYS ON TOP.
HE IS NOT TRYING TO DO ANYTHING
BUT PLAY PEPPER WITH THE BASE.
BRIAN: I'M SORRY.
HE HAS A DOUBLE AND THERE, TOO.
DOUBLE IS BETTER THAN A SINGLE.
RYAN: GETS BEHIND THE COUNT WAS
TWO STRIKES.
REALLY SIMPLE.
BRIAN: SEE WHAT MITCH HANIGER
DOES, IF HE POUNCES.
AND TO GET BACK TO SOMETHING WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT WHERE I SAID
I LIKE SEVEN INNING GAMES, YOU
PROBABLY LIKE THAT EXTRA RUNNER
ON IN THE NINTH.
IT DOES FEEL GIMMICKY, LITTLE
ARTIFICIAL, AND EVEN AS I'M
CALLING THIS GAME NOW, DO I WANT
TO SEE A MAN ON SECOND?
NO, I DON'T.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT PLAYED
OUT HONESTLY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS THE
RIGHT WORD BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT PLAYED OUT MORE TRUE.
RYAN: I KIND OF LIKE IT.
I LIKE THE RUNNER ON.
MAYBE ONE EXTRA INNING AND THEN
THE 11TH.
MARK: YOU HAVE BEEN IN MULTIPLE
GAMES LIKE THAT.
IT GETS PAST THE 12, GUYS START
LOOKING AT EACH OTHER LIKE -- IT
BECOMES A HOME RUN DERBY, WHO IS
GOING TO RUN INTO WHAT.
THAT 10TH AND 11TH INNING, WE
ARE TRYING TO EXECUTE BASEBALL.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I DON'T MIND IT A LITTLE BIT
LATER BUT TO JUST ENACT IT IN
THE 10TH FEELS A LITTLE --
BRIAN: THAT'S A STRIKE.
THAT WAS THE 12, RIGHT?
I THINK IT WAS THE 12.
IT WENT FOR A WHILE BEFORE THEY
DID THAT.
SEEMS WEIRD.
I BELIEVE IT WAS THE 12 INNING
AND NOW, IT IS THE 10TH INNING.
RYAN: ONE EXTRA INNING OF
REGULAR BASEBALL, NO RUNNERS ON.
SARAH: IT WAS THE 10TH.
BRIAN: MY MISTAKE.
10TH INNING.
I HAVE BEEN WRONG BEFORE.
I CAN'T RECALL WIN, BUT THAT WAS
ONE.
MARINERS ARE 8-1 IN EXTRA
INNINGS.
THE MIGHTY DODGERS ARE 1-7.
IT HAS THAT FLUKE-ISH QUALITY.
SARAH: BOTH TEAMS SCORE IN EACH
INNING FOR A COUPLE INNINGS.
THE GIANTS PLAYED A GAME LIKE
THAT A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF THEM
WHERE TOP OF THE 10TH, BOTTOM OF
THE 10TH, IT'S A DIFFERENT
CADENCE THAN WE ARE USED TO.
BRIAN: COUNT GOES FULL ON
HANIGER.
MARK: J.P. STEALING BAGS.
RYAN: BRIAN: -- RYAN: 3-2 COUNT.
6-6.
SARAH: 3-6 THIS YEAR.
MARK: IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE HE IS
GOING.
READ THE BODY LANGUAGE.
BRIAN: TWO ON IN THE TOP OF THE
NINTH.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK RETURNS
JULY 9 AS THE REDS TRAVEL TO
MILWAUKEE TO TAKE ON THE BREWERS
, WHO HAD TAKEN OVER FIRST PLACE
IN THE CENTRAL.
TY FRANCE, WHO WE HAVE HAD MIKE
TAP THROUGHOUT THE DAY, WILL
STEP IN.
NOW, HIS BIG CHANCE.
TWO ON, NOBODY OUT.
RYAN: A BUNCH OF TIMES LATE IN
GAMES, THAT LITTLE INSIDE-OUT
SWING TO RIGHT FIELD.
BRIAN: HE HAD THE SINGLE IN THE
FIFTH.
1-4.
A 34TH ROUND PICK BUT THIS YEAR
NOT ONLY HITTING FOR SOME POWER,
HE IS 30TH IN CONTACT.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT SUPER ELITE,
NOT LIKE YOU ARE DAVID FLETCHER,
BUT 30TH MEANS YOU ARE NOT A BIG
SWING AND MISS GUY.
YOU ARE PUTTING THE BAT ON THE
BALL.
HE IS ALSO A PLUS DEFENDER AT
FIRST AND THE GUY WHO SUCCEEDED
AT MOST EVERY LEVEL IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES.
I MENTIONED HE TOURED UP FOR EL
PASO IN THE PADRES SYSTEM.
I DON'T KNOW HOW OFFENSIVE THAT
PLAYS.
PROBABLY EXTREMELY, BUT STILL,
YOU DID THAT HERE -- LITTLE
LEAGUE FIELD IN SECAUCUS.
THAT'S GOOD.
THE 1-0.
SKIED TO RIGHT.
RECHECK -- GRICHUK -- HMM.
WOULD YOU HAVE SENT HIM?
MARK: I LIKE THAT READ RIGHT
THERE.
YOU COULD HEAR THE CENTER AND
THE SECOND BASEMAN KIND OF
ALERTING RANDAL GRICHUK RIGHT
THERE.
TAG, TAG.
BRIAN: I THINK IT WAS A LITTLE
CLOSE.
AND YOU ARE STILL WITHIN A
SINGLE.
WITH KYLE SEAGER, YOU CANNOT.
SO STILL JUST ONE OUT.
FLIES OUT TO RIGHT FIELD.
RUN EXPECTANCY HERE.
THAT IS WHEN THERE'S NO OUTS.
1.54, DROPS DOWN A 0.98 AND
THAT'S WHY BUNTING IS BIG IN
THAT SITUATION, FIRST AND
SECOND, NOBODY OUT.
I DON'T THINK YOU WOULD HAVE TY
FRANCE BUNTING.
>> THE SOUND.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN: IMAGINE HIM GOING,
REALLY?
WHY DID HE SAY THAT,?
-- WHY DID HE SAY THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
SEAGER WITH A HOME RUN BACK IN
THE THIRD AND ALSO STRUCK OUT
TWICE AND SINGLED, SO HAVING A
BIG DAY, 2-4.
>> STRIKE!
BRIAN: ONE OF THE ALL-TIME
MARINERS.
TIE BALLGAME HERE IN THE NINTH,
INSIDE PART OF THE PLATE.
>> BIG KNOCK RIGHT HERE.
GET THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME TROPHY.
>> KNOCKING OFF CAVAN BIGGIO.
>> THINK HE IS THINKING THAT
RIGHT NOW?
BRIAN: THINKING THE WAY THE WIND
IS BLOWING.
ANY TIME THE BALL HAS BEEN HIT
TO LEFT FIELD, IT TAKES EXTRA
FLIGHT.
YOU DON'T SEE AS MANY BEARDS
THESE DAYS.
THAT WAS A THING TO HER THREE
YEARS AGO.
RYAN: 2013 RED SOX.
BRIAN: FEWER OF THEM NOW.
THAT'S A BIG BEARD BY ROMANO,
TOO.
IT'S 79% HUMIDITY.
THAT CANNOT FEEL GOOD.
RIGHT?
YOU KNOW WHO LOOKS GOOD AND
APPEARED, DERO -- A BEARD, DER
O?
MARK: EVERY TIME I SEE A
BEARD, I THINK BRIAN WILSON.
BRIAN: THAT IS TO INSPIRE FEAR.
THAT DOES FIGHT YOU.
ROMANO STRIKES HIM OUT, GETS IT
OUT.
THAT IS HUGE.
RYAN: BIG OUT FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
RUNS IN SCORING POSITION.
SWING AND A MISS AND A WHOLE LOT
MORE IN THE MONTH OF JUNE FROM
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN USED TO
SEEING.
BRIAN: I WAS WATCHING CENTRAL
ONE TIME.
YOU HAVE THE BUREAU DON AND I
SAW YOU CLEAN-SHAVEN.
YES, YOU DO LOOK BETTER WITH A
BEARD.
MARK: NOT ACCORDING TO MY WIFE.
BRIAN: MINUTES OVER.
BUT ALSO, LIKE, YOU KNOW.
TRY AND SELL IT.
BIG SPOT FOR TORRANCE.
TWO ON, TWO OUTS IN THE NINTH.
HE IS 0-4.
AND JORDAN ROMANO COMING ON,
TRYING TO CLOSE THE DOOR, GIVE
TORONTO A BIG SHOT IN THE BOTTOM
OF THE NINTH.
98 UP AND IN.
WHAT DO YOU THROW NEXT TIME?
GIVE ME YOUR SCOUTING ON THAT.
YOU SET THAT UP AND WHAT DO YOU
DO?
RYAN: ELEVATE IT, SAME THING UP
IN THE STRIKE ZONE.
ESPECIALLY AGAINST THAT KIND OF
REACTION AS WELL.
HE IS CRUSHING FASTBALLS, AWARE
OF THAT SINCE HE HAS COME BACK
FROM THE IL.
BRIAN: THE SHORT BENCH HERE.
BIGGIO UP AND THROWING AND GETS
THE OUT.
EARLY TROUBLE.
ROMANO GETS OUT OF IT.
WE HAVE A THE NINTH.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ, GEORGE
SPRINGER, RANDAL GRICHUK, FOOD
THE BLUE JAYS -- FOR THE BLUE
JAYS, BOTTOM OF THE NIGHT,
TRYING TO WIN IT.
♪
>> SUP?
>> OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD.
>> I GOT TO GET SOME LINES GOING
OUT HERE.
>> I AM DOMENICO AND.
>> DO NOT RECORD THAT.
DO NOT RECORD THAT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
NO, NO.
>> DEFINITELY DO NOT SAY THAT TO
MY MOM.
>> I'M GOING TO LOSE IT.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
>> I HAVE TO GO BACK TO THIS.
I LIKE THAT.
HOW WAS IT?
>> IT WAS REALLY NICE.
FIRST EPISODE.
♪
>> TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ, GEORGE
SPRINGER, AND RANDAL GRICHUK FOR
THE BLUE JAYS IN THE BOTTOM OF
THE NINTH.
6-6 BALLGAME.
THESE TWO CLUBS REALLY GETTING
AFTER IT.
THEY RUN HARD, THEY CHALLENGE
GUYS LIKE BO BICHETTE TAGGING
UP, GOING TO THIRD.
MITCH HANIGER THROWING A BULLET
TO THIRD BASE.
EXCITING PLAY.
HE COMES ON FOR A SECOND INNING
OF WORK.
>> GOING HOME TO FIRST.
FIRST AND HOME.
BRIAN: HARD PLAY THROUGHOUT.
HERNANDEZ IS 0-4 BUT HE HAS THAT
LINE OUT DOUBLE PLAY IN HIS
FIRST AT-BAT WHERE HE SMOKED A
BALL, FOUND A GLOVE AND SOME
HARDLUCK.
LEADING OFF THIS POTENT CLUB, A
6-6 GAME.
WE BARELY GOT TO THIS BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE TOM MURPHY, YOUR
CATCHER D.H.'ING, IT DID LEAVE
SCOTT SERVAIS A LITTLE SHORT ON
THE BENCH.
MARK: I DID NOT UNDERSTAND IT.
I DID NOT WANT TO DIVE TO DEEP
INTO IT EARLIER BECAUSE YOU
DON'T KNOW THE INS AND OUTS.
BRIAN: WHEN I SAW MURPHY --
USUALLY, YOU DON'T DO THAT.
YOU HAVE A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
IT TOOK A LITTLE BIT AWAY FROM
HIM THERE.
IF YOU WANTED TO PINCH HIT
TORRANCE IN THAT SITUATION.
0-2 VERY QUICKLY.
SMACKED.
NICE PLAY.
TY FRANCE, WELL DONE AT FIRST
BASE.
I WONDER WHAT HE SAID THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
ANALYTICS.
YES.
NICELY GLOVED.
GLOVED LOW.
HE PLAYS THIRD BASE.
YOU CAN SEE THERE IS A LITTLE
THIRD BASEMAN IN THAT PLAY AT
FIRST.
HE IS NOT A PLUS THIRD BASEMAN
DEFENSIVELY.
HE IS A PLUS FIRST BASEMAN
DEFENSIVELY BUT YOU CAN SEE WHY
AS HE CAN PLAY A LITTLE THIRD.
SPRINGER COMES IN.
HE PLAYS A LITTLE SECOND BASE AS
WELL.
THAT IS HELPFUL.
WHEN YOU SEE A GUY LIKE JAKE
CRONENWORTH, THAT GUY CAN FIELD.
IT IS DIFFERENT.
RYAN: THE MARINERS LAST YEAR HAD
THESE UTILITY GUYS.
TY FRANCE CAME INTO THE MIX.
SAME THING.
THE UTILITY SPOT AND NOW, THEY
ARE FIGURING OUT WHAT POSITIONS
HE'S RUNNING.
BRIAN: THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
HUMANS GET TIRED.
ELECTRONICS DO NOT GET TIRED.
ROBO ARMS, NEVER TIRED.
MARK: BAD PRESENTATION.
BRIAN: BAD PRESENTATION!
MARK: GEORGE SPRINGER, KING OF
THE BIG MOMENT.
BRIAN: THERE IS A PHILOSOPHY
THAT IT IS EITHER IN THE STRIKE
ZONE OR IT IS NOT.
I'M JUST SAYING, IN THE FUTURE.
MARK: CHALLENGE HIM WITH A 2-0
HEATER.
RYAN: THAT HAS BEEN HIS BIGGEST
WEAPON.
BRIAN: MISSED SORT OF UP TOP.
I AM NOT BEEFING ABOUT THAT.
THE OTHER ONE WAS A STRIKE IN
THE SECOND.
MARK: WE WILL SEE HOW GEORGE
FEELS RIGHT HERE, 3-0.
JUST BACK FROM THE IL.
BRIAN: DO YOU WANT HIM SWINGING?
MARK: ABSOLUTELY.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
BRIAN: NO.
NO.
MARK: 150 MILLION.
BRIAN: IT IS 6-6 IN THE BOTTOM
OF THE NINTH.
MARK: I'M GETTING A MAN ON
SECOND STANDING ANYWAY.
-- NEXT INNING ANYWAY.
HE IS SWINGING.
SARAH: HE HAD ENOUGH ON SECOND
BASE AND A DOUBLE.
WALK-OFF HOME RUN.
MARK: THE WHOLE BENCH IS YELLING
"WHAT?"
BRIAN: MAKE THEM THROW.
RYAN: HE IS GOING TO MISS
THE SLAUGHTER BY THREE FEET.
BRIAN: 3-1 TO SPRINGER.
MARK: YOU DON'T LIKE IT.
RYAN: SECOND-GUESSING.
THAT IS ONE PITCH THAT GOT HIM
IN TROUBLE.
MORE CHANGEUPS AS WELL.
FASTBALL IN.
HE WANTS TO GET BACK, FASTBALL
IN.
BRIAN: HE MISSED BY A BUNCH SO
YOU ARE RIGHT.
HERE IS TY FRANCE MAKING THAT
PLAY AT FIRST.
>> YOU ARE GOOD.
BRIAN: NOW, HE HAS NOTHING TO
SAY.
HE HAS BEEN TALKING NONSTOP
BALLGAME.
I GOT IT.
I GOT IT, I GOT IT, I GOT IT.
MARK: ME, ME, ME.
BRIAN: TAKE CHARGE OUT THERE.
SPRINGER DRAWS THE WALK SO YOU
HAVE THE POTENTIAL GAME-WINNING
RUN OVER AT FIRST BASE AND HERE
IS RANDAL GRICHUK.
>> SERIOUS ON THAT SINKER.
RYAN: CAMERA ANGLE IS NOT DOING
ANY JUSTICE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT.
BRIAN: GRICHUK, GOOD DAY RIGHT
THERE.
2-4.
A DOUBLE, A SINGLE, AND IT'S
FLOWN OUT TWICE.
MARK: I'M PUTTING GEORGE IN
MOTION AT SOME POINT.
BRIAN: YOU ARE RUNNING HIM?
MARK: THIS SETS UP FOR A DOUBLE
PLAY FOR ME.
POWER SINKER TO RANDAL GRICHUK.
BRIAN: NOT A LOT THE OTHER WAY
FOR GRICHUK.
HEAVY POLE.
SPRINGER ONLY HAS ONE STOLEN
BASE THIS YEAR.
MARK: I DON'T KNOW HOW HE FEELS.
IS HE 100%?
70%?
WHERE IS HE?
BRIAN: SPRINGER HAS GOOD SPEED
BUT HE HAS NEVER REALLY BEEN A
STOLEN BASE GUY.
HE HAS HAD ONE YEAR WHERE HE HAS
HAD MORE THAN 10 AND THAT WAS IN
2015.
BIG SWING THERE.
SO EVEN THOUGH HE IS DYNAMIC ON
THE BASE PATHS, HE IS NOT A
STOLEN BASE THREAT ORDINARILY.
BOTH MANAGERS HAVE WORKED HARD
IN THIS ONE.
FOUR PITCHES FOR THE BLUE JAYS
AND FIVE FOR THE MARINERS.
HE MISSED INSIDE.
2-1.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT IS GOOD, TOO?
THEY HAVE BEEN GOING TO THEIR
A-SQUAD.
BOTH -- IT HAS GONE BACK AND
FORTH, THIS GAME.
EVEN SCOTT SERVAIS HAS GOT --
FOUR INNINGS OUT OF JUSTUS
SHEFFIELD.
AND THEN GRAVEMAN IS ON FOR A
SECOND INNING OF WORK.
FOULED BACK 2-2.
RYAN: A COUPLE OF OPTIONS.
BACK FROM TRIPLE-A.
HE WAS HAVING A GOOD YEAR WITH A
TWO.
IT'S INTERESTING.
RAFAEL MONTERO CAME OUT FROM THE
RANGERS, A CLOSER FOR THE
RANGERS LAST YEAR, STARTED THE
YEAR OFF WITH THAT CLOSER SPOT,
STRUGGLED, GAVE IT UP LAST
MONTH.
THREE-MONTH HOME RUN, SIX LAST
BRIAN: CAVAN BIGGIO IS ON DECK.
ONE OUT.
MARK: HE HAS QUICK FEET.
BRIAN: IS SPRINGER'S LEAD THAT
GOOD?
HE IS ATTRACTING A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
MARK: I'M GOING TO POUND THAT
SINKER IN, TRYING GET A GROUNDER
TO THIRD.
BRIAN: THAT IS NOT A BIG
LEAD, IS IT?
GRICHUK IS SAFE.
MARK: I HAVE BEEN RANDAL GRICHUK
MULTIPLE TIMES.
BRIAN: YOU ARE SAYING SEND HIM,
BUT YOU KNOW, HE CAN GET THROWN
OUT, TOO.
I MEAN, GRICHUK IS SLUGGING
.470.
MARK: I GOT IT.
THAT IS A TOUGH MATCHUP FOR HIM.
I AM MANAGING NEXT YEAR.
BRIAN: YOU GOING TO LET HIM HIT
3-0?
MARK: ABSOLUTELY.
BRIAN: HE IS 10 YEARS OLD.
RYAN: -- LINEUP EVERY DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN: HERE IS CAVAN BIGGIO.
STILL A MAN ON FIRST.
TWO OUTS.
CHARLIE MONTOYO THERE.
A WALK EARLIER IN THE GAME.
SINGLED AS WELL.
1-3.
MARK: YOU MIGHT GET YOUR WISH.
BRIAN: BIGGIO IS IN THE SPOT,
SANDY?
--ISN'T HE?
HIS NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
OUTSTANDING SINCE HE CAME OFF
THE D.L..
OVER .400 WITH HIS ON-BASE
SLUGGING FOR SOME PRETTY GOOD
POWER.
THAT'S NOT NORMALLY HIS GAME.
SARAH: SLUGGING .538 ENTERING
TONIGHT.
BRIAN: POWER ON THE INSIDE
CORNER FOR A STRIKE.
BIGGIO THOUGHT IT WAS A BALL.
THERE WE GO.
IT'S A SMALL SAMPLE BUT --
SINCE COMING OFF THE INJURED
LIST.
BIGGIO HAS SEEN THE BALL WELL.
THERE HE GOES.
GRICHUK IS IN.
GRICHUK STEALING THE BASE.
THAT IS HIS FIRST OF THE YEAR.
HE WAS 0-2.
LAST YEAR, HE WAS 1-2.
THE YEAR BEFORE, 2-3.
HE IS NOT A BIG THREAT
ORDINARILY.
THERE HE GOES.
I ADMIRE THE CHUTZPAH.
MARK: HE WAS -- RYAN: HE WAS
QUICK TO THE PLATE.
BIG LEG KICK.
BRIAN: RYAN THE HEAD.
THE THROW TO SCOTT RIGHT IN
THERE.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO LOOK
-- OH!
MARK: HE IS OUT.
BRIAN: HE IS KIND OF WHAT WE
CALL OUT.
MARK: THAT WAS THE FIRST STOLEN
BASE ATTEMPT.
BRIAN: HE IS OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
IF HE REALLY HAD IT, HE WOULD
START TAKING A SHOWER.
THEY ARE GOING TO TURN THIS
OVER.
HIT THE BUFFET, START EATING,
TAKE A SHOWER, GET THE ROBE ON
AND SAY YOU HAVE TO GET THAT.
NO, I DON'T.
I GOT THAT.
REPLAY REVIEW.
IT LOOKED LIKE THE THROW WAS IN
THE PERFECT SPOT.
QUICK CALL.
IT PROVES HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
MAKE THESE CALLS IN REAL TIME.
THEY ARE FAST AND YOU ARE
LOOKING AT MULTIPLE THINGS.
THE FOOT ON THE BAG, THE GLOVE,
THE BALL COMES INTO WHACK ON THE
HEAD.
DECENT JUMP, BUT THAT THROW IS
JUST BEAUTIFUL FROM TORRANCE.
HE IS OUT.
THEY GOT THE CALL RIGHT.
GOOD JOB IN NEW YORK.
TAKING THE BAT OUT OF CAVAN
BIGGIO'S HANDS.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
START TRAVELING THE GLOBE WITH
YOUR SON'S TEAM.
6-6 GOING TO EXTRA INNINGS.
WE WILL GET A GUY ON SECOND BASE
REAL SOON.
>> IT IS RARE THAT BASEBALL FANS
ARE GLUED TO A PLAYERS MINOR
LEAGUE AT BATS BUT THAT WAS THE
CASE IN THE WEEKS BEFORE VLAD
GUERRERO JR. MADE IT TO THE BIG
SHOW.
>> SIGNED BY THE BLUE JAYS WHEN
HE WAS 16 YEARS OLD AND HE TORE
HIS WAY THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
>> HIS DEBUT IN TORONTO CAPTURED
THAT SAME EXCITEMENT FROM THE
HOME FANS.
THEY HAD BEEN WAITING FOR HIM
SINCE THE JAYS SIGNED HIM AS A
16-YEAR-OLD IN 2015.
>> A MOONSHOT FOR VLADIMIR
GUERRERO JR..
>> HIS POWER WAS ON FULL DISPLAY
AT THE MID-SUMMER CLASSIC.
HE BROKE THE ALL-TIME HOME RUN
DERBY RECORD WITH 29 HOMERS IN
THE FIRST ROUND.
>> HE HAS PUT ON THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE POWER SHOW TONIGHT.
>> JUST FOR GOOD MEASURE, HE
ADDED 62 MORE FOR A GRAND TOTAL
OF 91 DINGERS.
30 MORE THAN THE PREVIOUS SINGLE
DERBY RECORD.
>> WHAT A SHOW.
>> HIS PERFORMANCE GAVE FANS A
TASTE OF WHAT IS TO COME.
HE IS THE FACE OF THE JAYS YOUNG
CORE AND ALONG WITH TWO OTHER
LEGACY STUDS AND CAVAN BIGGIO,
HE COULD ANCHOR ONE OF THE BEST
LINEUPS IN BASEBALL FOR YEARS TO
COME.
♪
BRIAN: WE GO TO EXTRA INNINGS,
TOP OF THE 10TH, 6-6 BALLGAME
BETWEEN THE MARINERS AND THE
BLUE JAYS.
NEW PITCHER FOR TORONTO.
IT IS PATRICK MURPHY.
11 MAJOR LEAGUE INNINGS.
FIVE OF THEM THIS YEAR.
HE HAS GIVEN UP THREE RUNS,
THREE STRIKEOUTS, TWO WALKS,
FORMER THIRD ROUND PICK, WAY
BACK IN 2013.
RYAN: COMING INTO A TOUGH SPOT
RIGHT HERE.
BRIAN: YOU ARE SAYING YOU LIKE
THIS?
THERE IS A GUY ON SECOND BASE
NOW.
COME ON, LIKE THIS?
MARK: I DON'T LIKE THIS.
RYAN: I DO.
I ACTUALLY DO.
FOR WHATEVER REASON -- THINK OF
IT LIKE -- DON'T SHAKE YOUR HEAD
AT THIS.
BUT HOCKEY GOES OVER TIME.
YOU START, YOU KNOW, DROPPING A
PLAYER, AND THEN YOU GET THE
PENALTY SHOOTOUT.
I DO LIKE KIND OF THE URGENCY OF
IT.
BRIAN: CHANGE, BEAUTIFUL.
BRIAN: WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
MARK: LEAVE IT ALONE.
BRIAN: JAKE BAUERS LEADS OFF.
MURPHY, DYLAN MOORE -- I DO WANT
TO LEAVE IT ALONE.
GET THE GUY OFF SECOND BASE.
THIS WAS THE CHANGE THAT WAS
MADE.
THIS WAS THE CHANGE, WHICH MADE
SENSE IN THE YEAR OF COVID.
LET'S JUST GET THIS GAME IN AND
GET OUT OF HERE, BUT NOW, IT
JUST FEELS ARTIFICIAL.
IT DOES SPEEDED UP BY THIS GAME
WILL CHANGE.
BOWERS STAYS UP.
THE RUNNER STAYS AT SECOND.
I HAVE SEEN A LOT OF TIMES, YOU
KNOW, AND THE NUMBERS DON'T
SUPPORT THIS TO PLAY SMALL BALL,
BUT I HAVE SEEN IT.
IT FEELS ARTIFICIAL.
GROUND BALL TO THE RIGHT SIDE,
AND THEN YOU GET A FLY BALL TO
THE OUTFIELD.
FEELS LIKE, ALL RIGHT, THAT
RELIEF PITCHER JUST FAILED.
HE DID NOT FAIL.
IT FEELS WEIRD.
THAT'S WHY.
SHED LONG COMES OFF THE BENCH.
PINCH-HIT FOR MURPHY IN THE D.H.
SPOT.
NOW, AGAIN, BIGGER PICTURE, IT
GETS YOU OUT OF HERE.
THEY HAVE ALREADY GOT TO THE
BULLPEN THE WHOLE NIGHT.
15 INNINGS, YOU REALLY DEPLETE
YOUR RESOURCES SO I GET IT.
MAN ON SECOND.
GHOST RUNNER.
IS THAT WHAT WE ARE GOING WITH?
GHOST RUNNER?
>> I THINK SO.
I THINK SO.
BRIAN: THIRD BASEMEN IN THE
THIRD-BASE POSITION.
JAYSON STARK IS A'S ON BE
RUNNER.
CATERING TO THAT AUDIENCE.
IN OUR STUDIO, GUYS ARE CRACKING
UP.
I AM NOT INTO ZOMBIES.
PEOPLE LOVE ZOMBIES YOU INTO
ZOMBIES?
-- ZOMBIES.
YOU INTO ZOMBIES?
IT GOT THROUGH.
THAT IS THE CATCHER.
HE STAYS AT THIRD ON THE BASE
HIT.
FIRST AND THIRD, ONE OUT.
SO SHED LONG OFF THE BENCH.
THAT IS NOT EASY.
HE TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THE
ALIGNMENT.
BICHETTE IS IN SHORTSTOP
POSITION.
NOT THAT FAR OFF.
A LITTLE BIT OF A HOLE.
AND IT BRINGS UP DYLAN MOORE.
2-4.
HE HAS BEEN ACTIVE ON THE BASES
AS WELL.
I THOUGHT WE RAN THE NUMBERS ON
THIS.
HE PLAYED FOR ONE, YOU GET ONE,
AND YOU ARE IN GOOD SHAPE.
ACTUALLY, IT DOES NOT WORK THAT
WAY.
YOU HAVE TO PLAY FOR MORE THAN
ONE.
THAT IS WHAT THE NUMBERS HAVE
REVEALED, WHICH SURPRISES ME.
GET THAT FIRST RUN,
PSYCHOLOGICALLY, YOU HAVE AN
ADVANTAGE.
IT DOES NOT WORK THAT WAY.
SARAH: THESE ARE MAJOR LEAGUE
PLAYERS.
THAT ONE RUN SCORES PRETTY
FREQUENTLY SO THERE IS A HUGE
INCENTIVE TO GETTING MORE RUNS,
ESPECIALLY AS THAT ROAD TEAM AND
NOT BEING IN THAT SITUATION.
BRIAN: THAT MISSED DOWN LOW.
I HAVE TO SAY, RYAN -- HE COVERS
THE MARINERS GAMES.
I AM MUCH MORE OF A DYLAN MOORE
FAN NOW THAN I WAS AT THE START
OF THE NIGHT.
I LIKE THE GUYS GAME.
HAS TO HIT A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT
THE WAY HE RUNS AND GETS AFTER
IT --
RYAN: HE GOT OFF TO A REALLY BAD
START.
IN APRIL, NONEXISTENT FOR DYLAN
MOORE.
2020, HE HAD A CHANCE TO PLAY A
LOT MORE FREQUENTLY, PUTTING UP
GOOD NUMBERS, SHOWING LOTS OF
POWER, SLOWLY BUT SURELY
STARTING TO SEE THAT.
HE STARTS HITTING TO RIGHT FIELD
AND GOOD THINGS HAPPEN.
BRIAN: BOTH MANAGERS, I AM A FAN
OF THE WAY HE MANAGES THIS.
USE YOUR BEST GUYS.
SEWALD WAS USED FOR THE BLUE
JAYS.
GORDON ROMANO WAS USED.
TYLER CHATWOOD.
DO NOT BE WAITING FOR THIS AND
IF YOU LOSE IN EXTRA INNINGS, WE
HAD TO BRING IN PATRICK MURPHY.
HE IS NOT OUR A LIST GUY.
YOU GOT THIS FAR.
RYAN: BOTH MANAGERS CAME INTO
THIS, TOO.
MASSIVE RESTRICTION.
ON THE FLIPSIDE, SCOTT SERVAIS
KNOWS THAT JUSTUS SHEFFIELD HAS
BEEN STRUGGLING SO THEY KNOW
THEY HAVE TO PRECONCEIVE THE
FACT THAT THE BULLPEN WILL HAVE
HEAVY LIFTING.
BRIAN: THAT BALL IS HIT HARD.
THAT BALL IS GONE.
A BOMB FROM DYLAN MOORE AND A
THREE RUN BLAST FOR SEATTLE.
THESE GUYS ARE 8-1 IN EXTRA
INNINGS AND LOOKING GOOD FOR
9-1.
RYAN: IT IS AMAZING LATE IN
GAMES.
GOOD TO SEE.
HE HAS GOT SOME POWER, TOO.
LIKE I SAID AND KEEP SAYING --
YOU ARE SLOWLY BUT SURELY
STARTING TO SEE IT.
SARAH: 405 FEET.
RYAN: 96 UP IN THE STRIKE ZONE.
THAT WAS JUST A WIPEOUT FOR
DYLAN MOORE EARLY IN THE SEASON.
STARTING TO GET TO IT.
MARK: THAT IS A GOOD PIECE OF
HITTING RIGHT THERE.
TWO SEAM FASTBALL.
GOT HIMSELF IN A GOOD HITTER'S
COUNT.
BRIAN: WE ARE GOING TO SEE A
PITCHING CHANGE NOW.
MOORE PUTS THAT OUT,
SEVENTH HOME R13
STOLEN BASE.
THAT WILL DO IT FOR MURPHY.
WE STEP AWAY.
9-6, MARINERS TAKE CHARGE IN THE
TOP OF THE 10TH.
♪
>> TO PREP FOR THE DRAFT, OUR
SCOUTING GROUP IS A YEAR-ROUND
DRAW.
THEY BEGAN ROUGHLY THE DAY AFTER
THE PREVIOUS YEAR'S DRAFT ENDS.
>> WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA OF
10 NAMES THAT WE WERE REALLY
FOCUSED IN ON SO WE STARTED THE
WORK THIS PAST WINTER ON THOSE
10 NAMES.
>> THIS YEAR, THERE WAS A
DRAMATIC CHANGE IN OUR WORLD
ABOUT THE MIDDLE OF MARCH SO
STARTING AT THAT POINT,
BASICALLY ALL OF OUR SCOUTING
EFFORTS MOVED TO VIDEO.
WE ALREADY PLANNED TO MOVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF OUR
SCOUTING OPERATIONS TO VIDEO
THIS YEAR.
WE FELT LIKE WE COULD INCREASE
OUR COVERAGE AND SEE MORE
PLAYERS BY IMPLEMENT TEAM A
LARGE AMOUNT OF VIDEO.
THAT BECAME OUR ONLY OPTION.
>> WE DO OUR CONFERENCE CALL
EVERY DAY.
WE HAVE ABOUT 17 SCOUTS,
SUPERVISORS, AND ANALYSTS TODAY.
THE FIRST THREE PICKS, YOU GO
FOR THE HIGHEST PLAYER YOU THINK
SO WE REALLY GO INTO THIS, WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE THE BEST
PLAYER AVAILABLE THAT WE THINK
WE HAS THE UTMOST FOR THE
SEATTLE MARINERS.
BRIAN: HERE IS SOMETHING WE DO
ON "MLB NOW.
MANAGERIAL CHECK.
JORDAN ROMANO FOR THE BLUE JAYS
ONLY 19 PITCHES IN THAT ONE
INNING OF WORK.
OBVIOUSLY A STEP DOWN GOING TO
MURPHY ON THE HILL.
WOULD YOU HAVE LIKED TO HAVE
SEEN A SECOND INNING OUT OF
ROMANO OR IS THAT ALL YOU GET
FROM HIM?
RYAN: YOU HAVE TO KNOW YOUR
PERSONNEL AS WELL.
CAN YOU GO MULTIPLE INNINGS?
MAYBE THAT IS A CONVERSATION --
HOW ARE YOU FEELING? THE OTHER
PART OF THIS IS YOU STILL GOT
PLENTY OF SEASON LEFT AND THAT
ONE EXTRA INNING -- WHEN YOU SIT
DOWN, THE HEART RATE DROPS AND
GET BACK UP AGAIN, THE RECOVERY
TIME TRIPLES, SO I THINK IT'S --
YOU LOOK AT THAT AND SAY --
STICK AROUND FOR THAT EXTRA
INNING.
LOOK, WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIS GAME
LOG RIGHT NOW, REALLY, I MEAN HE
HAS NOT DONE IT ALL YEAR LONG.
YOU KIND OF HAVE TO MAKE THAT
CALL.
BRIAN: WE SAW ANTHONY, SAVE IT
EARLIER.
HE SMOKED -- WE SAW ANTHONY
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU WILL HAVE THAT
SUCCESS THE NEXT INNING EITHER.
0-2 QUICKLY TO TRAMMELL.
TAYLOR COMES IN AND GETS A
STRIKEOUT.
THE LEFT-HANDER.
HE GETS IT DONE.
BY THE WAY, HIS THAT HE ONLY
PITCHED THREE POSTS INNINGS.
YOU KNOW WHERE HE PITCHED BEFORE
THIS?
BUFFALO.
HE DID NOT HAVE TO GO ANYWHERE.
WE ARE BRINGING YOU UP.
MARK: SITTING IN HIS APARTMENT
IN BUFFALO.
BRIAN: WHEN DO YOU GUYS PLAY?
MARK: HE PROBABLY HAS GUYS
STAYING WITH HIM.
RIGHT NOW, THAT SECOND BEDROOM.
BRIAN: I HAD TO LOOK AT HIS
MINOR LEAGUE STATS UP.
THEY ARE PLAYING IN BUFFALO.
THEY WILL NOT BE THERE FOREVER.
THEY WILL GO TO TORONTO
EVENTUALLY, BUT INTERESTING.
>> A COUPLE AIR MATTRESSES ON
THE LIVING ROOM FLOOR.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN: SO J.P. CRAWFORD NOW AT
THE TOP OF THE ORDER.
I AM TOLD THAT BUFFALO, OF
COURSE, PLAYS ITS GAMES IN
TRENTON.
SARAH: SEE, I WAS NOT GOING TO
CORRECT YOU.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
BRIAN: SARAH IS THE ONLY PERSON
I WORK WITH WHO DOES NOT WANT TO
CORRECT ME.
THAT IS KEN ROSENTHAL.
BICHETTE GETS THE OUT.
OF COURSE BUFFALO IS NOT PLAYING
IN BUFFALO, WHERE BUFFALO PLAYS.
THEY HAD TO MAKE ROOM FOR THE
BLUE JAYS.
9-6.
DYLAN MOORE WITH A BIG THREE-RUN
SHOT UP.
HERE WE GO.
INSPECTION TIME.
TAKE A LOOK.
JUST GOT IN.
HE DID NOT DO ANYTHING.
HERE WE GO.
9-6.
WE GO TO THE BOTTOM 10TH.
♪
>> [SINGING IN A NON-ENGLISH
LANGUAGE]
>> ON INDIGENOUS PEOPLE DAY, I
WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT CULTURE
IS IMPORTANT.
>> WHAT THE COMMUNITY MEANS TO
ME IS THAT IT HELPED ME AND
OTHER YOUTHS COME TOGETHER AS
ONE BIG TEAM.
IT HELPED US IN A PRETTY UNIQUE
WAY.
>> IT HELPED US ENCOURAGE EACH
OTHER TO KEEP PLAYING, TO FINISH
STRONG WHEN WE WERE WINNING,
WHEN WE WERE LOSING.
>> MY INDIGENOUS STRENGTH TO ME
MEANS MY RESILIENCE.
>> TAKING PRIDE IN HOW WE LIVE.
>> TAKING PRIDE IN MY HERITAGE.
>> WE ARE PROUD.
>> WE ARE STRONG.
>> WE ARE RESILIENT.
>> AND WE ARE INDIGENOUS.
>> THAT PAID OFF.
>> THANKS FOR MAKING ME THE
HITTER THAT I AM TODAY.
BRIAN: DYLAN MOORE WITH THE BIG
HOME RUN.
HE HAS DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB.
HE IS A LITTLE TIRED NOW.
YOU CAN TELL.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE IS DYLAN MOORE AGAIN.
HE HAS HAD A BIG GAME AND THEN
THE THREE-RUN SHOT.
HE COMES INTO TRYING TO NAIL
THIS DOWN FOR SEATTLE.
30 STRIKEOUTS, 11 WALKS, 2.22.
GOOD WORK.
RYAN: THIS IS ANOTHER GUY YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT, PAUL
SEWALD.
HE HAD A COUPLE INJURY ISSUES
AND HERE HE IS, GETTING SOME
GOOD REPS.
BRIAN: RANDAL GRICHUK HAS TO GO
TO SECOND BASE.
NOW TAKE SECOND.
YOU ARE THE ZOMBIE.
CAVAN BIGGIO GETS ANOTHER SHOT
WITH A CLEAN COUNT.
I THINK HE HAD TO STRIKES WHEN
HE WAS OUT THERE, DIDN'T HE?
RESET THAT FOR ME, PLEASE.
HE HAS THROWN NINE CONSECUTIVE
SCORELESS INNINGS AND NORMALLY
PITCHES EARLIER IN THE GAME,
WORKING THE SIXTH, BUT AGAIN, IF
YOU HAVE THESE TYPE OF RESULTS,
YOU KNOW THE DRILL.
IF YOU HAVE AN E.R.A. IN THE LOW
TO USE, MORE STRIKEOUTS THAN
INNINGS, YOU ARE WORKING YOUR
WAY TO LEVERAGE.
RYAN: THAT IS SOMETHING YOU
EARN, TOO.
WHETHER IT BE ON WAIVERS OR JUST
STRAIGHT FREE AGENTS, AND THEY
COME IN AND EARN THEIR SPOTS.
BRIAN: TO HAVE THESE GUYS WITH
THESE NUMBERS, -- WHY ARE YOU
GUYS A LITTLE BETTER THAN HE
SHOULD BE?
HE SAID OUR BULLPEN.
WE HAVE GUYS WHO ARE EARNING IT
OUT THERE.
HIT HARD BY BIGGIO TO RIGHT
FIELD OVER THE HEAD OF HANIGER
AND THAT IS GOING TO DRIVE IN A
RUN AND QUICKLY, THE BLUE JAYS
ARE WITHIN TWO.
THAT WAS QUICK.
SARAH: THAT IS WHY YOU PLAY
MULTIPLE RUNS IN THE TOP OF THE
INNING, RIGHT?
BRIAN: YOU GO TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE ORDER BUT NOW YOU HAVE
LOURDES GURRIEL, WHO HOMERED.
RILEY ADAMS WAS DOUBLED AND YOU
GO TO THE TOP OF THE ORDER AND
YOU KNOW HOW THEY ARE.
THAT IS NICE RIGHT THERE,
GETTING ON TOP OF THE HIGH
FASTBALL.
MARK: KIND OF WONDERING WHAT HE
WAS WAITING ON.
HE GETS ON TOP OF IT AND TRADES
PLACES WITH RANDAL GRICHUK.
GET IT.
BRIAN: STECKENRIDER HAD NINE
CONSECUTIVE SCORELESS INNINGS.
THIS ONE IS NOT BUT IT IS REALLY
NOT HIS FAULT.
IT IS PART OF THE ARTIFICIALITY
OF THIS WHOLE THING.
I KNOW YOU LIKE THAT.
RYAN: THAT DOES NOT COUNT
TOWARDS THE E.R.A.
BRIAN: THAT IS AN UNEARNED RUN.
2-3 IN THE BALLGAME.
GURRIEL HIT THAT TO TIE IT UP.
SCOTT SERVAIS HAS DONE A GOOD
JOB TODAY AND THIS SEASON.
AGAIN, THERE'S A BUNCH OF CLUBS
THAT ARE LITTLE -- A LITTLE
BETTER THAN THE SUM OF THEIR
PARTS.
THE METS, THE GIANTS.
THE METS HAVE HAD ALL THE BIG
PIECES FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS.
THIS YEAR, SUDDENLY, THEY HAVE
GUYS LIKE LUIS GUILLORME A AND
THEY ARE IN FIRST PLACE.
JUST A BIT HIGH.
2-0.
AND A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
PLAYERS -- JONATHAN VILLAR,
DYLAN MOORE, RUNNING AND
FIELDING MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE.
YOU HAVE GUYS WHO BATTLE FOR
NINE INNINGS.
THE MARINERS HAVE A LOT OF THOSE
GUYS AND THAT'S WHY -49 RUN
DIFFERENTIAL AND THEY ARE STILL
ABOVE .500
.
LOOKING TO GET THREE GAMES OVER
THAT IF THEY CAN HOLD ON HERE.
MARK: THE BLUE JAYS THE OPENER
LAST NIGHT 9-3.
THEY WILL FINISH IT UP TOMORROW.
SMOKED THEM AT 95 UP TOP.
RYAN: A LOT OF FASTBALLS, TOO.
60% CHANGEUPS, HIS PITCH USAGE
IN 2021.
THROWS BOTH RIGHTIES AND
LEFTIES.
BRIAN: BLUE JAYS WERE TRYING TO
REACH THE HIGH WATERMARK IN
MID-MAY AND GOT TO 23-17, SIX
GAMES OVER 500 AND THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO THAT AGAIN TONIGHT.
STILL POSSIBLE.
NOBODY OUT.
MAN ON, DOWN BY TWO, SO THAT IS
POTENTIALLY THE TYING RUN AT THE
PLATE.
THE BLUE JAYS AT THE TIME WERE
NOT AS SET A UNIT.
THEY HAD LOST RIGHT AFTER THAT
WHEN THEY WERE SIX ABOVE 500,
THEY LOST SIX IN A ROW.
THERE IS A STRIKEOUT ON GURRIEL.
BIG PITCHED BY STECKENRIDER.
RILEY ADAMS, THE CATCHER,
DOUBLED IN THIS GAME AND WALKED.
HE WILL STEP IN AND COULD NOT
CATCH UP TO IT.
REESE MCGUIRE IS IN.
EXCUSE ME.
HE HAS REPLACED ADAMS.
SO MAGUIRE GETS HIS FIRST
AT-BAT.
AND THEN YOU GET TO THE TOP OF
THE ORDER AND THIS IS PIVOTAL
BECAUSE YOU HAVE VLAD JR..
AFTER THIS.
MARK: AND LISTENING TO THE GAME
LAST NIGHT, REESE MCGUIRE HAD
BEEN SWINGING A HOT BAT.
BRIAN: YOU SEE HIS NUMBERS.
MARK: HE IS NORMALLY IN THE NINE
SPOT IN THE LINEUP AND HE SAID
ALL I AM TRYING TO DO IS GET
SEMIEN TO THE PLATE.
BRIAN: CAVAN BIGGIO ON SECOND
WITH A DOUBLE.
THE R.B.I..
HE IS ABLE TO RIDE THAT
FASTBALL, YOU KNOW?
RYAN: UP IN THE STRIKE ZONE.
BIG PITCH.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE IT RIGHT
HERE, ESPECIALLY AGAINST
LEFTIES.
AND THE 16% MARK WITH THE
CHANGEUP.
MORE TO LEFTIES.
BRIAN: IN THE AIR, NOT TOO DEEP.
JAKE BAUERS BRINGS IT IN AND THE
BLUE JAYS ARE DOWN TO THEIR LAST
OUT.
STECKENRIDER WILL HAVE TO EARN
IT.
MARCUS SEMIEN STEPS UP WITH TWO
OUTS AND A MAN ON.
SCOTT SERVAIS IS CLOSE.
HIS CLUB HAS BEEN VERY GOOD IN
EXTRA INNINGS.
8-1.
THEY WON A LOT OF CLOSE GAMES.
THEIR RECORD IS OUTSTANDING.
SEMIEN, 1-3 WITH A DOUBLE.
HE HAS ALSO WALKED TWICE AND
SIGNED THAT ONE YEAR DEAL WITH
THE BLUE JAYS, REESTABLISHING
HIS VALUES.
I WOULD SAY HIS VALUE IS EVEN
HIGHER.
YOU CAN DUPLICATE THE TYPE OF
YOUR HE HAD WITH THE A'S TWO
YEARS AGO.
FIRST PITCH SWINGING, 0-1.
SARAH: TALKING ABOUT HIM BEFORE.
HE IS WARMING UP.
BRIAN: ADAM CIMBER JUST BROUGHT
OVER FROM THE MARLINS WITH COREY
DICKERSON.
DREW STECKENRIDER TRYING TO
CLOSE THIS OUT.
TWO STRIKES AWAY.
JUST MISSED UP HIGH.
MARK: THEY DON'T MIND ELEVATING
THAT.
RYAN: A LOT OF THE TIME,
ESPECIALLY AGAINST RIGHTIES.
BRIAN: HE IS OVERPOWERING THAT.
HE IS GOING TO PAINT IT RIGHT
THERE AT THE CHEST.
MARK: IT IS 50-50 RIGHT HERE.
HE IS STAYING WITH THE GAS.
BRIAN: MARINERS ARE ONE STRIKE
AWAY.
IN A VERY COMPETITIVE BALLGAME
THROUGHOUT.
WE HAVE BEEN OUT HERE OVER FOUR
HOURS, AND IT HAS GONE BACK AND
FORTH, A REAL BATTLE BETWEEN
THESE TWO CLUBS THAT ARE JUST
OVER 500.
THE 1-2.
AGAIN, TOP OF THE ZONE, AND HE
POPPED HIM UP.
AND THE MARINERS GET THE WIN AND
TAKE GAME TWO IN THIS SERIES.
JUMPED UP ON TOP AND THE THIRD
INNING.
IT WENT BACK AND FORTH.
HOME RUNS ON BOTH SIDES.
LOURDES GURRIEL TIED IT UP.
HOME RUNS FROM DYLAN MOORE.
HOME RUNS FROM KYLE SEAGER.
MITCH HANIGER, WAY BACK.
VOTING IS NOW OPEN TO DECIDE WHO
WILL TAKE HOME THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME HONORS TODAY.
IT COULD BE DYLAN MOORE.
HE HAD TWO SINGLES, STOLEN BASE,
AND A HOME RUN.
DYLAN MOORE, MITCH HANIGER, J.P.
CRAWFORD, KYLE SEAGER.
SCOTT SERVAIS GETS THE WIN.
THAT IS A NICE WIN FOR THE
MARINERS.
THEY HAD TO FIGHT ALL NIGHT.
RYAN: IT WAS GOING TO BE A TOUGH
BATTLE FOR HIM.
ONLY GONE FOUR INNINGS.
THE BULLPEN HAD A COUPLE HICCUPS
BUT HE IS DOING HEAVY LIFTING.
BRIAN: WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK POSTGAME SHOW.
WE ARE ON YOUTUBE.
MARK DEROSA, SARAH LANGS.
WE SAW A WELL PLAYED BALLGAME.
JUST FROM A FAN ASPECT, STRATEGY
ASPECT, WELL-MANAGED.
ENERGY WAS GOOD.
IT WAS A WELL PLAYED,
COMPETITIVE BALLGAME.
SARAH: ABSOLUTELY.
WE GOT TO SEE ALL FACETS OF THE
GAME FROM BOTH TEAMS.
THEY FELT EVENLY MATCHED.
THE MARINERS MAY BE PLAYING
ABOUT WHAT WE MIGHT EXPECT FROM
THEM.
THEM BEING ON PAR WITH THE BLUE
JAYS HERE TODAY IS A PRETTY GOOD
SIGN FOR THEM.
BRIAN: NOW, THEY HAVE WON 8-11.
11-15.
RYAN: ESPECIALLY WHAT THEY ARE
DOING WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION, WE SAW THOSE NUMBERS
AGAIN TONIGHT.
WE SAW SOME PRODUCTION FROM THE
BOTTOM PART OF THE LINEUP.
THAT WAS A SORE SPOT FOR THEM IN
THE MONTH OF APRIL.
A LITTLE BIT MORE LENGTH OUT OF
THAT LINEUP AND THE BULLPEN.
THEY HAD A COUPLE HICCUPS BUT
THEY ARE JUST ABLE TO CARRY THAT
THROUGH THE INNING.
MARK: I CANNOT STOP THINKING
ABOUT J.P. CRAWFORD.
CONSTANTLY ON BASE, CREATING
HAVOC, DOING DIFFERENT THINGS TO
KIND OF SET UP.
LET THOSE YOUNG GUYS -- THAT THE
DYLAN MOORE'S HAVE THEIR BIG
MOMENTS.
BUT IT'S GOT TO BE THE GUYS AT
THE TOP OF THE ORDER KIND OF
TAKING THAT NEXT STEP FORWARD.
THAT IS WHAT I AM SAYING.
BRIAN: 9-1 IN EXTRA INNINGS.
IT IS NOT THAT MUCH OF A SHOCK
GIVEN THAT THEIR BULLPEN IS THAT
TIGHT AND AGAIN, THEY HAVE A LOT
OF WAYS OF BEATING YOUR.
I KEPT MENTIONING ALL THE
SINGLES IN THIS GAME.
IF YOU ARE NOT RELYING ON HOME
RUNS, YOU CAN WIN IN A LOT OF
WAYS.
MARK: HE HIT A BIG THREE RUN
BOMB.
JUSTUS SHEFFIELD, A LITTLE BAND
BUT DON'T BREAK.
TORONTO COULD HAVE KNOCKED HIM
OUT EARLY, BUT THEY DIDN'T.
BRIAN: DYLAN MOORE JOINS US NOW.
BRIAN KENNY HERE WITH SARAH
LANGS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WELL PLAYED GAME.
DYLAN: THANKS.
BRIAN: TELL ME.
YOU WERE TRYING TO ASSESS WHAT
WE SAW HERE.
IT SEEMED VERY COMPETITIVE.
YOU GUYS PLAY A VERY COMPETITIVE
BRAND OF BASEBALL.
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR CLUB NEW
GUYS, EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE BEEN
OUTSCORED ON THE BY AND LARGE
THIS YEAR, YOU ARE A COUPLE OF
GAMES OVER .500.
DYLAN: WE CAN WIN IN A LOT OF
WAYS AND I THINK OUR PITCHING
AND DEFENSE HAVE BEEN ABOVE
AVERAGE THIS YEAR AND THOSE ARE
BOTH A LOT OF GAMES.
YOU HAVE BACK END GUYS THAT CAN
REALLY SHUT IT DOWN, WHETHER WE
ARE UP BY THREE OR ONE AND THAT
HAS REALLY HELPED US OUT THIS
YEAR.
MARK: TAKE ME THROUGH THE HOME
RUN.
3-1 COUNT, TWO SEAMER UP.
YOU WERE ABLE TO PULL YOUR HANDS
IN NICE.
TAKE ME THROUGH PRE-PITCH
ANALYSIS, WHAT YOU WERE TRYING
TO DO.
SARAH: I SAW -- DYLAN: I SAW A
COUPLE OF HEAVY SINKERS DOWN AND
I WANTED TO GET HIS SINKER UP
AND IN THAT COUNT, I AM JUST
TRYING TO OBLITERATE A FASTBALL
OUT AHEAD AND I WAS ABLE TO DO
THAT.
RYAN: YOU HAD A REALLY GOOD YEAR
IN 2020, STRUGGLED IN THE MONTH
OF APRIL, AND YOU HAVE COME
BACK.
YOU JUST LOOK LIKE YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT RHYTHM.
LATELY, YOU HAVE BEEN HITTING
THE BALL WELL, DOING SO MANY
GOOD THINGS.
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
WHAT HAS BEEN THE ADJUSTMENT FOR
YOU?
DYLAN: I KIND OF RELAXED.
I PUT TOO MUCH PRESSURE ON
MYSELF AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR AND DID NOT HANDLE
ADVERSITY WELL.
I NEEDED TO BE HONEST WITH
MYSELF.
I WORKED HARD AT IT AND YOU
KNOW, IT HAS BEEN PAYING OFF
LATELY AND I HOPE I CAN CONTINUE
THAT THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
SARAH: THE HOMER WAS OBVIOUSLY
THE GAME CHANGER HERE,
ABSOLUTELY, BUT WE ALSO SAW YOUR
SPEED REALLY PLAY IN.
HOW MUCH OF A FOCUS IS THAT
STOLEN BASE AND TAKING THOSE
EXTRA BASES?
SARAH: -- DYLAN: IT IS HUGE, NOT
VERY PREVALENT IN TODAY'S GAME
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
DO AND MORE OF MY TEAMMATES CAN
DO SO I THINK WE SHOULD DO MORE.
IT PUTS PRESSURE ON TEAMS AND IT
ALLOWS FOR MAYBE THE PITCHER TO
BE NOT FOCUSED ON THE HITTER AND
IT OPENS UP A LOT OF AREAS I
THINK IN THE GAME AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
BRIAN: WHEN YOU LOOK AT CONTACT,
SPEED, THAT SORT OF THING, WHY
DO YOU THINK YOU GUYS ARE
BETTER?
WE ASKED THIS TO SCOTT SERVAIS
EARLIER.
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU ARE SUCH A
COMPETITIVE CLUB AND YOU ARE
ABLE TO BEAT CLUBS LIKE EARLIER
THIS YEAR?
DYLAN: THANK YOU.
MARK: YOU WON.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU ARE THE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
>> THAT IS AWESOME.
THAT IS AWESOME.
DYLAN: WE ARE A VERY COMPETITIVE
TEAM.
WE BLOCK OUTSIDE NOISE AND SOME
OF OUR LOSSES HAVE BEEN BAD BUT
WE KIND OF RIDE THE WAVE AND
WITH A LOT OF YOUNG GUYS AND
COMPETITIVENESS WITHIN THE TEAM,
IT REALLY SHOWS UP ON THE FIELD
AND I AM HAPPY TO BE PART OF
THIS CLUB.
MARK: IS THERE SOMETHING TO
BEING THE UNDERDOG?
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU GUYS PLAY THAT
WAY, IN A REBUILDING MODE,
GETTING UNDER AFTER -- GETTING
AFTER IT, UNDERFUNDED, BUT ABLE
TO FIGHT WITH THE BIG BOYS.
IS THERE ANYTHING TO DEVELOPING
THAT MINDSET?
DYLAN: I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK IT IS MORE ON FIELD
STAFF.
THERE IS A LOT OF STUFF
THAT YOU CANNOT PAY TOO MUCH
ATTENTION TO OR IT COULD
NEGATIVELY AFFECT THE MINDSET OF
THE CLUBHOUSE OR THINGS LIKE
THAT SO I THINK WE ARE JUST A
YOUNG TEAM, LIKE I SAID, AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF COMPETITIVENESS
AND IT IS SHOWING UP ON THE
HILL.
BRIAN: A PLEASURE WATCHING YOU
PLAY TODAY.
HE REALLY GOT AFTER IT.
YOU EARNED THAT.
AND YOU GUYS EARNED THE WIN
TONIGHT.
CONGRATS, AND GREAT TALKING WITH
YOU.
DYLAN MOORE, PLAYER OF THE GAME,
GETTING THAT STOLEN BASE,
ADVANCED A BUNCH OF TIMES AND
THEN HIT THE THREE RUN BOMB IN
THE 10TH INNING.
WE WILL SAY GOODBYE TO DYLAN
THERE, AND WE WRAP UP.
IT'S A BIG AWARD.
>> RIGHT ON THE MANTLE.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN: HE WAS SURPRISED.
A COUPLE SECOND TAKES.
BRIAN: RIGHT NOW, YOU PUT THAT
--
>> IT IS BETTER TO NOT, ISN'T
IT?
BRIAN: PLAYER OF THE GAME OR
SAUCEPAN ALL THE VOTING.
54 PERCENT.
KYLE SEAGER.
21%, MITCH HANIGER WITH THE
BOMB, AND J.P. CRAWFORD, ACTIVE
THROUGHOUT THE GAME.
A COUPLE OF HITS AS WELL.
TWO SINGLES AND A DOUBLE AND
DYLAN MOORE GOT IT DONE.
THAT WAS IMPRESSIVE.
THERE IS SOMETHING TO THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO KNOW WHERE
THEIR PAYROLL IS BUT I THINK
THERE IS BUT I THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING TO IT.
THEY PLAY A VERSION OF BRAVES
BASEBALL WITH THIS CLUB.
RYAN: THEY REALLY DO.
THERE IS A SCRAPPY ELEMENT TO IT
AS WELL.
THERE IS THE UNDERDOG ELEMENT
AND I REALLY DO THINK GOT SOME
GOOD LEADERSHIP.
YOU TALK ABOUT KYLE SEAGER BEING
ONE OF THESE -- BUT HAVING HIM
-- SOMETHING YOU CANNOT PUT IN
THE NUMBERS.
IT IS INTANGIBLE.
GOOD LEADERSHIP AND THAT YOUNG
GROUP, FULL OF ENERGY.
BRIAN: DYLAN MOORE, GAME-WINNING
HOME RUN IN THE 10TH INNING.
WHEN WE COME BACK, WE WILL HEAR
FROM TOM MURPHY.
JON MOROSI IS IN BUFFALO.
SO WE WILL TAKE A SHORT BREAK.
WE HAVE HIGHLIGHTS OF THIS
BALLGAME, COMING YOUR WAY.
COMPETITIVE BALLGAME, BOTH
MANAGERS GETTING AFTER IT WITH
BULLPEN AGGRESSIVE.
GOT
WE ARE BACK, AFTER THIS.
>> THE BEST DECISION THIS
ORGANIZATION EVER MADE WAS IN
THE JUNE DRAFT OF 1987.
>> WE ARE READY TO GO WITH THE
FIRST ROUND.
THE FIRST ELECTION GOES TO
SEATTLE.
>> THE BALLCLUB WAS STRUGGLING
IN THE NORTHWEST TO PUT
TOGETHER A WINNING TEAM, THAT
THEY NEEDED SOMEBODY TO RALLY
AROUND.
THEY REALLY NEEDED A SUPERSTAR.
>> KEN GRIFFEY JR. HAS TAKEN A
FEW STEPS ON HIS OWN.
THE MAJOR LEAGUE SCOUTING REPORT
SAYS THE KID IS FASTER AND MORE
POWERFUL THAN HIS DAD.
>> I WANT TO GO NUMBER ONE.
THAT WAS A BIG DEAL TO ME.
>> CENTER FIELDER FROM A MOTHER
SCHOOL IN OHIO.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> I FEEL FINE.
>> THERE ARE TWO KEN GRIFFEY IS
IN PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL.
THE MARINERS USING THE NUMBER
ONE PICK IN THE NATION ON A
17-YEAR-OLD CENTER FIELDER WITH
GENES OF A MAJOR LEAGUER.
>> IT'S GOING TO TAKE A FEW
YEARS AND WE ARE NOT GOING TO
RUSH HIM AND WE HOPE THAT IN
FOUR OR FIVE YEARS, HE WILL BE A
STAR PLAYER FOR US.
BRIAN: 9-7, THE FINAL.
JON MOROSI IS THERE WITH -- OF
THE MARINERS.
>> TOM MURPHY PLAYED HIS COLLEGE
BASEBALL AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
BUFFALO.
PROBABLY THE HAPPIEST.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR YOU TO
SHARE THIS WITH HER FAMILY?
TOM: IT IS A HUGE HONOR FOR ME.
FIRST TIME I EVER PLAYED IN THIS
FIELD.
COME HERE AND JUST EXPERIENCE
THIS IN BUFFALO AND HAVE ALL MY
COLLEGE TEAMMATES AND FRIENDS
HERE, IT IS TRULY SPECIAL FOR
ME.
SARAH: YOU ARE 81 GAMES THROUGH
YOUR SEASON.
ANOTHER DRAMATIC EXTRA INNING
WIN FOR YOU THIS SEASON.
JON: WE PLAYED A LOT OF TIE
BALLGAME'S.
WE PLAYED RELATIVELY WELL.
TO DO THAT WITH THE USE THAT WE
HAVE -- THE YOUTH THAT WE
HAVE IS SPECIAL.
WE SHOW A LOT OF HEART.
WE NEVER GIVE UP AND WE ARE JUST
A PLAYER WAY IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY
GAME AND WE ARE DOING WELL.
SARAH: HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE THE
MONTH -- JON: HOW DO YOU
DESCRIBE THE MONTH OF JUNE YOU
JUST HAD?
TOM: HE SHOWS UP EVERY DAY,
READY TO COMPETE.
ONE OF THE BEST TEAMMATES I HAVE
EVER HAD ON OR OFF THE FIELD AND
THIS TYPE OF MONTH IS SOMETHING
THAT IS HUGE FOR HIM
OFFENSIVELY.
DEFENSIVELY, HE IS ALWAYS GOING
TO HAVE A GOOD MONTH.
IT'S TRULY SPECIAL.
>> THE BUNT.
HOW CREATIVE WAS THAT TO SEE
FROM J.P. EARLIER?
>> IT'S NEVER REALLY A SHOCK TO
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN AROUND HIM
WHEN HE DOES SOMETHING CRAZY
LIKE THAT.
BUT I MEAN, IT SPEAKS TO THE
TYPE OF PLAYER HE IS.
IT TRULY DOES.
>> MITCH HANIGER, A HUGE HOME
RUN TONIGHT.
>> THAT GUY MEANS EVERYTHING TO
OUR CLUB.
HE IS OUR BEST PLAYER, OUR
LEADER, AND ONE OF THE BEST
HITTERS IN THE LEAGUE AS WELL.
TO SEE HIM COME BACK AFTER THE
1.5 YEARS HE SPENT AWAY FROM THE
GAME, JUST TRYING TO GET HEALTHY
AGAIN AND DO WHAT HE IS DOING
THIS YEAR, NOTHING BUT PRAISE IS
FOR THAT GUY AND HOW HARD HE HAS
WORKED AND IT IS TRULY A
TESTAMENT TO HIS WILL AND
DETERMINATION.
>> WELCOME BACK TO BUFFALO.
CONGRATULATIONS ON A GREAT WIN
TONIGHT.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
BRIAN: THANK YOU.
LET'S LOOK AT THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
THIS ONE.
>> HERE IS CAVAN BIGGIO.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THAT IS A QUALITY TAKE.
NO, HE DID NOT.
THAT IS THE HIGHLIGHT OF THE
GAME RIGHT THERE.
THAT IS THE BEST MOMENT.
MY DAY IS MADE.
BASES FOR GURRIEL.
PAYOFF PITCH.
LIFTED INTO RIGHT FIELD.
THAT SHOULD BE DEEP ENOUGH.
HANIGER CAN THROW BUT NOT LIKE
THAT.
SPRINGER IS GOING TO SCORE.
GRICHUK GOES INTO THIRD AS WELL.
1-0, BLUE JAYS ON TOP.
MARK: TRAMMELL CAME OVER IN THE
TREVOR BAUER TRADE.
>> ANYTIME HE WANTED TO ON THE
OUTER HALF AND HE WOULD JUST
FORCE YOU TO COMMIT TO IT.
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN HIS M.O.
BRIAN: BALANCING THAT OFF THE
WALL.
ROCKETS.
COMING TO THE PLATE, BICHETTE ON
THE GROUND AND IT IS ALL TIED
UP.
HE BONDS.
YOU HAVE SEEN EVERYTHING.
LOOK AT THIS.
J.P. CRAWFORD.
A RUN SCORES.
WE ARE SEEING SINGLES, BONDS.
BRINGS UP KYLE SEAGER, USING THE
LAST YEAR OF HIS DEAL.
THEY HAVE AN OPTION BUT UNLIKELY
TO PICK THAT UP.
HE HAS BEEN AN OUTSTANDING
PLAYER FOR THIS ORGANIZATION.
3-1.
HIT HARD LEFT FIELD AGAIN.
THAT BALL IS TRAVELING TO LEFT
FIELD AND THAT IS GONE.
BIG TWO RUN SHOT, KYLE SEAGER.
RANDAL GRICHUK STEPS UP, FIRST
AND THIRD NOW.
BASE HIT.
BO BICHETTE WILL SCORE.
CAN THEY GET ANOTHER RUN?
DIVING IN.
GLAD IS IN.
WOW, AND GRICHUK GOES ALL THE
WAY TO THIRD.
VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR., BEAUTIFUL
BASERUNNING.
MARCUS SEMIEN STEPS UP.
THAT BALL IS HIT HARD LEFT FIELD
AND OFF THE WALL.
DID NOT GO OUT.
THAT WILL DRIVE IN A RUN.
>> THIS IS MITCH HANIGER.
>> HIGH FLY BALL, DEEP INTO LEFT
FIELD.
HERNANDEZ GOING BACK, LOOKING UP
INTO THE NIGHT, AND GOODBYE,
BASEBALL.
IT IS WAY OUT OF HERE TO LEFT
FIELD.
>> HANIGER LAUNCHES ANOTHER HOME
RUN.
SARAH: 419 FEET.
>> THE RUNNERS ARE NOW AT FIRST
AND THIRD WITH TWO OUTS AND
LOURDES GURRIEL JR. IS THE
BATTER.
BRIAN: A BASE HIT AROUND.
WE HAVE A 6-5 GAME.
GOOD HITTING BY GURRIEL.
JUMP INTO THESE HIGHLIGHTS.
THERE IS THE BOTTOM OF THE
EIGHTH.
AND HERE IS LOURDES GURRIEL.
FIRST PITCH.
RYAN: SOME GOOD STUFF.
KEEPING THE HANDS INSIDE THAT.
MADE 90'S.
BRIAN: NOT A BAD HIT.
TOP OF THE 10TH, TWO ON, AND
HERE IS DYLAN MOORE, VERY BUSY
ON THE BASE PASS.
MURPHY COMES IN OUT OF THE
BULLPEN.
YOU GOT ALL OF THAT.
HE JUST FLEW RIGHT OUT.
A THREE RUN SHOT.
>> GOOD TO SEE HIM PICKING IT
UP.
BRIAN: CAVAN BIGGIO GET THE BLUE
JAYS BACK.
LEADOFF DOUBLE DRIVES AND A RUN.
TURN INTO THE TOP OF THE ORDER.
BLUE JAYS ARE NOT DONE.
MARK: IMPRESSIVE.
STAYING WITH THE HIGH GAS,
BLOWING PEOPLE AWAY.
MARCUS SEMIEN RIGHT HERE GETS
HIM TO POP UP.
BRIAN: THEY COULD NOT GET ON TOP
OF THAT BASEBALL.
MARK: CAVAN BIGGIO WAS THE ONLY
GUY TO DO IT.
BRIAN: RIGHT IN THE TOP OF THE
ZONE.
COLLECT THE HARDWARE.
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK: FIRED UP.
BRIAN: 9-7.
SO 13 HITS FOR THE MARINERS, 12
FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
A VERY COMPETITIVE GAME, BACK
AND FORTH.
HANIGER HAD THE HOME RUN, AND
THEN MAKE OF THIS WHAT YOU WILL.
9-1 YOU NEXT OR INNINGS.
BEST WINNING PERCENTAGE.
CARDINALS, 3-1 SOMEHOW.
SARAH: OUR COLLEAGUE POINTED
THIS OUT.
THE DODGERS, RAYS, YANKEES, BLUE
JAYS, COMBINED 10-33.
THE MARINERS BY THEMSELVES HAVE
ALMOST AS MANY EXTRA INNING WINS
AS THOSE TEAMS WHICH TELLS US
THAT A LOT OF THESE GAMES ARE
COMING DOWN ALMOST A CHANCE,
EXACTLY WHERE THE BULLPEN IS AT.
BRIAN:
BRIAN: IF STYLE -- IF YOUR
BULLPEN IS SHARP BUT YOU PLAY A
DIFFERENT STYLE, THAT DOES HELP.
THEY PLAY I DON'T WANT TO SAY
SMALL BALL, BUT IT IS AN
AGGRESSIVE STYLE.
>> YES, IT IS.
SCOTT SERVAIS CONSTANTLY TALKS
ABOUT CONTROLLING THE ZONE AND
HAVING GOOD AT-BATS AND ALL
THESE DIFFERENT THINGS, BUT
GOING BACK TO THE PITCHING, TALK
ABOUT THE BULLPEN, A COUPLE OF
THINGS WE SAW TONIGHT, KNOWING
WHO CAN GO MULTIPLE INNINGS,
THAT IS ONE BIG THING.
ALL THESE GUYS, THESE GUYS CAN
GO MULTIPLE INNINGS.
YOU DO HAVE A LITTLE MORE LENGTH
IN THE BULLPEN IF YOU ARE GOING
TO GO EXTRA INNINGS.
>> HE WAS NOT WAITING AROUND
UNTIL THE END OF THE GAME.
HE WAS LIKE, YOU ARE GETTING MY
BIG-TIME STUFF HERE IN THE
SEVENTH.
>> YOU HAVE THE MARINERS NOW
THREE GAMES OVER .500.
IT IS A TALL ORDER TO MAKE A RUN
AT THE ASTROS AND A'S.
THE BLUE JAYS ARE BACK A BUNCH
OF GAMES TOO.
BUT THE MARINERS ARE MAXIMIZING
WHAT THEY HAVE AND SEE US RISE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE SAYING
THERE.
>> I THINK WATCHING THIS GAME,
TORONTO IS GOING TO NEED BULLPEN
HELP IF YOU WATCH THEM GO WHERE
THEY NEED TO IN THE SECOND HALF.
YOU CAN'T EXPECT ANTHONY KAY TO
GIVE YOU MULTIPLE INNINGS.
BRIAN: HE WENT FOUR.
STEVEN MATZ COMING UP THE COVID
LIST AND LOOK SHARP.
HE LOOKS SHARP AND SUDDENLY HE
IS OUT SO THEY HAVE TO GO DEEP
IN THE BULLPEN, BUT I THINK IT
IS WELL PLAYED ON SCOTT
SERVAIS'S PART.
JUST IN SHEFFIELD DANCES
THROUGH, BUT SHARK WHILE WITH
ONE, -- CHART WHILE -- CHARGOIS
WITH ONE.
IT IS A LIST HE IS GOING
THROUGH.
>> ONE THING HE IS ABLE TO DO IS
GO MULTIPLE INNINGS, AND THERE
IS SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THAT.
WE MAYBE SAW THAT TREND A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WITH, WHAT'S HIS NAME,
DEVENSKI WITH THE HOUSTON ASTROS
, BUT LOOK, YOU HAVE SOME OF
THESE GUYS WHO ARE HAVING A
SECOND CHANCE.
THAT HELPS OUT IN THESE EXTRA
INNING GAMES.
>> COMING UP, WE'VE GOT MIKE
TOP WITH TY FRANCE.
LESS TALKATIVE LATE IN THE GAME.
IMAGINE THAT.
TEOSCAR HERNANDEZ ALSOFRANCE GO.
WE WILL LISTEN IN TO THAT COMING
UP.
>> WE OPEN UP THE YEAR IN
OAKLAND, AND HERE HE IS.
HE'S WALKING UP HOME PLATE FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
>> DRIVING TO LEFT CENTER FIELD,
AND HE REALLY HIT IT.
IN GRIFFEY JUNIOR HAS A BASE IT
ON HIS FIRST AT-BAT IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
IT DOES NOT TAKE HIM LONG TO
SHOW THE BIG LEAGUE GUYS HE CAN
SWING THE BAT.
>> JUNIOR STARTED OFF ON THE
ROAD AND NOW THEY ARE IN THE
KING DOME.
THIS PLACE WAS EXCITED TO SEE
THIS 19-YEAR-OLD KID.
WHO WAS THIS KID?
>> THERE ARE SO MANY CHALLENGES
BEING A YOUNG PHENOM, AND
EVERYBODY IS SAYING --
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO BE A TEENAGER, TO BE A
PHENOM, AND THEN TO BE DRAFTED
NUMBER ONE TO A FRANCHISE,
SAYING, LISTEN, YOU ARE OUR LAST
HOPE.
>> 25 YEARS FROM NOW, YOU ARE
GOING TO WANT TO SAY I WAS THERE
WHEN KEN GRIFFEY JR. MADE HIS
OWN DEBUT.
>> GOODBYE, HIS FIRST SWING OF
THE KINGDOM.
-- KING DOME.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> SECONDARY HITTING COACH.
PRIMARY HITTING COACH.
>> EL FUERTE!
>> EVERYBODY STAY AWAY FROM ME
NOW.
OK.
>> COACH CARSON, COACH CARSON --
>> GOOD PENMANSHIP.
YESTERDAY WAS HORRIBLE.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> GREAT.
>> LOTS OF FASTBALLS DOWN THE
MIDDLE, OK?
>> I CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
>> WHICH ONE OF YOU GUYS IS
MIGHT UP?
>> TEOSCAR?
>> I AM MIKED UP.
>> HELLO.
>> CAREFUL, HOT MIC.
NO ENGLISH FOR ME TODAY, MAN.
ME DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH.
HOW ARE YOU DOING, RATHER?
-- BROTHER?
GOOD.
>> HE AIN'T THAT OLD YET.
>> I AM GOING TO BE 32 IN
SEPTEMBER.
I'M WORKING WITH A LOT OF ADVIL
RIGHT NOW.
A LOT OF ADVIL AND PAIN-OFF.
IT COULD BE WORSE.
WE COULD BE SITTING AT A DESK.
IT MAKES YOU THINK.
WHAT WOULD YOU BE DOING IF YOU
ARE PLAYING BASEBALL?
>> I WOULD PROBABLY BE A BUM OR
PLAYING GOLF.
>> STAY HIGH TO YOUTUBE.
-- STAY -- SAY HI TO YOUTUBE.
>> HI.
>> DID YOU FIND THAT IN YOUR BAG
FROM LAST YEAR?
>> JOSEPH GAVE IT TO ME
YESTERDAY.
I TOLD HIM TO GIVE ME ONE AND HE
BROUGHT THREE.
>> NOW YOU'VE GOT TO STEAL
SECOND.
YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE SECOND.
FIRST MOVE.
I WILL TELL HIM NOT TO PICK OFF.
>> START BALL?
-- DIRT BALL?
OK.
YOU'VE GOT TO DIG.
HE JUST TOLD ME GOOD CHICK IS
GOING TO HIT A DOUBLE AND I AM
GOING TO SCORE FROM FIRST.
THAT IS WHAT HE TOLD ME.
A MAN OF HIS WORD.
WE GET TO COME BACK AND DO THIS
IN A COUPLE HOURS.
ENJOY YOUR NAP AND THEN COME
BACK.
BRIAN: HE IS A CHATTY FELLOW.
IS THAT ME?
I'VE GOT TO GO.
>> TIME TO WAKE UP.
BRIAN: I DID NOT KNOW TY FRANCE
HAD THAT PERSONALITY.
>> EVERYBODY AT FIRST BASE
KNOWS.
BRIAN: HE IS CHATTING THEM UP
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
FRANCE HAS BEEN PRETTY GOOD.
IF YOU ARE SLUGGING .639 --
ALSO, I KEEP POINTING OUT, 34TH
ROUND PICK, SO HE DOES KIND OF
HAVE THAT LOVE OF LIFE.
THIS IS GREAT, I'M IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES AND HITTING WELL.
>> YOU CAN TELL HE HAS ALWAYS
HIT.
HE PROBABLY MATCHED WHEN HE WAS
A YOUNG BOY, HIGH SCHOOL,
COLLEGE, ALL THE WAY UP.
EVENTUALLY FIND A POSITION FOR
YOU, JOURNEYMAN KIND OF
DEFENDER, AND NOW HE IS SITTING
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE MARINERS
LINEUP, WIRED FOR SOUND.
BRIAN: STATCAST THREE IS POWERED
BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
HERE WE GO.
HERE ARE THE HITS TONIGHT FROM
THE MARINERS.
14 SINGLES.
THEY SAY THE SINGLE IS DEAD.
MARINERS HAVE EIGHT OF THEM, BUT
SARAH, YOU ARE SAYING IT IS
NOWHERE NEAR THE HIGH POINT FOR
SINGLES IN A SINGLE GAME THIS
YEAR?
SARAH: NO, THE MOST SINGLES
COMBINED AND AGAIN THIS YEAR IS
24, 2 NAMES WITH 24.
I DOUBLE CHECKED THE BOX SCORES.
IT SOUNDED LIKE A LOT, BUT --
>> THAT'S SMALL BALL.
HAROLD REYNOLDS WOULD LOVE THAT.
>> THESE ANALYTICS DEPARTMENTS
DO NOT DO THEIR JOB.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
BRIAN: YOU'VE GOT TO SWING LIKE
THIS.
LAUNCHED THAT BALL, GET THAT
OUT.
I STILL THINK THE BLUE JAYS ARE
GOING SOMEWHERE.
WITHIN THAT DIVISION.
MAYBE YOU ARE RIGHT, THE
ROTATION IS NOT A LEGION OF.
HOWEVER, HE WAS GREAT IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE?
ASTROS ARE GOOD.
I DO NOT THINK THEY ARE GREAT.
THIS OFFENSE IS GREAT.
I KNOW THE BLUE JAYS LOST
TONIGHT, A CLOSE GAME, BUT THEY
ARE GETTING BETTER MONTH BY
MONTH.
>> I THINK YOU NEED TO LOGIN ON
THE ASTROS MORE BECAUSE THE
STARTERS ARE PRETTY NAILS, AND
TWO OF THOSE GUYS ARE GOING TO
GO IN THEIR BULLPEN BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN PIGGYBACKING WHEN
ODORIZZI CAME BACK OFF THE I.L.
YOU CAN ALWAYS PUT ONE OF THOSE
GUYS IN THE PEN.
I JUST THINK OF A FIVE-GAME
SERIES, WHO IS GETTING A BALL?
AM I DRIVING A YARD?
I MIGHT HAVE TO BASH IF I AM
TORONTO.
AM I GOING TO HAVE TO SCORE FIVE
OR SIX RUNS.
BRIAN: RYU WAS A GOOD START.
MARK: NO DOUBT.
I WAS GOING TO MAKE THAT POINT
DURING THE BROADCAST.
I PLATE NUMBER MARK SHAPIRO IN
CLEVELAND FOR THREE MONTHS.
THIS GUY GETS IT.
WHEN THEY FIRST SIGNED RYU, I
BLEW MY HAIR BACK.
THAT IS BIG MONEY TO GO TO THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE EAST AFTER
PITCHING FOR THE DODGERS.
HE HAS BEEN AWESOME FOR TORONTO.
BRIAN: AND ROBBIE RAY'S TOO.
AT HIS HEIGHT, HE IS DYNAMITE.
I JUST DON'T HAVE A LOT OF FAITH
IN THE RED SOX WITH THE
ROTATION.
THE YANKEES, WE SEE WHAT IS
THERE, AND THE RAYS MIGHT END UP
-- WE KNOW WHAT THEY CAN DO.
MARK: THEY ARE GOING TO STAY IN
THE FIGHT ALL YEAR, BUT I WOULD
BE STUNNED IF THEY ARE GOING TO
WIN THAT DIVISION.
LAST NOW IS CLAIMING HE IS GOING
TO COME BACK.
-- GLASNOW IS CLAIMING HE IS
GOING TO COME BACK, I WOULD NOT
HOLD MY BREATH ON THAT.
BRIAN: WANDER FRANCO, HAVE YOU
GOTTEN A GOOD LOOK AT THAT GUY?
RYAN: I HAVE NOT SEEN A LOT OF
HIM, JUST TRYING TO TRACK SOME
OF THESE NUMBERS.
IT WASN'T HE IN A ROLLS-ROYCE OR
A TINLEY OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
BRIAN: THREE RUN BOMB IN THE
TANK, KIND OF LIKE KELENIC.
RYAN: I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO
BE THE SAME AS KELENIC.
LAUNCHED HIS OWN CLOTHING LINE.
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
MARK: WHAT IS CRAZY AS I ROCKED
HIM BECAUSE GILBERT WAS MAKING
THAT START -- WAS I LOCKED IN
BECAUSE GILBERT WAS MAKING THAT
START.
THE QUALITY OF THOSE AT-BATS,
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS NOT GETTING
HITS, I WAS LIKE, HE IS GOING TO
BE FINE.
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'VE GOT TO
CARRY THE WEIGHT OF THE WORLD.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN IN THAT
POSITION AS AN UBER PROSPECT.
BRIAN: WHO WINS THE A.L. EAST
THIS YEAR?
YOU HAVE ONE PICK.
SARAH: I AM STILL GOING TO GO
WITH THE RAYS, BUT ALL OF THESE
TEAMS ARE FLAWED, BUT I AM GOING
TO GO WITH THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE
THERE RIGHT NOW.
BRIAN: IF I AM A BETTING MAN, I
WOULD GO WITH THE RAYS, BUT I
THINK THE BLUE JAYS ARE GOING TO
BE THERE.
SHOUT OUT -- COME ON AND VISIT
US IN SECAUCUS.
IT IS FUN TO WATCH.
WHO WINS THE A.L. EAST?
RYAN: I'M GOING TO GO WITH THE
BLUE JAYS.
PICK UP SOME BULLPEN PIECES.
I HEAR YOU ABOUT THE STARTING
PITCHING.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
ENOUGH, PICK UP BULLPEN PIECES.
BRIAN: I THINK THEY HAVE A BIG
SECOND HALF.
THE RAYS, THERE IS SOMETHING
STILL HAPPENING.
I HAVE DONE SOMETHING ON THE
RAYS THIS YEAR.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS IS
HAPPENING, BUT IT DOES.
IT IS RIGHT IN YOUR FACE.
BRIAN: GIVE THEM CREDIT, THE
MARINERS SWEPT THE RACE, TOOK
FOUR ON THEM IN A ROOM.
THAT SHOWS YOU THEIR PITCH BY
PITCH GRIT AND COMPETITIVENESS.
I HOPE YOU ENJOYED IT HERE.
I DID TOO.
DERO, THANK YOU.
SARAH, AS ALWAYS, GREAT HAVING
YOU.
AND RYAN, A PLEASURE, GREAT
HAVING YOU.
WE HAVE NOT CALLED AGAIN
TOGETHER, AND THAT WAS A REAL
BLAST.
IT WAS A FUN GAME.
HOME RUNS ALL AROUND.
SHEFFIELD SURVIVED.
I WONDER IF THEY HAVE A QUALITY
TAKE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
ROLLOUT.
THAT WOULD BE VERY BASEBALL-Y.
REDS AND BREWERS JULY 9, OUR
NEXT YOUTUBE GAME.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
BRIAN: 9-7, MARINERS GET THE
WIN, WILL PLAY THE THIRD OF
THREE TOMORROW, SPLIT THESE
FIRST TWO.
IT HAS BEEN A PLEASURE.
HOPE YOU ENJOYED
YOU ARE WATCHING OUR YOUTUBE
GAME OF THE WEEK.
WE WILL SEE YOU ON JULY 9.